TO ORDER. HI GOOD MORNING HI IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SHE WON-
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY-
I REMEMBER ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY IS SENATOR MORALE THE
VICE CHAIR OF OUR COMMITTEE AND
SENATOR MORALE WE HOUSE THAT IF
YOU HAVE A STAFF WITH YOU TRIED.
THAT STAFF NOW. I DO AND HER
NAME IS MELISSA BOYD AND SHE'S
IN THE OTHER ROOM IF YOU'D LIKE
HER TO COME IN AND ARE FIGHTING.
IDENTIFYING HER SUFFICIENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER AND
CENTERMAN ARE MY- OF MOVE
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE BILLS OR
COULD THIS GREATLY AID A
LIMITED AND YOUR FEEDBACK. ON
MY OUTSIDE EVERY TIME WISH TO
BE SO YOU YOU THE YOUR HANDS
FEATURE THE PROGRAM EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING YOU. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE- YOU WILL THEN-
SELECT OPTION BEFORE BEGINNING
TO SPEAK- ARE I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN
YOU ARE DONE ONE SECOND SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THIS AND- STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU ALREADY TO
ADDRESS COMMITTEE. HI TO ALLOW
PUBLIC I. FOR WAITED MEMBERS OF
THE- TO HEARING TO THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIRE ALLOW. TIME
WILL BE USING IT. SERVICE FOR
IT IN THE- WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL WISHING TO HOPE
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANTS FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT CALL IN NUMBER IS.
1-844-291-6364 ONCE AGAIN ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS NINE FIVE ONE
SIX THREE EIGHT NINE. ONCE
AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS NINE
FIVE ONE. SIX THREE EIGHT NINE
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS.
RIGHT INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TIME WORKS YOU
CAN REFER. TO THE SENATE
WEBSITE OR THE SECURITIES UP.
FOLLOWING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A- TO
ONE THEN ZERO. TO EXPRESS A- OR
UP PRESS THERE'S ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER- THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE.
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON YOU DID WHEN YOU WILL BE
READY TO ADDRESS. THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST TO MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON SUCH AS
A COMPUTER. OR TELEVISION PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU- AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
EVENT INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
EFFORT MADE TO STREAM THE
PROCESS. THANK INDUCT HEARING
AS IT US KERR TO THE SAME. AS
CUTS. THERE MAY BE SOME LACKS
FOR. WHO WERE ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW USE. OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD- I ALSO WANT TO MENTION
THAT WE WILL BE TAKING A HALF
HOUR RECESS. AT ONE PM TODAY-
AROUND. THE LUNCH HOUR SO ONE
PM. I WAS WE- AND THEY'LL BE
ARBIL HEARING THERE ARE FOUR
BILL ON ASIA TODAY I DO WANT TO
MAKE A COUPLE OF AN- BUT FIVE
THREE PIECE OF LEGISLATION ARE
BEING REMOVED FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA- AB. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. THIRTY
ONE OH SEVEN SO IT'S SEVENTY
NINE. AND THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN
BOTH BY ASSEMBLY BLOOM. ARE
BEING REMOVED FROM THE AGENDA
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
IN ADDITION AB THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED BY SOME NUMBER
SANTIAGO- IS ALSO BEING REMOVED
FROM THE AGENDA SO FOR THESE
THREE BILLS AB TWELVE SEVENTY
NINE SB THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN AND
AB THIRTY THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM THE
AGENDA THEY WILL NOT BE HEARD
TODAY FOR ANYONE WHO MIGHT BE
ON THE PHONE ONE IN THE
TESTIFIED. HI ADDITION WE HAVE
BILL. ON CONSENT. AB EIGHT
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE. AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE. TEN AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY. ONE OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE FIRST ITEM ON
TODAY'S AGENDA AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WILL NOT BE HEARD FIRST.
IT WILL BE HEARD LATER IN THE
AGENDA SO- BEFORE I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A QUORUM- AND SO WE WILL
NOW NOT CALL THE ROLL. THE
MICROPHONE MICROPHONES OUT ON.
ALL THE CONSULTANTS MICROPHONE
IS NOT ON. CENTER WINNER.
SENATOR WIENER. THREE CENTER
WINNER. TESTING OKAY SENATOR
WIENER PRESIDENT WINNER PRESENT
SENATOR MORALE WELL PRESENT IN
HERE WELL PRESENT SENATOR BATES.
HERE CAN YOU SAY ON MIKE PLEASE.
THE SALE. WHERE TO STAY HERE
HERE SENATOR BATES HERE CAFIERO.
THERE CABALLERO HERE TORONTO
HERE TO READ SO HERE MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK READ MORE LOT PRESENT
ROSS ROSS HERE SKINNER. SKINNER
HERE I'M BURKE. CASKEY HERE BUT
ASK HERE WE HAVE A CAR. I THANK
YOU FOR HAS BEENESTABLISHED
WE'RE NOW GOING TO I NUMBER TWO
BY WITH A. SIXTY NINE. I
BELIEVE I AM PRESENTING THIS
BILL. THAT WILL BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR SKINNER SO CENTER
SKINNER YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF
THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH MANY
BILLS INCLUDING BY OUR
COLLEAGUE. FROM FREMONT AND
ACTUALLY FROM THIS AUTHOR FROM
SAN CISCO AND OTHER-
LEGISLATION EIGHTY USE FOR
SECOND UNITS BACKYARD COTTAGES
HAVE BECOME A MUCH MORE WELCOME
TO- EMBRACED AND- UTILIZED FORM
OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA IT IN
FACT. IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS THERE
WERE MORE PERMITS PULLED FOR
EIGHTY USE THAN ANY OTHER
SOURCE OF HOUSING. NOW IT IS IN
OUR INTEREST GIVEN OUR HOUSING
CRISIS AND OUR JOBS CRISIS TO
ENCOURAGE THE BUILDING OF
EIGHTY USE. THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THERE ARE OBSTACLES IN THE
AVAILABLE FINANCING TOOLS THAT
ARE PREVENTING MANY HOMEOWNERS
FROM BEING ABLE TO GET THE
FINANCING THAT THEY WOULD NEED.
TO PURSUE THEIR PLANS TO BUILD
AN EIGHTY YOU WHAT AB SIXTY
NINE DOES IS IT HELPS
HOMEOWNERS CREATE AT LEAST
FIFTY THOUSAND EIGHTY USE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. OR OTHER SMALL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS SO IN
OTHER WORDS UNITS OF DELETED
WITH A SINGLE FAMILY HOME. OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. AND IT
ADDRESSES THESE ROAD. TO THE
EXISTING FINANCING BY CREATING
A FINANCING MECHANISM. THAT OF
THAT THE HOMEOWNER'S CAN USE TO
ACCESS BRIDGE LOANS TO PAY FOR
AN EIGHTY YOU OR DUPLEX PROJECT
THE TREASURER IS OUR TREASURER.
FIONNA MAS OFFICES- WOULD
ADMINISTER THIS AND IS THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT WHO IS ARE THE STATE
TREASURER FIONA MA IN THE
TREASURE SCHAFER. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH US ARE SKINNER WE
WILL NOW HEAR FROM OUR EARLY
WITNESS ON BEHALF OF TREASURER
MA WILL BE TIM SCHAFER WHO WAS.
KILLED DEPUTY TREASURER BY
MISTER SCHAPER. SHARE AND-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR MORALE- FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF THE- OUTLINE OF
THE BILL I'M GOING TO DEFER TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AND MR
CASEY O'CONNOR WHO WAS ON THE
TELEPHONE WITH US NOW GO AHEAD
CASEY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SO OF THE COMMITTEE
YES THANK YOU I DON'T TREASURE
SHAPER FOR BEING ON THE
HEALTHCARE ANY TECHNICAL. MY
NAME IS CONNOR I AM YOUR YOUR
MOTHER DIRECTOR TREASURY IS
PROUD TO COAST A THINKING NINE
BOB AND I ASSEMBLY JAY WHICH
WERE CREATE AN EFFECTIVE. I
DON'T HANDLE THE RED. AROUND
THE FINAL OF DEFENSE WILLING
YOU KNOW TOWARDS TODAY THE
TREASURE IN HER IS. FOR
IMPORTANT PRO. DEVELOPMENT
THAT'S THREE DRAWING AND- ALSO
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS GRANNY
FLAT. AB SIXTY NINE OKAY IS
UNLESS. BUT DON'T. ALL OF OUR
GREAT PEOPLE ALSO. OF MAKING
HOUSING AFFORDABLE ACROSS THE
LINE WHAT THE TOWN BOARD. WHICH
MANY INVEST OF STATE. THIS
FINANCING PROGRAM LOBBYIST IN
TO THE BOOK PENDA. AS FAMILY
MEMBER WILL NEED TO BE TO ONE
ANOTHER TO OFFER CARE TO ALL
RELATIVE. BUT CHILD CARE DURING
THESE TRYING. OR SIMPLY BECAUSE
OUR REAL WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO
LET WITH THEIR OWN DIE
ROCKETING HOUSING COSTS IN BIG
INCOMES. WELL OR PERMITTING
THAT. AT EIGHTY YEARS FORTY TO
THREE TWO UNIT IN OUR STATE.
CELERY EVERYTHING YEARS BUT
THEN THE BY THE FOR THE LAGGING
AND- X. THREE DRAWING UNIT ON
NUMER AND- I THEY ARE. OF THEY
DO NOT REQUIRE THE APPLE OF
THAT STREET NEWLY PARK. NOR DID
IT REQUIRE. LOCAL TO SUPPORT
THAT. THE FINANCING PLAN BY ABC
NINE AT THE DRIVEN OF WELL
ESTABLISH HOW THE- THAT'S DONE.
GOING TO BE A FACTOR AND WHICH-
ONLY SMALL I. BY THE MORE BY
COMMUNITY. THAT WE EXPAND OUR
PORTAL HOW NOT AND BILLED YOU
JEFF THAT SO WITH THAT SAID THE
TREASURE AT OUR TEAM LIKE TO
OUR TO MEMBER PAIN IN ENTER
THEIR LEADERSHIP IN THE AREA.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT I
LOVE TO SUPPORT THE PROCESS OF
WORKING OP. FOR CALIFORNIANS
TANK YOU. THANK YOU. APPLE
THAT IS OUR ONLY LEAVE WHEN S.
BUT THERE ONE MORE YES THAT'S
OUR- FRAZIER WAS FOR SHE'S NOT
ON THE LINE DON'T BELIEVE SHE
IS OKAY OKAY THAT'S R. O. WHEN
I HAS OUT MOVE. TO A OTHERS
WANTING TO IN SUPPORT BY TWO TO
CONSTRAINTS THE OF HERE. TECHNO
CANAND CLEANING PRODUCTS.
COMMITTEE CHAIRS RIGHT TIMELINE
ON TESTIMONY- BY EACH SIDE WILL
BE PERMITTED- AN EQUAL AMOUNT
OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED-
BRIDGE BUILT ON ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
THE PHILLIES IN A POSITION ON
THE MEASURES- AND SERVE WE ASK
MEMBERS A PUBLIC PURPOSE AND
OTHER BILLS. TO LET THEY'RE NOT
BE WHEN AS B. ST. L. A. BUT
BUILT SO WE WANT BEGAN AND IF
THERE ARE ANY WITH THE HERE AND
THE GAL AND SOME OF AB NINE.
SAYING NINE WE WERE NOW LOOK TO
SEE IF ANY WITNESS IN ROOM
FORTY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY
NINE. THERE ARE NONE. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO WIN THE SAYS
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARE US- THE
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND
WE WILL GO TO OUR FIRST LINE.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I THANK TWENTY
THREE LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE
A TIME YOU. AND WE WILL CALL ON
THE NEXT LINE OF SIXTY SEVEN
SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE-
CRYING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YIMBY IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND OUR NEXT LINE IS FIFTY
FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS SENATOR WIENER
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
WAS JACK GARDNER I'M A RESIDENT
OF BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE JOHNSON YOUR
COMPANY I SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT LINE
WILL COME FROM SIXTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JOSE TREND THAT HAPPEN YEAH.
THE FOUNDER OF YOUNG VOICE IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND ADDED THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LISTENING TO
THIS BILL. I MEAN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I NEXT FINAL
COMPANY FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS-
CHRIS FOR CARLISLE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND OUR
NEXT PLAN WILL COME FROM FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
ASSIST KEEP DONE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I CLIENTS FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND OUR NEXT
LINE WILL BE SIXTY EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PIETIST YOU MIGHT A BETTER LOOK
AT THE AREA COUNCIL AND AS A CO
SPONSOR AT EIGHTY SIXTY NINE
WHERE YOU'RE INTRACTABLE. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT LINE. NINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE OF. TWENTY
THREE A LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
LEVINE SENATE FINANCE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BETTER
HEARING MEMBERS OF THE ERIN
EVANS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY OF CALIFORNIA COURT
THANK YOU. YOU CAN. LINE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS ADAM RAMALINA OF
MAKING HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
HAPPEN AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTY NINE AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH. I THINK THAT. AND OUR
LAST TWENTY Q. IT FROM A LINE
OF TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MEETING WITH WHITE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN ON BEHALF OF
THE DIFFERENT. BAY AREA URBAN
PLANNING IN RETURN ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND THEY
ARE NO SUPPORT QUESTIONS QUEUE
CAN YOU PLEASE JUST MAKE FOR
REQUEST. CHECK IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND THEN
EXPLAIN WILL COME FROM FIFTY
FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SO MY
MISTAKE THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A
FEW MOMENTS ONE MOMENT HERE. I
NEXT COME FROM SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH FRAN. I'M
WORKING COMPANY. AB INTERNET
NUMBER IS THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS HAS ALIGNED
WITH GENERATION HOUSING BASED
ON THE COUNTY AND WE ARE ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT LINE IS
NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE THIS IS BRITNEY
SONG CORRECTOR THE NAPA
CANNELLA EIGHTIES. ACCORDING TO
THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S
ONE MORE TIME SINCE WE HAD
SOME- ADDITIONAL LAST TIME. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. NO
ONE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVES TO ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTY NINE- IS
THERE ANYONE IN- THE CHAMBERS
WHO OPPOSES SB SIXTY NINE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK I SEE NO. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO ROOM TO TWENTY
FORTY- IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE AB SIXTY NINE- I SEE NO
ONE THERE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OUR MODERATOR
PLEASE. DETERMINE IF THERE ARE
ANY OPPONENTS OF AB SIXTY NINE
WAITING TO SPEAK. YES IF YOU
ARE IN A POSITION OF AB SIXTY
NINETY MY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
IN ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. OUR
LINE WILL COME FROM WELL YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HI MY NAME
IS MARK FROM COMMUNITIES UNITED
EIGHTY SEVEN THE HUNGER. THANK
YOU FOR LETTING US SPEAK ALL WE
LIVE IN A VERY HIGH FIRE- HOUSE
CHILD. AND WE ALL HAD A JERRY
DIFFICULT TO EVACUATING DURING
THE MULTIPLE FIRES WE HAD AND
WE HAVE ALREADY HAD TO FIGHT IT
HERE I'VE BEEN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BECAUSE
OF THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND I CAUGHT ONE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I BELIEVE I
GET IN ON THE WRONG BILL.
TWENTY FIFTY COULD BOB THIS TO
ANOTHER ONE. OKAY THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN CUBA
STRUCTURE. BAKER TOOK ONE LAST
TIME. SURE IT HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SIX NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND
NO IN A FEW OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE CONCLUDES THE
OPPOSITION BY TESTIMONY WHEN
THEY'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- OR DOANY MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS COMMENTS SENATOR
CABALLERO FOLLOWED BY SEN
THEY'RE AWESOME. AND LIKE A
BETTER COME COMING. THINK
HEARING. MR TO ON THE COMMITTEE
LET ME JUST SAY THAT I AM
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S.
WORK IN THIS AREA HAS DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB- MOVING THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF EIGHTY USE THAT
NOW TO HELP. FINANCING IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT-
COMMITTEE. RAISED SOME CONCERNS
AND I APOLOGIZE TO- CENTER
SKINNER- I IN REGARDS TO THESE
BUT- YOU'RE NOT THE AUTHOR BUT
YOU'RE- DOING THE PRESENTATION
SO ON MY CONCERNS HAVE TO DO
WITH A NUMBER OF THE ITEMS THAT
WERE LISTED. ONE I'M CONCERNED
THAT- THAT THIS PROGRAM WORKS
AND IS AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES AND IN PARTICULAR
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES. THERE'S A
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS NEED
PROBLEM AND THEN THERE WAS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT. HE APA L.
AND- THAT DAD. IF THAT'S THE
CASE IT'S GONNA TAKE A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME TO COME UP WITH
THE RULES IT'LL GOVERNESS- AND
THE REASON THAT THE A. P.
BECOMES REALLY IMPORTANT IS
THERE SOME COMMUNITIES. FROM
THAT HAVE PRINT CIRCUMSTANCE
AND ARE GONNA NEED TO
PARTICIPATE IN HOW THIS GETS
CREATED AND IT UNLESS YOU HAVE
A VIBRANT PUBLIC OUTREACH
PROCESS- YOU DON'T GET THE- THE
INPUT AND THEN THE NEED. VERY
COMMUNITIES AN IMPORTANT MANY
OF MY- SO BE THEME FOR TODAY IS
THAT I HAVE A TWENTY SEVEN
CITIES AND- FOR THOSE CITIES
ARE LARGER THAN FORTY THOUSAND
THE REST ARE WAY BELOW I HAVE A
COUPLE THAT ARE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
RESIDENTS AND SO WHAT WORKS IN
A BIG CITY DOESN'T NECESSARILY.
IN THOSE DAYS BUT THE GREAT
HOUSING. IS PARTICULAR
AFFORDABLE. THOSE ARE I
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT HE'S
TRYING TO DOING THIS BUT I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT THOSE ARE KIND
OF IMPORTANT TO ME AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. TENER
SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND YES MAY I. SO I AM A-
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. IT IS AN
AB BUT I AM A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR. END OF. WORKING THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE AND CAL HFA
ON IT IN SO.I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD RESPOND IS THAT. THE LAWS
THAT HAVE. HELPED ENCOURAGE AND
MAKE IT EASIER TO BILL EIGHTY
USE. HAVE BEEN PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN OUR STATEWIDE.
AND THEY ARE NOT SPECIFIC TO.
FOR DO NOT DISCRIMINATE THE
BASS PLAYER ENCOURAGE. FOR
EVERYONE WHAT THIS. IS A
FINANCING BILL. ANY CAN THIS
FINANCING TO. AS I UNDERSTAND
IT. WOULD NOT BE IN THE I SAY
AS I UNDERSTAND IT. BETTER. CAN
SORRY. WOULD BE ONE THAT AGAIN
IS NOT IS AVAILABLE TO ANY HOW
AND REASON IT'S NECESSARY IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE HOMEOWNERS
ESPECIALLY UNFORTUNATELY LOW
INCOME HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE A
GREAT ASSET OF THEIR HOME WITH
GREAT EQUITY BUT THEY MAY NOT
HAVE GREAT CREDIT. AND BECAUSE
OF THEIR NON HAVING GREAT
CREDIT THE USUAL FINANCING
TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM-
BUT BECAUSE THE IMPROVEMENT IS
THE IMPROVEMENT TO THE HOME
IMPROVEMENT IS WILL HAVE LITTLE
INCREASE THE VALUE OF THE HOME
SO WE'RE TRYING TO. GET OUR TOP
BILLS BY FINANCING TOOL FOR
EXACTLY THAT COMMUNITIES THAT
MOST NEED SO I THINK THAT SOME
OF THE CONCERNS YOU'RE
EXPRESSING WOULD BE ADDRESSED.
THIS IS WHAT I DID NOT MENTION
IN MY OPENING IS AT. ALL THE
TREASURES OFFICE IS PLAYING A
ROLE WOULD BE DONE IN YOUR SHIP
WITH H. C. D. AND CAL J. AND US
BEFORE OFTEN. OKAY CLOSE DRAWS
FIRST PUBLISHED. US CORRECTLY
RELATED TO THE S. I WAS I'M ALL
CO AUTHOR ON THIS IN PART OF
THE IT MAY PROCEDURE FOR THAT
THE REACHED THE POINT. THIS IS
THE PRESSURES REPRESENTATIVE
NOTED THIS IS A DERIVATIVE OF
EXISTING LOAN PROGRAMS SO FOR
THE- AUTHORS BELIEVE THAT IT'S
CAPTURED IN THE PROGRAMS ARE
GOING WE'RE NOT WE'RE CREATING
THESE BRIDGE PLANS THE PRIVATE
LENDERS ARE GOING TO BE THE
ONES WHO ARE ULTIMATELY GOING
TO GIVE GIVE THEM UP. I THINK
THE MONEY PEOPLE HAVE WHAT
WOULD EITHER HAVE INCOME
THEY'RE NOT GONNA USE THIS
PROGRAM HAZARDOUS GOING TO GO
OUT AND PAY FOR THE EIGHTY YOU
ARE GO TO WELLS FARGO AND GET
IT IT'S GOING TO BE THAT SECOND
TIER BY DEFINITION ARE THE ONES
THAT. ARE GETTING THOSE LOANS
AND DATE ON PAPER DON'T QUALIFY
THROUGH THE PRIVATE LNDER
STILL HAVE TO QUALIFY THEM BUT
WE'RE GOING TO. GIVE THAT
GUARANTEE SO THAT THEY CAN DROP
A LOAN AND NOT REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT THE PEOPLE COULD YOU
STILL GET THE UNIT YOU'RE
SOMEBODY'S GOT THAT OUT AT THE
END OF THE- SO. IT TURNED OUT.
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE THE PRO.
AND A- WITH THE- PART OF THE
SCHEME PRO TO GET. THIS OUT TO
GET WITHIN WE CAN OUT FOLKS HIS.
THROUGH THE OWNERS IN. HEALTH
URBAN OR SUBURBAN CAL SO I
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE THANK
RIGHT NOW WE'RE OPEN TO.
CONSIDERATIONS THANK YOU CENTER
BECAUSE THE CENTER THERE ALSO
AND THANK YOU FOR YIELDING TO
CENTER BY CAL SKI TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER. WELCOME SENATOR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- WHAT KIND OF
FEEDBACK BASED ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THIS
EXPERIENCE. HAS CAL HFA
PROVIDED WHAT WHAT HAS BEEN
THEIR FEEDBACK OR THEIR-
RECOMMENDATIONS OR IDEAS. FIVE
THREE CHAIR. BUT THE VENTURE
FIRM KELLY AFFAIRS BEEN
INVOLVED IN ALL OF THE
DISCUSSIONS AND- CAL HFA HAS
HAD A PILOT PROJECT RIGHT NOW
BUT IN A VERY SMALL COMMUNITY
AND- ONE OF THE ISSUES WAS THEY
DID NOT SEE THE TAKE UP THAT
THAT PERHAPS PEOPLE EXPECTING.
I THINK YOU LOOK THE COMMUNITY
WHERE THEY PILOT WAS IT WAS NOT
A COMMUNITY THAT HAD A HIGH
HOUSING NEED AND IT WAS NOT IN
A HIGH JOB EITHER AND SO IT
WASN'T COMPLETELY SURPRISING
THAT IT DIDN'T QUITE HAVE THE
TAKE UP THAT PEOPLE HAVE
EXPECTED- BUT WHAT THIS FIVE.
WHAT IN WORKS CAL HFA IN THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE WHAT WE ARE
ON WORKING ON DESIGNING IS TO
HAVE. A CAL HFA HAS HAD HAVE
SOME OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR
FINANCE ENTITIES IN PARTNERSHIP
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW IT'S GOING
TO WORK WITH. WELL STATE MAY
PLAY A ROLE. IN I'M IN HELPING
CREATE A- BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
LENDER WE WOULD STILL BE REAL%
ON SECTOR LENDERS AND SCALIGER
OBVIOUSLY IT HAS THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE YES WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM. I'M SORRY MR
CHAIRMAN RIGHT I HAVE TO I
DIDN'T. ASK THAT THE YOU FOR
PERMISSION FOR THE QUESTION SO
I HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY SIR OKAY THANK YOU-
THE OTHER IS- ISSUES WERE
RAISED ABOUT ISSUING THE BONDS.
ON AND- I THINK I KNOW BASIC
ANSWER BUT IF YOU HAVE MORE
INSIGHT IS- HOW. WOULD YOU RATE
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THE
POTENTIAL BERRY IS WITH REGARDS
TO THE BONDS OF THIS PROGRAM.
THE TIME THAT IT TAKES AN. I'M
THE MISTER WACO SKI DO YOU HAVE
A BETTER ANSWER ON THE BONTA
PORTION OF IT THERE. RIGHT
THROUGH THE CHAIRS CENTER ONE
HEALTHY YES- MISTER CHAIR PHIL
SAID THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT
ALREADY ISSUES REVENUES BONDS
ON A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES ONE OF ONE OF THE OTHER
COMPANION BILLS. COMPANION
BILLS THAT WE HAVE HERE IS
THOSE TAX CREDITS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE OUR PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A- ADVANTAGE OF
WHERE THE PEOPLE CAN'T PAY RENT
THE LANDLORD COULD GET A TAX
CREDIT. THAT'S GOING TO CREATE
A FUND A POTENTIAL FUND OF
MONEY WHAT WHAT THE BILLS
DECIDED TO IS EXPAND THAT. THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE USE OF
FUNDS. TO THE EIGHTY YOU LET SO
IT'S AUGMENTATION OF THE
EXISTING FUNDS OR THEIR A PLUS
THIS INCREMENTAL IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE THE SIZE OF THE SIZE
OF THE PIE AND- AGAIN. I THINK
IT IS THE PRESENTER SAID THIS
IS IT'S SIMPLY A BRIDGE LOAN SO
WE THINK IT'S GOING TO BE YOU
KNOW IF I IF I IF I. IT WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN IS THAT SOMEBODY
WHO'S QUALIFIED IS GOING TO
COME IN AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS THE WE'RE GOING TO
GUARANTEE THAT THIS. MUST
HELPFUL GUARANTEED GOING TO BE
THIS MONEY THIS COULD COME IN
BUT THEN THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO
A BANK AFTER THE EIGHTEENTH
KANNST. AND GET THE PHONE BACK
ALL THE FEE TO THE STATE- JUST.
THINGS SOURCES OF. THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU CENTER THE
AUTHORS MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I IT GET A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT I CALL
STYLE DRIFT WERE. EVERMAN
STARTS TODAY HE SAID IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY WITHIN ITS CORE
BUSINESS- AND SOLD FOR JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT. WHAT
WE'RE DOING WILL WILL MAKE
SENSE- BECAUSE WE'RE NOT A
FOUNDATION THEY WERE NOT A
MORTGAGE COMPANY. AND WE
ACTUALLY DON'T EVEN HAVE A LOW
WAGE WORKFORCE WE HAVE PRETTY
EXPENSIVE BENEFITS SO IT GETS
REAL INTERESTING WHEN YOU WANT
TO DO. SOME PASTA ASSIST TO SEE
HOW THIS PENCILS OUT SO I. A
THEM CURIOUS IF I COULD ASK
MISTER TIM SCHAFER A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IF HE'S STILL ON THE
LINE. AND HERE SENATOR THANK
YOU YES SO YOU MADE BY CENTER
MORE LIKE WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION
YOU MAY ANSWER THANK YOU MISTER
WILL DISCLOSE THAT MR SCHAEFER
IS A FORMER ORANGE COUNTY. AND
A FRIEND SO. WITH THAT MISTER
SCHAEFFER NOTED- BORROWERS ARE
GOING TO GO LOOK AT THIS
PROGRAM- PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NO EQUITY IN THEIR
PROPERTY OR- JONES. YOU KNOW
HAVE THE MAYBE THE CREDIT
RATING SCORE THAT WOULD BE- IN
KERR JIM- SO MY CONCERN IS A
DEFAULT RATE IT WOULD BE
AWKWARD FOR THIS HAVE TO BE
INVOLVED IN FORECLOSURE AND SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE DOING SOME WORK
WITH. ORIGINATING LENDERS BUT
BUT HOW HOW ARE WE ARE WE GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP. AND
MAINTAIN A VERY LOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR OUT OF AND ATTACK THAT
BY THE FIRST OF LANCASTER
TRYING A LITTLE BIT AGREE WE
INCREASE THE HOLD ON ONE SECOND
COOLEY INCREASE THE AUDIO OR
COULD YOU OR YOU SPEAK. SIX IS
THAT BETTER SNOW YOU'RE VERY
YOU'RE VERY FAINT AND SO I
DON'T KNOW YEAH A- I HAVE HOW
IS THIS ANY BETTER THAT'S MUCH
BETTER. OKAY THANK YOU. SENATOR
MARCO RIGHT INTO YOUR QUESTION
THIS WAY AT THE END AGREED. TO
WHAT MORE WERE TEMPORARY
BYZANTINE AWKWARD STRUCTURE
FREQUENTLY THEY WERE WEBER COLD
CHANGE MARKET MARRIES HOME
WOULD BORROW MONEY FOR FIVE OR
TEN YEARS AND THEN WOULD HAVE
SOME BRIEF AND PRESS. AND
THAT'S WHAT THE THIRTY YEAR
MORTGAGE BECAME MORE COMMON.
ZELTER THAT STANDARD. LARA'S
SINGLE FAMILY FOR MUCH MORE
EASILY FROM. UNDERWRITING
CRITERIA TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
CREDIT WORTHINESS AND EQUITY
COULD BE INCORPORATED INTO THE
UNDERWRITING CRITERIA. IN THIS
WHAT. THREE STARTED TO BECOME
MORE THAT BECAME MORE DIFFICULT
AGAIN THE THEY CHOOSE. TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. BE
CONTEMPLATED FRAME FOR THE
WOULD. WOULDN'T UNDERMINE
STANDARDIZED UNDER CRY ANOTHER
WAY. A PROPERTY IN ORDER TO
CALL. EXCESS THREE TWO UNIT
WOULD STILL HAVE TO MEET
UNDERWRITING. OF THE UNDER. NOW
THE PROBLEM IS. THAT IT'S A
TIME PROBLEM THE IS THAT IF I'M
BILL AND DWELLING UNIT IN MY
HOME. IT ISN'T YEAH. AND SINCE
IT'S NOT RENTED. THE
UNDERWRITING CRITERIA TIPO YOU
TO MARK WON'T. RATIOS. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS PROGRAM IS TO
THE PERIOD IN OTHER WORDS TO
ENCOURAGE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
YOU'RE KIDDING NORMAL
UNDERWRITING CRITERIA. FOR
ATTACK- DO YOU RATE THE
HOMEOWNER TO. BE INCOME FROM
THE RENTAL ANY COUNT EQUITY
UNDER THAT INTERIM PERIOD TO
PROVIDE SOME SUPPORT FOR THAT
MUCH AS THE FEDERAL HOUSING IT.
IT FOR AFTER THE BREAK TO AND
WHICH HAD HELD TO THE STANDARD
OF THE THIRTY OR MORE AS WE
KNOW IT AND THAT PERHAPS IS THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF THE SELECTED.
FOR A WERE. CAN TO BE IN A VERY
LOW RATE MARKET PLACE AND IT
SAYS THAT THE STATE WILL CHARGE
PREMIUMS FEET THEN AND
SUFFICIENT TO COVER THE COSTS
OF THE PROGRAM. RISK FALLS SO
PROGRAMS. SO I'M WONDERING IF
YOUR LENDING COSTS WOULD BE
HIGHER THAN WHAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
MR SHAPE FOR YOU MAN SO THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU MR
CERTAINLY SENATOR I CAN'T
PREDICT THAT KIND OF FUTURE I
WILL TELL YOU THAT IF THE
PROGRAM IS MORE THREE AND THE
TREASURY BELIEVES IT IS WORTH
THREE I MEAN THAT THE FIRM. IS
IN THE MARKET WILL WE HOPE TO
PRODUCE THE DESIRED AND BASS
PRO IF WE THE PROGRAM OPERATED
BY. G. AS Y. QUE ANY MAE AND
FOR MAC FOR EXAMPLE SINCE IT IS
AN ENTRY PERIOD WE BELIEVE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF
RICHARD PRESENTED ABOUT THE
MARKET SINCE THE LION'S SHARE
OF THE QUALIFICATION PROCESS
AND THE PROJECT EVEN THE MOSQUE
IS WILL IN FACT. THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU MISTER. THANK
YOU CENTER MORLOCK COLORS ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- SEEING NINE- YES
CENTER LIKE HEALTHCARE I'D LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL OKAY- I CENTER
HEALTHCARE BILL AND SENATOR
SKINNER YOU MAKE FOR. BY
THERE'S A VERY- GOOD. I WOULD
JUST CALL DEBATE BUT GREAT
QUESTIONS WERE ASKED AND I
THINK WE GOT SOME VERY THOROUGH
ANSWERS IN WITH BUT I ASKED DR
VOTE. REMOTE WE- ADVICE A WHITE
CAL STATE WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS EIGHTY SIX NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WINNER. WINNER HI
SENATOR MORALE. MORRELL NAY
MORRELL NOW SENATOR BATES. PAGE
NOT VOTING BOATING YEAH.
SENATOR CAFIERO HI CABALLERO HI
TORONTO HI TORONTO HI MCGUIRE
MORE LUCK OR NOT VOTING MORLOCK
NOT VETTING PROCESS. ROTH AYE
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE BURKE
CASKEY BY CAL SKI I. SIX I.
OKAY WE'VE SUCCEEDED VOTE THAT
IS ENOUGH FOR THE BILL TO BE
OPERATING A PUT THE BILL ON
CALL- FOR ABSENT MEMBERS I'M
ALSO COLLEAGUES BY MASS GOING
FORWARD IF YOU'RE NOT VOTING IF
SAYS STATE PLATE NOT VOTING I
KNOW WE NORMALLY DON'T ASK FOR
THAT. GIVEN CHANCE TO TRY BE
VERY SO THAT. THAT IS CALL. WE
NEXT MOVE TO I TO NEXT ITEM
WHICH IS I. AB THIRTY BY A DALY
AND CENTER SKINNER WILL ALSO
BE- PRESENTING THAT BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SO I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB FOUR
THIRTY FORTY TODAY WHICH WILL
STREAMLINE. THE EXISTING RENTAL
HOUSING PROGRAMS THAT WE THE
STATE OF ESTABLISHED AND THAT
ARE OVERSEEN BY HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS WE'VE ESTABLISHED TEN
RENTAL HELPING PROGRAMS MEETING
WHERE WE PROVIDE GRANTS- MOSTLY
GRANT SO I'M NOT VERY MANY
LOANS BUT SOME. HI TO THE-
ENTITIES MANY TIMES IT IS
ACTUALLY THE BILL BUT IT'S-
MANY. DIFFERENT ENTITIES. I'M.
SEVEN THANK THE BUILDING OF
MULTI YOU AFFORDABLE HOUSE
RENTAL HUSING AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING YOU NOW THE THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW OUR HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO USE A SINGLE
APPLICATION AND SCORING'S. TO
MAKE COORDINATED AWARDS FOR THE
SEVEN PROGRAMS SO IT STILL
MAINTAINS THE INTENT OF EACH
SEPARATE PROGRAM BUT BY
STREAMLINING THE FUNDING AWARD
PROCESS IT DRASTICALLY REDUCE
THE COST STATE CD TO IT MISTER.
ALSO REDUCE THE COSTS FOR THOSE
WHO ARE APPLYING AND THE
RESULTING PROVIDING MORE FUNDS
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL IS RECEIVED BROAD
SUPPORT FROM. A HOUSING
ADVOCATES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
AND I HAVE TO WITNESSES MARK
STIVERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN MARINO
WANTED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM. REMEMBER
TURN LEAD WITNESSES- WE HAVE
TWO MINUTES FOR SUPPORTERS BUT
WAIT WHEN A SAYS- AND THEN WE
ALSO. TO FOR THE ONLY
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION IF I
SO. WE WILL MOVE TO. MY
APOLOGIES TO MARK STIVERS. OKAY
MY YOUR PHYSICAL I DON'T KNOW I
HELLO SIR WELCOME LOOK THE
CHAMBER GO AHEAD MARK STEINBERG
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING.
PARTNERSHIP AND I ALSO SEE TO
THEM OF MY ONE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
WE ARE BOTH PROUD TO COAST THIS
LEGISLATION. OUR DEVELOPERS ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE STATE
RESOURCES THIS IS MADE
AVAILABLE IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FORTUNATELY ARE FACTORED
SYSTEMS HAVE SIGNIFICANT TIME
COST RISK AND JUST PLAIN
HEADACHE TO THE DEVELOPMENT BE
DEFINED DEVELOP IN THE ALREADY
VERY DIFFICULT. OUR GOAL OF A
ONCE SHOP FOR NON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO ASK H.
RENTAL RESEARCH. AND BILL GETS
AS OF WAY THERE. AN IMPORTANT
MATTER REDUCE CLASS INCREASE.
OF AFFORDABLE WITH RESOURCE WE
HAVE WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BUT THANK
VERY MUCH AND SO WE WILL NOW.
MOVES TO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENTS EXCUSE ME OR ANYONE
ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS WHO WISHES
TO MAKE A COMMENT SAYING NINE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THAT IS ANYONE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT NUMBER TWENTY FORTY WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
THIS IS FOR SUPPORT. OF AB FOUR
THIRTY FOUR- WELL THE MODERATOR
PLEASE. LET US KNOW HOW MANY OR
PLEASE ARMENIAN NOT COMMENT. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
THREE FOUR OR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. OUR FIRST FINAL COME
FROM THE LINE OF EIGHTY NINE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING. ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOUNG. Q. AND AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR THREE
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OUR NEXT WILL
COME FROM FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING WIENER
AND SENATORS MEMBERS PRESENT
AGAIN THIS IS JACK GARDNER
RESIDENT OF BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
AND PRESIDENT OF THE JOHN STORE
COMPANY WERE STATEWIDE
DEVELOPER AND MANAGER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WORK WITH H.
T. EXTENSIVELY IN THAT REGARD.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. FOUR
THREE FOUR CAN YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU AND I FINAL COME FROM LINE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS A TRINIDAD
CASTANEDA AND IT IS NOT IT
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THAT SIXTY
FIVE SENATE DISTRICT NINE. IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR THREE FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE MISTER CHAIR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND THAT WILL COME FROM
THE LINE UP BY NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHRISLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES URBAN
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
THREE FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
ONE MORE Q. ENOUGH ONE MOMENT.
YEAH YEAH. AND THAT WILL COME
FROM THE LINE OF NINETY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KIDNEY FAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS IN QUEUE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU COULD ACCESS TO ASK
MAKE ONE FINAL CALL FOR SUPPORT.
SURE IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR THREE FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. ZERO NOW. THAT IS
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF AB.
FOUR THREE FOUR. AND WE HAVE A
LINE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS ACCURATE FROM
REPRESENTING HOUSING CALIFORNIA
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
THREE FORTY FOUR AM
RESPECTFULLY URGING. THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN IT FOR THE PORT AB
FOUR THREE FOUR YOU MAY PRESS.
ONE ZERO. WELL I NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I MEMBERS
ARE PRETENDING HOUSING
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FORTY FOUR IN RESPECTFULLY
VERY DELIGHTFUL. OKAY. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN Q. S. ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR THREE FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. ONE
ZERO IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF
AB. FOUR THREE FOUR. AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO POSITION
TODAY BEFORE THIRTY FOUR IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY-
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. RESTING ON. A WILL
NOT MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY I
DO NOT SEE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ONE NOW MOVES TO
THE PHONE LINES. YOUR IN
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION I'M SORRY
MR CHECK. IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR THREE
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FOUR THREE FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE A
LINE ONLINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME'S MARK GOTTEN
FROM- COMMUNITIES UNITED GW TO
HONDA. ABOUT THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE SPECIFIC LOCAL NEEDS OF
EACH COMMUNITY REGARDING THEIR
PARKING RESTRICTIONS TRAFFIC
PROGRAMMERS AND FIRE KEY THAT.
CONDITIONS AM STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
IF YOU'RE IN A POSITION OF AB
FOUR THREE FOUR YOU MAY PRESS.
ONE ZERO. IS ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB. FOUR THREE
FOUR. AND WE HAD NO WARNING YOU
MISTER CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW BRING A
BEFORE THIRTY FOUR BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- A I'M ANSWER
QUESTIONS SENT RUSSELL CAN I
MOVE THE BILL THANK SENATOR
ALSO HAS MOVED A REPORT BEFORE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CALLED. OKAY I CENTERS
SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT WE'VE
HEARD THE- WHAT THE BILL
DOESN'T VERY GOOD- DESCRIPTION
FROM ALSO OUR PRINCIPAL
SUPPORTERS AND WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR THE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR AT
WE'RE- MOTION BY CENTER ALSO
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR THIRTY FOUR BY A
FAMILY MEMBER DALY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WINNER. WINNER HI
MORRELL. BATES HI BATES HI
CABALLERO HI CABALLERO HI
TORONTO HI TORONTO HI MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK BY MORLOCK HI ROTH IRA
ROTH AYE SKINNER HI SKINNER HI
NUMBER. WIECKOWSKI HI
WIECKOWSKI AYE YOUR- YES
SEVERAL. MORRELL HI. NINE VOTES
OKAY THE BILL HAS MORE THAN
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WE WILL
PUT IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS I THANK USERS HERE NOW
CONTINUING WITH CENTERS SKINNER
SO- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. AB SEVEN TWENTY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS CENTERS
GONNA I BELIEVE IS THE BILL
SEVEN FIFTY TWO OR SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE SEVEN TWENTY FIVE OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO MY DYSLEXIA TRANSPOSED.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS- I WANT TO THANK
THE- CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN THE STAKEHOLDER FOR
THEIR COLLABORATION ON THIS
BILL. CALIFORNIA NEEDS. DENSITY
TO ACHIEVE OUR INCREASE NUMBER
OF HOUSING UNITS THAT WE NEED
BECAUSE IT IS WE ARE IN A
HOUSING CRISIS AND WE ALSO ARE
FACING NOT ONLY A VERY SEVERE
CRISIS IN TERMS OF AFFORDABLE
FOR THEIR ART LOWEST INCOME
RESIDENTS LOGIN LOWEST INCOME
WE ARE ALSO NOW IN MANY PARTS
OF THE STATE. A CRISIS WHERE.
WHAT WE HAVE ALWAYS CONSIDERED
MIDDLE CLASS. EARNERS MANY OF
WHOM ARE EVEN IN OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNITS FOR EXAMPLE
STATE WORKERS THAT CAN NOT
AFFORD COST OF HOUSING WHERE
THEY LIVE. AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. IT REQUIRES OUR
METROPOLITAN JURISDICTIONS
ALLOCATE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF THEIR ABOVE MODERATE AND
MODERATE HOUSING TO MULTI
FAMILY PRODUCTION RATHER THAN
JUST ADDRESSING IT THROUGH
SINGLE FAMILY PRODUCTION BUT
THROUGH- MULTI UNIT BUILDINGS.
THE BILL GIVE ZONING
FLEXIBILITY TO LOCALS THE
THOUGHTFUL IMPROVEMENT TO
HOUSING LAW. BY CREATING MORE
MULTI FAMILY OPTIONS FOR ALL
RESIDENTS SAID MOM ALREADY OF
INCOME LEVELS WE ADDRESS THE
INEQUITY IN HIGH COST COMMUNITY.
I'M WE HAVE A COUPLE OF. OF KEY
WITNESSES WHO WERE ON THE LINE
IN SUPPORT AND- I THINK IT'S
MAYBE ONLY ONE BUT WILL ALLOW
CROSS CHRISTY KERING'S. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER WILL NOW
MOVES- TOUR- SUPPORTING
WITNESSES AND OUR LEAD
SUPPORTER- WILL BE- MISS-
CHRISTMAS CONSIDER CRITICS- AND
YOU MAY PROCEED. THE NEW TWO
MINUTES GOOD MORNING QALANDARS.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR CAL
MEMBERS NAME AT THE YOU LOOK AT
CRANE. FIND BEHALF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA HAS FALLEN
SIGNIFICANTLY BEHIND CREATING A
CALM ACCOMMODATE ALL OF ITS
RESIDENTS ONE OF THE CHALLENGES.
THAT SPECIALLY IN. OKAY THE
DALLAS THE TURNER CENTER
CONDUCTED A RECORD LAND SURVEY
FROM TWENTY SEVEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND FOUND THAT MY OF
THE LANDING CAL IS THE BURSTING
WITH BACK THAT WOULD BE LITTLE
PHONE TO LOOK MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING DIVERSITY OF LAND
ADEQUATELY CAPACITY SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTOR TO INCREASE PLAN
PRIVATE DEVELOP. A ALL RIGHT
OUR STATE FOR THE BILL QUITE BY
REQUIRING A LOCAL PLAN FOR THEM
IN THE FIVE MILE HOUSING NEEDS
THANK THAT CAN OCCUR. A PORTLET
MALIK IN BILL. EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE ENSURE THAT GOVERNMENT
USED LAND YOU THINK. ALSO
WRITING THIS TYPE GENTLE. ONE
IN OF HOME AVAILABLE AND HELP
BRING DOWN AVERAGE HOUSING IN
HIGH COMPLICATION WE THE CYCLE
GAIL OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD. FORTY
THREE POINT NINETY IS YOUR
SUPPORT ON THE TWENTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I WILL NOW MOVE
TO PUBLIC AS OUR IN THE- TO
TESTIFY SO OF AB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE SAYING ALL MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NO ONE APPEARS TO
BE AROUND TWENTY FORTY WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES. FOR
SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
NET IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE. AND LOCAL TO THE
LINE- TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI HOLLY FOR MEETING WITH
WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS IN
THE PARKING ON BEHALF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY BERMAN AND
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OFTEN OUT.
THANK YOU AND I NEXT FINAL FROM
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TRACY
MELANCHOLIC THREE OF THE NECK
AND A MEMBER OF THE ETHNICITY
OR SAN FERNANDO VALLEY NY.
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE THANK
YOU. AND THAT FINAL COME FROM
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER EARNERS IS NOT
A BEHALF OF CAL APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
AND THE NEXT FINAL COME FROM
ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI EVERYONE PAGE NOT OFFERED TO
YOU HAVE A MODERATE INCOME
RESIDENTS IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC SALUTE.
PLEASE NOTE YES THANK YOU. AND
OUR NEXT PLAN WILL BE ONE LOT
BETTER YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS WAS GREAT OAKLAND AND
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND A
MEMBER OF SOUTH BAY GIVE BEACH
AND I AM SUPPORT. YOUR SUPPORT
AT EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU. YEAH I WILL BE WON
ALL FOUR HUNDRED AND FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HI MY- SON AND I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES- EXPECTANT
FATHER LOOKING FOR A SMALL
PLACE TO LIVE AND WITH THE REST
OF MY SPORT. BOB AND ALSO SANTA
MONICA YEAH. AND THE NEXT FINAL
COME FROM SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JOSE
TRINIDAD CASTANEDA FROM
FULLERTON. B. IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE IN THE WAY AND
ORANGE COUNTY FAMILY. IN OUR
NEXT ONE WILL COME FROM FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN
THE SKATING ADDED IN UNION CITY
I AM WITH BUFFET FOR EVERYONE
CAN I ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. THANK Q. AND THEN I FIND
OF THE HON AND SEVEN YEAR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
TOWARD I'M- YEAH CALLING STRONG
SUPPORTER AB FIVE. ON B. OF AN
INFOPRINT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE WILL COME FROM AND THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS ISAAC TAYLOR I'M
CALLING IN FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I AM INDEPENDENT. A
CALL SEEKING COMMENT AND- WHO
WOULD BILL IS WITH AB HA ND
PAY AND BOND WITH NOTHING IN
THE I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB. SEVEN FIVE FIVE. AND OUR
NEXT ONE WILL COME FROM AND-
YOUR LINE OF OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS THE COMMON CALLING FROM
THEIR CRUZ ON BEHALF OF STATE
ECONOMY OF THE POOR BY. SEVEN
TO FIVE. SHE AND THE NEXT IT
COMES FROM FIVE AIRLINERS. JACK
GARDNER A RESIDENT OF BERKELEY.
ON THE PRESIDENT THE JONSTEWART
COMPANY BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO
I WOULD URGE YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. TWENTY FIVE A GOOD
MIDDLE THAT RECOGNIZES THE DIRE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CALIFORNIA
IS CURRENTLY IN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. IN OUR
NEXT LINE WILL COME FROM A
HUNDRED AND NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS RAFAEL
SONNENFELD- SANTA CRUZ AND THE
CALLING PUMP IN SUPPORT OF
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE AND- APPLE
THE PEOPLE PARKS AND CHRIS
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT LINE WILL
COME FROM A HUNDRED AND ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY MY NAME
IS ARIELLE STARR I'M CALLING
FROM OAKLAND AND REPRESENTING
EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. I LIKE
NINE WILL COME FROM LINE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY
GEORGE OKAY. ASIA AND WE A
SUPPORT FOR THE GOLD WERE JUST
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AN
AMENDMENT TO WEAR SPECIALLY
RECOMMENDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THESE. PACKAGE BUILD
WORKING WITH. AND WE'RE GOING
TO. CYCLE OF ALL THE HOUSING
AND WE APPRECIATE THEIR SUPPORT
THERE ARE A. IN THE NEXT NINE
WILL COME FROM A LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS THERE'S LESS BOND I AM
CALLING FROM VENICE CALIFORNIA
ON BEHALF OF I SAID BMB. AND I
SUPPORT WE SUPPORT YOU SEVEN
POINT FIVE. YEAH CAN I EXPLAIN
WILL COME FROM THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MORE IN THE DETAILS
ROLE WITH THE BAY AREA HOUSING.
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY FIVE THANK. AN
EXCELLENT A LINE OF ONE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
THOMAS IRWIN A RESIDENT AT EAST
LOS ANGELES CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE HALF OF THE
STATE. NEXT CALL LINE UP
SEVENTY EIGHT. MY NAME THE OPEN.
IT IS KIND OF SILLY FROM ME
VERY SANTA CRUZ NUMBER I'M
CALLING AT THE PORT. THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT ALTHOUGH THE LINE
ITEM SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PRIVATE CAPITAL GAINS
FROM PALO ALTO RECORD NINETEEN
PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE
INSTRUCTORS COURT. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SAM
DEUTSCHE I'M A RENTER AND SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY. SEVEN
AND THEN I FIND WILL COME FROM
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MANY TEACHERS FROM LONG BEACH
AND CO ORGANIZER FOR AGAIN THE
LONG BEACH AND CALLING AT THE
PORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT FINAL COME
FROM. SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS. I'M
REPRESENTING SANTA CRUZ SENIOR
FOR HOUSING CALLING INTO COURT
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE THANK
YOU. AND AS A REMINDER FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE. CAN WE HAVE
KNOWING HUMAN NATURE. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVES TO OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE WE HAVE NO
OFFICIALLY DESIGNATED OPPONENTS
SAW WHAT EITHER BE TURNED OUT
WITH TEN IT INTO. SAYING NO ONE
WILL EVER FORTY. I SEE NO
ANSWER ANYONE IN TWENTY FOUR
AND WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES WE PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES OR UP. TO ROOM TO AB
SEVENTY FIVE AS A REMINDER WE
HAVE A LOT TO THE ANYONE
SPEAKING. MORE AIMS AFFILIATION
AND SAVE OPPOSITION I'M BEYOND
THAT- PEOPLE BE LIMITED LIMITED
TO SAY THEIR NAMES. WITH
ELATION. AND THE FACT THAT.
THANK YOU YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO. IT WILL GO
TO THE FIRST LINE OF LINE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MARK DUTTON TO HONDA AB TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND MORE CARS ON OUR
SMALL STREET AND CREATE A VERY
DANGEROUS FIRE BACK TO. PROBLEM
ONCE AGAIN. EIGHTY BEAT ALL
CITIES MUST YOU GIVE CONTROL
OVER THEIR OWN REALITY THIS ONE
THOUGHT IT'S ALL FROM THE- IT'S
NOT APPROPRIATE AND VERY
DANGEROUS. YOUR LOCAL. I OPPOSE
STRONGLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR INTERNET FINAL COME FROM
NINETY SEVEN. YOUR LINE AND- MY
NAME IS CAROL CHECK OF H. I'M A
RESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA I BELIEVE THAT- LOCAL
TO DATE COULD BE MADE LOCALLY
AND I STRONGLY. GEN PAST OF ONE
FIVE ALL. AND THEN I LINE WILL
GO TO IT ONE TWENTY FIVE YEAR
LINE OPEN. FINAL TO THE SAY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MERRY
JACK ON THE NUMBER OF CITIZENS
PRESERVING MENACE WHICH SUPPORT
BOTH AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
LOCAL PLANNING AND WE ARE
CLOSED THE BILL HAS. WRITTEN
HERE. NO NEXT FINAL VOTE TO AT
ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS MILLS TO SPEAKING
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
TWO GROUPS COUNTY WHITE
ANGELENOS RETREAT. CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT AND-
LITTLE CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION WE ALSO BELIEVE IN
LOCAL DECISION MAKING AND I'M
CHECKING SINGLE FAMILY HOME
OWNERSHIP WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE. THE
MODERATOR. NOT A MODERATOR ARE
YOU THERE. OKAY WERE CHECKING
ON A POTENTIAL TECHNICAL ISSUE-
ONE PLEASE HOLD ON. AND OUR
NEXT LINE IN ONE MINUTE FIFTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THEY
HAVE DROPPED. WHEN IT COMES
FROM THE LINE OF NINE EIGHT
ZERO NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES A MAJOR
SETBACK REVIEW. AS A
CERTIFICATION IN THE SOUTH BAY
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
FOR LOCAL CONTROL READ ABOUT
PORTABLE HOUSE. BUT SAID TWENTY
FIVE EAST. STABLE COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT. THANK FOR HOUSING THE
STRAW OPPOSE BILL. THANK YOU.
FROM THE LINE AT ONE EIGHT
ZERO. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH CATHERINE OUR
OCEAN AND- GO WE SUPPORT LOCAL
CONTROL THIS LEGISLATION THAT
WILL DESTABILIZE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND YET IT PROVIDES
NO WAY CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DOES. FINALLY FROM ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
FIRST CHAIR OF THE NIXON NINE
CAMPAIGN REPRESENTING THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS COULD SUPPORT
THE HELP HOUSING POLICY
RESEARCH AT THE EMBARCADERO
INSTITUTE. WE'LL GET POSED
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY FIVE.
FINEST THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THE BOND JOHNSON
FROM CAMANCHE AND I'M
REPRESENTING PROTECTING OUR PUT
HEALTH COMMUNITY I'M GOOD
ACTORS FIERY BANCORPORATION'S.
AND TRAFFIC THAT. THE ONE CRIED
ALL THAT LITTLE NOT IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I DON'T WANT ANOTHER
CLEAR NIGHT HERE. THE NEXT LINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS CAROL AUSTIN WITH
PROTECTING OUR FOOTHILL
COMMUNITIES WE ARE IN A HIGH
FIRE ZONE WITH AGING AND
FAILING FIRST SURE ALREADY AND
THIS DOES NOT FIT THE CRITERIA
HERE AND WE STRONGLY APPROACH.
AND THEN I CAN FINALLY COME
FROM ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IT. I AM PART
OF THE WEST TO LOOK AWAY
REGIONAL COUNCIL. I DO NOT
BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE
ANYTHING BUT LOCAL CAN OVER
ZONING. THERE IN LOSS AND THERE
ARE MANY WORKING CLASS. NAY
VOTES WHICH FAMILY. WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THIS I ALSO BELIEVE
THAT IF HIGH RISE AND DENSITY
FOR THE ANSWER TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE HOW WOULD YOU
EXPLAIN NEW YORK CITY AND SAN
FRANCISCO. SO I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE MODERATOR FOR BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE OFFICIAL LEAD
WITNESS SAYS- I'VE BEEN TIMING
THE SUBSTANTIVE COMMENTS OF
EACH OF THE- WE'LL HAVE BEEN
TESTIFYING TO MAKE SURE WE
APPARENTLY TWO MINUTES IN FAVOR
TWO AGAINST WE NOW EACH TWO
MINUTES ANSWER FOR WHEN THIS IS
GOING FORWARD PLEASE LET ME.
TESTIMONIES YOUR NAME YOUR A
SHINING AND. THANK YOU CANNOT
FIND WORK FROM LINE EIGHTY YEAR
OF THE- MY NAME IS. THE
PRESIDENT TEM OF THE WEST THE
LAKE RESIDENT TO SAYS IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY IN THE
PUBLISHER OF OUR COMMUNITY NEWS
AND ACTIVE IN THE GREATER TO
LOOK ALIKE NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL.
ONE SIZE FITS ALL NOT
APPROPRIATE STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE HAS
WRITTEN THANK YOU. AND AGAIN AS
A REMINDER PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY- AND THE
FACT THAT YOU OPPOSE A BILL. IN
THE NEXT FIVE WILL COME FROM
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHANGE ENERGY LEVEL RIVERSIDE
IN MARINO VALLEY WE OPPOSE. THE
NEXT LINE IS FINE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI AND
GEOGHAN FROM THE HOLLYWOOD
HILLS FRANKLIN CORRIDOR CAP
COALITION WE DO NOT HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS HERE IN
HOLLYWOOD WE HAVE AN AFFORDABLE.
HOUSING CRISIS THANK YOU VERY.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND OUR
NEXT LINE WILL BE FORTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JENNIFER KIßM A RESIDENT OF
THE RIGHT GENTRIFYING
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SUNNYSIDE IN
FRANCISCO I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AT NINE O'CLOCK COME FROM. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROL MORE
THANK YOU TO THEM. ALL I AM
THIS BILL IT DOES NOT PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND I NEXT
LINE WILL COME FROM LINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON THE
NEXT LINE OF ONE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI DAVID CAN
COUNT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
IT YOU KNOW WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. CAN NEXT
LINE IS NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MERRY GALLAGHER FROM
PALO ALTO AND SANTA BURKE
DOWNEY WE OPPOSE. WELCOME BACK
TO LINE OF NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JERRY LOS ANGELES I
REPRESENT NO SPECIAL INTERESTS
DURING THE DAY THAT IS FAULTY
AND THE BETA. BETA THAT BAD AND
I MAKE BAD DECISIONS PLEASE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE REMINDER
IT HERE IN OPPOSITION OF BILL
AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. OPPOSITION OF.
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE A FEW MORE
MATURE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
THAT WILL COME FROM THE LINE OF
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME ROUGHLY THE
NUMBER OF THE BEAR. ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF AND MY NEIGHBORS WE
OPPOSE SEVEN TWENTY FIVE. AND
THE NEXT ONE WILL COME FROM ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BONTA ONE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE TWENTY
ONE. YES THIS IS DEBBIE AND
BORING ARAMBULA WESTCHESTER
CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN THE
TRIANGLE AND WE BOTH KNOW ON
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE. LIKE FINAL
COME FROM ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT SPEECH WITH SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE IT SUPPORT- FROM
CALIFORNIA SO I HOPE BECAUSE-
AND WE CAN START THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHAT ACTIONS ON THE ACT
HAS THAT RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU WITH COMPLETED
SUPPORT TESTAMENT. WE ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY.
DURING MY PERRIN UP OF A SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO IN A POSITION OF
AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE. AND ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE
COMING. AND THAT'S GOING TO
COME TO A LINE- ONE THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB THIS
IS RECALLED FROM SAN FRANCISCO
ANTI GENTRIFICATION ACTIVISTS
IN THE MISSION DISTRICT UNITED
CIGNA MISSION- WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. AND AS A REMINDER IF
YOU'LL ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE MY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. AND ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION OF AB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE. MR SURE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO COMPLETE THEIR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY WE WILL
NOW- BRING THIS MATTER AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE- BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OUR COLLEAGUES OTHER
ANY QUESTIONS. OR COMMENTS.
CENTER CABALLERO. HOME OF THE
BILL. THE CENTER CABALLERO
THROUGH THE BILL. ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BEING NINE- WE WILL
GO TO CENTER SKINNER AND CENTER
YOU MAY. I'M SORRY CENTER MORE
LOCKED IT RAISES MY SO CENTER.
THANK YOU MR FORGET MY
HESITATION NINE. I REALLY
ENJOYED BEING A CO AUTHOR OF SB
FIFTY AND THERE WAS A
INTERESTING AND STIMULATING
EXPERIENCE BUT- THE TWO MAJOR.
PUSH BACK SAID I WOULD GET IN
ALL OF MY ENCOUNTERS WAS ONE WE
WANT TO HAVE LOCAL CONTROL.
MORE LIKE THE TO THE TO
CONCERNS THAT CAP BACK TO ME
WITH LOCAL CONTROL AND THE
OTHER WAS YOU KNOW THE FEAR OF
BUILDING- SAY A FOUR PLEX IN
THE CURRENT EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD SO.
SONOMA BIG PRIVATE. AT WE NEED
TO CERTAINLY FIND MORE HOUSING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A BALANCE BETWEEN
THE PRESSING NEEDS AND THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR APPROVING THE
PROJECTS IN THESE REBUILD SIDE.
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED THAT
THIS IS A RATHER STRONG MANDATE
AND A AND A STRONG TOOL AND I
WOULD PREFER TO SEE A- HAVING A
LITTLE LESS CARSON. IS THAT YOU
SHOULD CHIEF THIS IN THE FOUR
POINT. MANNER OVER THIS CERTAIN
PERIOD OF TIME AS OPPOSED TO A
U. MUSTARD IT'S REQUIREMENTS
HAVE ONE QUARTER OF YOUR-
JURISDICTION. SURE OF THE RE TO
BE A COMPONENTS OF. AM JUST
HAVING A LITTLE DIFFICULT SO
PERHAPS THE- PRESENTER THE BILL
CAN TRAIN. HELP ME OUT WITH
THOSE CONCERNS IN OUR CLOSING
REMARKS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY THANK YOU AND IF THERE'S-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
SAYING I'M SKINNER YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU. AND IN.
CLOSING ALL DRESSED OF BRIEFLY.
THIRD EMPLOYEE OF- MUCH OF THE
OPPOSITION'S EXPRESSION WAS
THAT THIS WOULD REQUIRE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ELIMINATE
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING IN FACT IT
DOES NOT. WHAT IT DOES ASK IS
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
LARGE METROPOLITAN AREAS.
LANDON RINA FOR FOUR UNITS AND
HIGHER AND THEY COULD KEEP IT
JUST FOR UNITS- FOR MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING WHICH OF COURSE
COULD BE DONE IN A VARIETY OF
TYPES OF HIS OWN AND DOES NOT
NECESSARILY REQUIRE THEM TO
CHANGE THAT R. ONE ZONING. THE
AUTHOR ALSO EXPECTED AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY HOUSING
GOVERNMENT FINANCE THAT MADE
THIS THE MINIMUM DENSITY IN
THIS BILL CONSISTENT WITH. THE
S. ELEVEN TWENTY BY SENATOR
ATKINS IN WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I DO THIS A NOTE I STRONG
SUPPORT BILL AND I WANT TO JUST
REITERATE- THAT THIS BILL THIS
IS ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF YOUR MONITOR AND A MOBILE
ABOUT MODERN. ZONING WHEN I
CITY IS- DOING SOMETHING
ELEMENT. THE CITY WILL GET TO
WHERE. JOINING GOES AND 75% OF
THE CAN STILL BE SINGLE FAMILY
IS A VERY BALANCED AND- ALL
THAT. I IS IT IS THAT WE NEED A
LOT MORE HOUSING. BETTER DOES
IT AND ALLOW TOUCH WAVING IT'S
VERY. AND I TO RECORD THAT I.
WITHOUT CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
A SATELLITE BILL SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS THE
MOTION IS DUE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR WINNER.
WINNER I'D MORRELL. ARAMBULA
MORAL NO BATES NO. THE SAN MIKE
PLEASE NO BATES NOW CABALLERO
HI CABALLERO I TO RUSSELL HI
TORONTO HI MCGUIRE. MARLA NO
MORE LUCK NOW ROTH HEY ROTH AYE
SKINNER BY SKINNER HI NUMBER
CAL SKI. FIVE TO THREE OKAY WE
WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WE ARE NOW-
PROCEEDING TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE BY A MEMBER
GRAYSON AND I SEE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE ALL
SUMMER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND ALSO TO MEMBERS. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE WHICH WILL ALLOW
QUALIFIED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS TO EFFECTIVELY UTILIZE
THE STREAMLINED APPROVAL
PROCESS ESTABLISHED BY SB
THIRTY FIVE WHICH PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE CO
NINETEEN. IS ONLY. CALIFORNIA'S
ONGOING HOUSING CRISIS AS
SOARING UNEMPLOYMENT AND THE
NUMBER LEAVE MANY UNABLE TO
AFFORD. AND ALL THE BRINK. OF
THE VICKS SB FIVE A LAN EFFORT
INCREASE OUR HOUSING SUPPLY.
HOWEVER SINCE THE BEEN. AT UBS.
WHAT SB THIRTY FIVE NINETY.
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED I DIDN'T
BE RAY DOES NEEDED PROJECT. THE
STOCK THE STATE SO AB THIRTY
ONE. THREE FIND TO A THE-
EMERGING ISSUES FIRST IT'LL
THEM BUT- TO AN S. THIRTY FIVE.
WITH OUR RECALL THE DEVELOPER
TO APPLY FOR A NEW. APPROVAL
SECOND IT REFINES THE
PERMITTING PROCESS FOR
CONNECTING AND S. THIRTY FIVE
PROJECT DOING THIS THING PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN LASTLY
AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE CLASS. AT
THE TWO THIRDS RESIDENTS A
REQUIREMENT AND SB THIRTY FIVE
APPLIES TO THE PROJECT ITSELF
AND NOT THE ZONING FOR THE SITE
THE PROJECT IS BUILT ON. WITH
THE STREET THE GOAL CHANGES AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE WILL ENSURE
QUALIFYING HOUSING. THANKS
AFFECT THE SPRING. INTENDED
UNDER SB THIRTY SO I DO HAVE A
WITH STATE MY MICHAEL A SEVENTY
DIRECTOR FOR SPUR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JUST MEMBER WHAT
NUMBER TO MISTER LANE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE- MISCELLANY
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES. SURE
WINNER NUMBERS MICHAEL LANE
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION. A PUBLIC POLICY
THINK TANK KNOWN AS BURKE. AT
THE THIRTY FIVE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ALLOWS FOR
STREAMLINED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
TO COMPLY WITH LOCAL ZONING AND
DENSITY STANDARDS THAT THE
JURISDICTION IS NOT
PARTICIPATION HOUSING. AT
VARIOUS INCOME LEVELS CALLED IN
ITS REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION. OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS LAW WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION
TECHNICALLY UP. TO ENSURE THAT
THE APPLICATION OF THE LAW
MEANS WITH YOUR HANDS OF THE
LADY CARE. SIX BILLION DOLLARS
BY HOUSING HERE THAT CLINTON
ACT OUT. FINER DESIGN MODEL.
ARE ALLOW. AS LONG AS OBJECT
STANDARDS TO BE THAT. BUT
THAT'S ALL CREDIT PROOF IS
REQUIRED IN AS THIRTY FIVE
PROJECT BUT ALSO BE A PER. AND
THREE THE TRUTH RESIDENTIAL
APART APPLIES PROPOSE BROAD.
AND NOT THE SITE FOR ITS OWN.
MIXED USE UNDER COMMERCIALS ON
THAT ALLOW RESIDENTS ABOUT
DIRECTOR WE REQUIRED A TWO
THIRDS OF THE SITE. DEDICATED
TO RESIDENTIAL USE. ARGI
CLARIFICATIONS PROVIDE GREATER
CERTAINTY UNDERSTAND THE
STATUTE FOR BOTH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND DEVELOPERS.
AND ENSURE THE PROMISE AND
LEGISLATIVE INTENT THAT SB
THIRTY FIVE CAN BE FULFILLED. I
REQUEST AND I BOTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER MAN
WILL NOW GO TO ADDITIONAL-
SUPPORT PUBLIC COMMENT- AND YOU
AND YOU WILL HAVE THE ABILITY
TO STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION THAT YOU SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
HOUSE. MISTER MEMBERS ALEX
TORRANCE WAS STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF UP FOR
GROWTH ACTUALLY CAL. SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANY ONE ELSE GALLERY
AND- MAYBE THIRTY ONE. SAYING I
WILL MOVE TO ROUTE TWENTY FORTY.
I DON'T SEE ANYONE AROUND
TWENTY FORTY WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AGAIN THIS IS
SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENT YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE
FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT. SURE IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
THREE ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. AND WE HAVE A LOT TO
OUR FIRST A FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS THIS IS KEITH
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. THE
NEXT LINE WOULD GO TO IT IS
LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HOLLY FOR MEETING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF REPEAT CAMPAIGN AND
DIVERSE GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS
THAT INCLUDE THE SAN FRANCISCO
FOUNDATION TMG PARTNERS AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. HELICON
VALLEY CALLING SUPPORT. WITHOUT
A LINE OF. FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR FOR THE AMERICAN
PLAYING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THE SERVER LINE OF SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT IS LUIS MARIN
DAY FOR CALIFORNIA BE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. EXTROVERTED
LINE OF ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI BUT YOU LOOK
AT THE OPENING HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CANAL AREA HOME IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF. ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I DIDN'T EVEN SHOW WITH
THE BAY HOUSING AND COALITION
IN SUPPORT THANKS. NEXT IN LINE
ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MEXICO TO LINE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN EVAN ON
BEHALF OF OUR HUMANITY A
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'D FINAL COME FROM NINE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GET A
LOT OF THE DATA THAT THE DAIRY
COUNCIL AND I WANT VERY IN
SHOCK REPORT EIGHTY THREE ONE.
AND I FINAL COME FROM ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS SANDRA AMARINDER
AND CAMPUSES I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THE NEXT TIME I
COME FROM A SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JOSE
TRINIDAD CASTANEDA FROM THE
WORK ORANGE COUNTY AND IN THE
VOID IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
NEXT TIME WILL COME FROM NINE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU CAN NUMBERS ERIN ADVANTAGE
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF STAND HELD
PROPERTY COMPANY AND TRACK
RECORD THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT THREE ONE YOU MAY
PUSH ONE ZERO NOW. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT THREE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
AMATEUR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION HI IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
HERE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
AB THIRTY ONE. SAYING I'M- ONE
MOTORING TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NO ONE TWENTY FORTY ONE NOW
MOVES TO THE PHONE LINES AND
AGAIN THIS IS FOR OPPOSITION TO
AB THIRTY ONE. PLEASE NORMAL GO
AHEAD. IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
I KNOW THAT A LINE OF TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MARK DAYTON-
FROM THE LOGIC THAT BUILDING BY
DEFINITION EXPAND ON THE
PROPERTY AYE OPPOSED MISLEADING
MISLEADINGLY WRITTEN BILL THANK
YOU. THE NEXT FINAL GO TO IS
FINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YVONNE JOHNSON FROM
PROTECT HERE COULD HILL
COMMUNITY. I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND AS A REMINDER IF YOU'LL ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF. EIGHTY THREE
EIGHT THREE ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. NOT POSITION OF AB
ONE ZERO. AND LOCAL IN THE LINE
OF EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HE ACTUALLY GOT A LINE OF
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS CAROL AUSTIN
PROTECTING OUR FOOT HILLS I'M
OPPOSED. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT THREE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
ORDER TO ALIGN A EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS TAYLOR AND PRESIDENT PRO TEM
OF THE WEST TO LOOP THE LAKE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS WRITTEN
THANK YOU. YOU AND AS A
REMINDER IN OPPOSITION A BILL
AB EIGHT THREE ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION OF AB EIGHT THREE
ONE. AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU IN THE FUTURE. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- RIGHT NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS REGARDING AB THIRTY
ONE. CENTER MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MATURE I WAS JUST CURIOUS IF
THE AUTHOR SPEND ANY TIME.
CONSIDERING A CHANGE TO THE
PREVAILING RATE PROVISION. SB
THIRTY FIVE. SO SB THAT THAT IS
A PROVISION OF SB THIRTY FIVE
ITSELF AND SO I AM JUST USING
AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES- THAT DO NOT
INCLUDE ANY OTHER CHANGES SUCH
AS PREVAILING WAGE SB THIRTY
FIVE. BUT WHAT OF WIN WHICH IS
ACTUALLY A PART OF THE SB
THIRTY FIVE BILL I'M JUST TO.
PROTECT CLEAN UP. TO SB THIRTY
FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MATURE. OKAY SEEING CENTER
CABALLERO. SOMEOF THE BILL
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER
CABALLERO HAS MOVED THE BILL BY
BY SEEING NO ADDITIONAL MIKE'S
UP FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE YOU MAKE.
THANK YOU RICHARD MEMBER I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE WILL NOT CALL THE
ROLL. ALL OF A SUDDEN SENATE
RATES HI I HAD A QUESTION NOW
REGARDING THE REQUIREMENT TO
APPROVE OFFSITE IMPROVEMENTS
AND IT SEEMS KIND OF TOOTHLESS
SAYING THAT- THEY MUST BE
APPROVED WITHOUT DELAY BUT
REMEMBER IN THE DAYS WHEN I WAS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND YOU HAD
PROUD HAD. CALL THESE WITH
LET'S SAY THE THESE ARE WHAT IT
NOT HAVE OR WRITE A- BUT HE'S
AT CETERA I AM CA. THAT THAT
LANGUAGES IN A IN THE BILL NOW
SAYING THAT IT HAS TO BE DONE
WITHOUT DELAY IS NOT GONNA BE
DEFINED. TO A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THEY SHOULD MAKE FINDINGS OF
WHAT THE DELAY IS OR WE NOW
MOVE TO SOME SORT OF PEELER
LITIGATION I'M A QUITTER THE
OFFER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION AND I DO. MAKING
CHANGES BUT THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS LEFT INTO THE HANDS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
CREATE A NEW ENVIRONMENT FOR
FURTHER IN THAT LITIGATION.
HOWEVER IN THIS PARTICULAR IT
HAS BROUGHT UP AS WE WERE OVER
STAKEHOLDERS AS THAT BEING THE-
SO HE WOULD BE MORE WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT AS IT
MOVES FORWARD. THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM ANY SENATORS.
OKAY SEEING NINE FIVE SOME
MEMBERS ALREADY CLOSE SO WE
WILL NOW I'LL CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION AS WELL AS A MEMBER
COMMERCENTRE COMPANY OR- THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR WINNER
HI WIENER HI MORRELL. RELY
MORRELL AYE BATES. BOATING
BATES NOT VOTING CABALLERO HI.
I TO RUSSELL HI. I REQUIRE.
MORLOCK RIGHT TELL MIKE PLEASE
HI MORLOCK I BROUGHT ALL ROTH
AYE SKINNER FIVE SKINNER I AM
BURKE WITH CASKEY. SEVEN BOATS
THE BILL HAS- SEVEN BOATS WE
WILL PUT OUR ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. OKAY WE NOW MOVE TO THE
NEXT ITEM WHICH IS AB NINETEEN
TO ASSERT THAT TIME CONSENT ONE
I. TWO ONE WE TAKE UP THE
CONSENT. AGENDA NOW- IT'S A
GREAT REMINDER- SO THE- CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF THREE
BILLS AB NINETEEN TWENTY. AB
FIVE THREE AND AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY CAñADA MOTION TO APPROVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SO MOVED
BY CENTER CABALLERO HI AND WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON
THE CAN UNDER WHICH CONSISTS OF
FILE ITEM SEVEN TEN AND ELEVEN
SENATOR WIENER HI WIENER AYE
MORRELL. MORRELL AYE MORALE AYE
BATES BATES HI CABALLERO HI
CABALLERO I TORONTO TORONTO AYE
MCGUIRE. MORLOCK HELLO HI SIR
HERE LIKE I'VE ROTH ROTH AYE
SKINNER BY SKIN HI NUMBER WITH
CASKEY. APRIL OKAY BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT BUT
WE'LL PUT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ. THIS
BILL WILL BE PRESENTED ON HER
BEHALF BY SENATOR THERE ALSO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE WOULD BOOST THE
NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE UNITS
BUILT IN CALIFORNIA BY
INCREASING THE DENSITY BONUS
AND THE NUMBER OF INCENTIVES
AVAILABLE FOR QUALIFIED HOUSING
PROJECT IT IS OBVIOUS THAT WE
AS A STATE HAVE FAILED TO AND
THERE'S ADDED IN FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IT'S I'M SICK AND
THEN HAVE WE HAVE AN OF. AND OF
CRISIS FAMILY STRUGGLE TO FIND
HOUSING THAT MEETS THEIR NEEDS
AND IF THEY'RE LUCKY TO FIND
THAT HOUSING THEY FIND THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD IT THAT IS
SIMPLY OUT I THEIR MEANS AFTER
WE WILL MOLD. IS IN A SINGLE
MINUTE OVER. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE WORK FOR IN MY DISTRICT.
AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE'S BIG
SALARY HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN A
DECELERATION. ONE OF THE MANY
TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL TO
INCREASE HOUSING IS THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW. BENEFITS UNDER THE
PROGRAM ARE OFFERED DEPENDING
ON HOW MANY HOLES DEED
RESTRICTED OF DOUBLE. FOR THE
YEAR. IT TO PROVIDING
DEVELOPERS A BONUS ABOVE THE
DENSITY CONCESSIONS FROM LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE HOWEVER THE CURRENT
DENSITY BONUS LAW HAS NOT
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT INCREASES.
IN SAN DIEGO ONLY FOUR THOUSAND
UNITS WERE. BUILT OVER A TWO
YEAR SPAN RESPONSE THE SLOW OF
THE PRO SAN DIEGO AND- THE
STATE PROGRAM BY INCREASING THE
MAXIMUM DENSITY BONUS TO BE
PERCENT AN INCREASE THE MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF. INCENTIVES TO FIVE.
I GET THE PET LEVEL A NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE IT'S DEVELOPERS
APPLIED FOR FOUR TIMES AS MANY
PROJECT IN THE FIRST TWENTY
MONTHS SPENT ON TRACK PRODUCE
MORE UNITS THAN UNDER THE
PREVIOUS PROGRAM WITHIN THE
FIRST THREE YEARS. AB TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE WITH A AND
CALIFORNIA'S DENSITY BONUS LAW
TO PRINT THIS ENHANCEMENTS
OPTED THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
ORDER TO INCREASE OUR HOUSING
STOCK ACROSS THE STATE. USUALLY
THIS BLOOD TEST MAXIMO PARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR QUALIFYING THE
CITY PROJECTS WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS COLIN PARENT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CIRCULAR.
SAN DIEGO. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILL NOW GO TO MISTER PARENTS.
WHAT TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU MR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PROVIDING
NEEDED BY AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLARS VIRTUES
IN THIS BILL AND CENTERED
AROUND STILL PRESENTING TODAY
MY NAME IS COLIN PARENT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND GENERAL
COUNSEL OF THE NONPROFIT CALLED
CIRCULATING DIEGO I'M ALSO A
MEMBER CITY COUNCIL. WE HAD MY.
EIGHTY TWO FOUR FIVE DESIGNED
TO DESIGNED PROVIDE LAW SAID IN
HIM THE DEATH POLITICS WHICH IS
ADOPTED THE CITY CITY IN TWENTY
SIX. IT HAPPENS WHERE IF
COMMITTEE AS ANY HOUSING. GOES.
HOW OR EAT WELL I SIR THERE THE
CAN STRUCK POLICY. EIGHTY TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE FOLLOW IDEAS
OUT THE- WHAT IT PERCENT BONUS
WHEN IS L. INCLUDES. PERCENT OF
THE UNIT OUT PORTAL AND THIS IS
FILE ROUGHLY. THE REACH OF A
LOT PERCENT OF FOR UNIT 235%
BONUS YOUR- ALREADY IT STATE
THAT BATACLAN. EIGHTY TWO
BEFORE FIVE. PM THE NUMBER.
THAT ACROSS YOU GET. THE WAY.
LAW WORK IS A KOREAN UP TO
THREE IN. WHICH ALLOW DEVELOP
TO ACTUALLY EXPAND ENVELOPE OF
BUILDING TO ACCOMMODATE THE OUT
OF RUBBLE IN POLICY THAT.
EIGHTY TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
EXPECT THE I DIDN'T IS TO A
CALM EVEN GREATER NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE. BUT DESPITE BILL.
REALLY GREAT. IN THE YEAR SO
CIRCULATED DIEGO ACROSS OF
REPORTS AND ON THE YEAR AUSTIN
OR THE ROCK MEASURE THE FIRST
WORRISOME UP FOR HUNDRED PER
INCREASE IN THE USE OF THE-
REALLY. PUBLISHED ALL CLIMATE
HOME AND IT SHOWED THAT MORE
THAN PER OF THE INSECURE
BECAUSE PRO WERE BEING ADDED
HALF MILE I PERFORMING TRAINS
WHICH IS CRUCIAL ACHIEVING SET
LOCAL INCREASE CARMICHAEL'S AND
MORE MOST CRUCIALLY THE PROGRAM
SHOWING THAT MORE THAN HALF
PROJECTS. PERMANENT IF. AREAS
AND THE SHOW HOW INCLUDING
PROBE LIKE AB THREE FOUR FIVE
HELLO CHIP AWAY AT THIS BECAUSE
ABOUT MERCURY THE DENTALS THIS
ALSO REASONS. FOR WE ARE A
LITTLE TOO MANY. SO IF YOU
COULD JUST WIND UP. HELLO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW GO
TO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
MORE PEOPLE I'M A STATE THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY UNDER
SUPPORTS- FOR- THIS LEGISLATION
HI IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY YES. MARK DIVERT
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
YOUR- PUBLIC STORAGE WAS
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF UP FOR GROWTH ACTION
CALIFORNIA A CO SPONSOR WITH
CIRCULATE AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SALARY FOR SAYING NINE WE
MOVE TWENTY FORTY TWENTY FORTY-
ONCE AGAIN TWENTY FORTY AS A-
EXCEPTIONALLY LONELY PLACE- NO
ONE IN THERE- WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES SO OPEN THE-
LINES. FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS GEN. AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE AM PLEASE SIMPLY SEND YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION ABOUT. AND THE
FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
ALTHOUGH THE FIRST LINE OF
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GERMAN SENATORS
GOODNESS KEEPS DONE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MAX NINE WILL GO TO ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
OLD THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OR
ONE OF YOUR LINE IS THE YOUR.
AUTO HELLO YOU CAN LEARN AND- I
WAS GOING TO CLAIM THIS YEAR'S
HER AND JUST BRING I AM AT WORK.
YOU AND THEN I LINE WILL COME
ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I DIDN'T EVEN THROW WITH THE
BAY AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION SUPPORT THANK.
EXXONMOBIL TO SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND IF YOU MATTER
IF NOT A VERY COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON REGULAR
FIFTY A CRANK ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME IN
SUPPORT. YOU CAN NEXT TO THE
LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALI WITH A QUITE HAVE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF AT A
THREE PEAT CAMPAIGN WHICH
INCLUDES THE THEATRICAL COUNTY
SEVENTY MG PARTNER IN A LOCAL
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY.
REPUBLICAN VALLEY AT. ALLEN OF
AS WELL CALLING ON THE BURKE
THE TEMPLE GO BAY AREA URBAN
PLANNER AND READ THE- AND COOK.
AN EXTRA BOTTLE LINE ONE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT WE
NEED ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PROVOCA MARKET. LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT. MEXICO
CAROLINA ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU KNOW WHY WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YEAR LINE
IS OPEN. LOUIS MANDE BE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA DMB IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. IN MEXICO LINE OF. ONE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD MORNING IMAGE OFFERED
TO YOU I LIVE IN BERKELEY AND I
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE BILL THE-
FERRERI ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT GO TELL
LINE AT ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MICHELLE RANTS ON
BEHALF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF ONE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS
PATRICK MORAN WITH AARON
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND NEXT BOTTLE I
KNOW FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS ERIN EVAN WE HAVE
OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NEXT ON
THE LINE OF ONE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
DEUTSCHEN I AM- RECTOR AND
JENNIFER JESSICA AND I'M
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO A LINE
OF FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS BILL. FROM THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND AS
A REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. AND THAT IF SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE.
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO A LINE OF ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NO ONE FORTY
EIGHT WE ARE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
MEMO MONTHS ALIGN OF ONE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DIFFICULTY BEING CURRENT GROUND
POWELL ALSO ON BEHALF OF LIFE
FOR EVERYONE IN SUPPORT. AND AS
A REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
HERE BECAUSE THIS LEGISLATION.
C. NINE WILL NOT RETURN TWENTY
FORTY. I DON'T SEE ANYONE THERE
WILL NOW MOVES TO THE PHONE
LINES AGAIN THIS IS OPPOSITION.
TO EIGHT TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE FIVE AND YOU MAY PRECEDED.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU'RE AN
OPPOSITE END OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. AND A LINE OF EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MARY JACK IN THE NUMBER OF
PRESERVING MENACE WHICH SUPPORT
BOTH THE FORMAL HOUSING AND
PROTECTING COOKBOOK COMMUNITIES
AND WE OPPOSE THE BILL AS
RECEIVED THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I WILL RESET
PETROCELLI'S WITH UNITED STATES
EMISSIONS FROM THE DEVASTATED
MISSION COMMUNITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS WRITTEN THANK YOU. THE
NEXT TO GO TO A LOT. SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS CAROL
THE HALF FULL AYE OPPOSED BAIL.
IN MEXICO THE LINE UP TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MARC
WELCOME TRANSPARENT PROCESS AND
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. AN ACTUAL QUOTE A
LINE OF ONE FIFTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YES CATHERINE OUR
DON'T BE HAPPY OPEN SPACE AND
HABITAT SUPPORT GROUP UPSET THE
OCEAN EDGE IN OPPOSE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE NEW JERSEY
SECRETARY HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION IN THE SOUTH BAY
AND CALIFORNIA CITIZENS OKAY.
PLANT CITY CONTROL OVER AND
GREEN SPACES YET ANOTHER
IMMORTAL HAND OUT TO DEVELOPERS
TO LUXURY HOUSING WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. TWO THREE FOUR FIVE.
MEXICO LINE OF FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY GEORGE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE THE
WESTERN CENTER IS A MEMBER THE
BILL WE ARE OPPOSITION YEAH.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
CAROL UP IN- PROTECTING OUR
FOOTHILL COMMUNITIES OPPOSED.
YEAH IT TOOK OUT A LINE OF
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THE BOND JOHNSON FROM
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITY FROM
DISASTROUS FIRE EVACUATIONS IN
TRAFFIC THAT. AND THEN WE DON'T
NEED TO INCREASE DENSITY WHERE.
WE HAVE A PANDEMIC ON ON AND WE
HAVE TRIED. IRAN I AM WE OPPOSE.
IN THE NEXT FINAL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY LEARN- PRESIDENT PRO TEM
OF THE WEST TO LOCAL LAKE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION RATHER.
THIS ALLOWS. IT TO A NORMA SAID
INCREASE IN BUILDINGS WITH TOO
SMALL A PERCENTAGE AFFORDABLE
UNITS THIS IS NOT A GOOD DEAL
COBIT NINETEEN IT OFFERS. LIGHT
NOT COME HOUSING WHILE
DEVELOPERS OVERRIDE CITY
STANDARD PLEASE KEEP CONTROL OF
LOCAL STRONG A POSE THE LESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. YOU FIND
WHAT. ONE FORTY YOUR LINE OF
THE- HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID FOR
I'M A NATIVE SANFORD EVER SINCE
IT WILL DRAW. CISCO IS BEEN
ABOVE WOMAN KHANUM WORKER IN A
BUS THIS BILL AS WRITTEN A DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR LOCAL CONTROL AND
AS MEMBER SENDING PEOPLE
WEBSITE THAT I'M- WRONG WITH.
THE LINE WILL BE FROM ONE FIFTY
TWO. YOUR LAST NAME. IN A
MESSAGE CHARACTER. I'M OF THE
BE IF YOU WANT TO BE IN OFFICE
TO THE BILL. AN EXCELLENT. ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BEGAN AGAIN LUXURY HOUSING NOT
ENOUGH AFFORDABLE I OPPOSE. YOU
AN ACTUAL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ON A LAWLER ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN POVERTY HELLO
WORLD THE CONSOLIDATION ONLY
BEEN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AT THE TIME BUT STILL
VERY HOPEFUL WE CAN FIND A-
PART. FINAL COME FROM LINE FOUR
YOUR LINE OF THE- GETTING INTO
LIVABLE REVERSE AND VALLEY WE
NEED TO THAT. THE AVAILABILITY
OF AFFORDABLE UNITS WHILE
MINIMIZING OVERDEVELOPMENT.
BILL BILL BILL REGINA OPPOSE.
CAN NEXT FINAL VOTE TO IT
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SURE MEMBERS JASON RYAN WITH
LEE CALIFORNIA CITIES- WE ARE
OPPOSING WAS AMENDED. SENATE
NEXT LINE WILL GO TO THE ONE.
YOUR AND SO. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KELLY HILL WITH UNITED
THE PRESIDENT SAN FRANCISCO WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AND THEN I CAN
FINAL VOTE WITH ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LONG IS OPEN. ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GIVEN THE
NEXT FINAL MOVE ONTO IS FINE
ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BRIAN BOWN WESTERN
OVERCROWDING AND OVERBUILDING
IS UNHEALTHY SURE ONLY OPPOSE.
THE NEXT FINAL CALL TO IT ONE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
FINANCING ONLINE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AND GEGEN
FRANKLIN COURT OF COALITION IN
HOLLYWOOD 50% IDENTITY AND
STILL DOES NOTHING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOMELESS
CRISIS IN LOS ANGELES THANK YOU.
MEXICO TOLD ONE SIXTY THREE
YOUR- GOOD MORNING CHRISTINE
ROBINSON CALLING FROM THE EAST
BAY NEAR LAFAYETTE I'M IN A
POSITION ON A LONG BY NEIGHBORS
DUE TO. TOO MANY PEOPLE AND WE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT EVACUATION OF
THE ROLLING HILLS AND VALLEYS
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR AREA THANK
YOU. EXTROVERTED LINE OF ONE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JENNIFER I'M A
RESIDENT OF VERY CONGESTED SAN
FRANCISCO SO I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CAROLINA ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR REPRESENTING THE FIELDS
THAT IN COMPANIES STRONG
SUPPORTER OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY
AND- I MAY BE ON THE WRONG LINE
BUTTON IN SUPPORT STILL. YOU.
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS- RECALL WITH-
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA- THIS BILL
DOES NOT PROVIDE ANYWHERE NEAR
THE LEVELS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT ARE NEEDED TO
PROVIDE THESE BIG- BONUSES- SO
WE ARE IN A WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IN OUR
NEXT FINAL COME FROM ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND LIMóN TO LINE ONE FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND
ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IN A VERY MINOR FAIR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIXTY SEVEN
UNITED OPEN YOU HAVE A SOME YOU.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. SIR DO YOU
KNOW MY NUMBER JILL STUART THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WHICH
INCLUDES ENGINEER HER TREES
COUNTY Y. LOS ANGELES
INTERESTED IN ENVIRONMENT
CREATING A CALL. FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT AND WITH LITTLE
CALIFORNIA. A CLOSE LOOK AT THE-
AND WHAT WE SEE IS THAT IT ADDS
IT SMALL 122% MORE AFFORDABLE
UNITS BUT THE DEVELOPER CAN
ALMOST ELIMINATE ALL LOCAL
CONTROLS ON HIGH. FOCUS STATES
PARKING DESIGN REVIEW BACK. OR
ANY OTHER ISSUE BUILDING. ATION
AND SPRINKLING THE NEW UNITS
IT'S JUST NOT IN THE GAME CAN
MEET THIS NEED TO BE COMPLETELY
REWRITTEN THANK YOU. THE LION
ONE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU HAVEN'T SENT ME AT
ONE FORTY FOUR. HELLO ONE FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB. TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO. ONE
ZERO THREE IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE. AND WE
HAVE ORDERED ONLINE ONE FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
WITH THE CITY OF HIDDEN HILLS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. SENATE
ONE AND ZERO PROPOSITIONS OF AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE. ZERO.
ONE MOMENT A SECURE WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMING IN. AND AS A
REMINDER OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THAT'LL
COME FROM THE LINE OF NINETY
ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GALLAGHER FROM PALO ALTO'S FOR
SENSIBLE JOHNNY THIS IS NOT
THAT BILL FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NEEDS FOR DEVELOPERS TO
START HI OPEN SPACE PARKING
SATISFACTION CETERA CAN BUILD
LUXURY HOUSING. THANK YOU WE
OPPOSE IT. NAZARIAN ONE ZERO
ROBERT OF AB. TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY
THAT CONCLUDES OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY- WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS REGARDING
AB. TWENTY THREE FORTY CENTER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I'M I'M A STRUGGLE THIS
ONE LET ME JUST SAY THAT I'VE
SUPPORTED PROBABLY EVERY SINGLE
HOUSING. BILL THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED MOSTLY
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY
WHAT A CRISIS WE HAVE AND THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
THINGS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
THERE ARE SOME COMMUNITIES ARE
RESISTANT AND SOME THAT. THAT
AND THEN WITH THEY NEEDED TO
BUT- WHEN I LOOK AT THIS I
WORRY BECAUSE THIS MAY HAVE
WORKED IN SAN DIEGO BUT SAN
DIEGO IS A IS A HIGHLY
URBANIZED. AS I BELIEVE THAT.
BUST TRANSFER. PUBLIC COUNTY.
SYSTEM AND THAT REALLY IS
BENEFICIAL WHEN YOU'RE STARTING
THE INCREASED DENSITIES AND- I
DID BONUS THEY WITH THIS FOR
DOES. ABOUT IT SO I GET
CONCERNED BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
PUSHING FOR US TO TAKE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS DOLLARS AND USE
IT TO BUILD PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS. INTO
THE SUBURBS. BRINKLEY THAT
REALLY HASN'T TO FRUITION AND
SO- IF I COULD CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO PAGE FIVE. OF THE
ANALYSIS WHAT WHAT THE ANALYSIS
SAYS IS AND I AND I WAS TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND. AS YOU. DO YOU
MOVE THROUGH THE DENSITY
BONUSES WHERE THE IMPACTS ON
YOUR DEVELOPMENT PLAN AND
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS ALWAYS GOOD
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN START
TO DECIDE WHAT SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE INCENTIVES ARE AND- THE
DENSITY BONUS. BECAUSE IT IT.
OPPORTUNITY FOR. US TO SEE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILT BUT-
BUT ON PAGE FIVE. THE ITEM NO
TEN TALKS ABOUT REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF PARKING. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CAN REQUIRE OF A
100% AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENTS. I
CHECKED FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. TO FROM POINT FIVE
SPACES PER UNIT TO ZERO SPACES
PER UNIT AND WHAT IMMEDIATELY
JUMPS INTO MY MIND IS FOR ALL
THE UNITS WHICH MEANS THERE
WOULD BE NO PARKING REQUIREMENT
AS I READ THAT SENTENCE THE
PARKING REQUIREMENT FOR PROJECT.
AND DISTINGUISH. A TWENTY UNIT
PROJECT. AND A TWO HUNDRED UNIT
PROJECT AND SO I GET CONCERNED
ABOUT. USING AND URBAN. MODEL
AND SAYING THIS IS HOW WE
SHOULD INTERPRET DENSITY
BONUSES ALL OVER THE STATE SO I
HATE TO PUT YOU IN A POSITION
OF TRYING TO DEFEND THAT WHAT
AND THEN BUT THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE I'M COMING. I REALLY LIKE
ON SEPT IN THE AND THEN I
STARTED AT THE DETAIL AND I'M
I'M REALLY WORRIED THAT IF IT
DOESN'T WORK WELL IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE RICH I
REPRESENTS- IF YOU CAN ANSWER
THAT AND- THAT WOULD BE FINE.
TO CHECK. ON OUR WITNESS. SIR
PLEASE. ABSOLUTELY MISTER
PARENT. YEAH THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION- I THINK THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY THE BEST WAY TO THINK
ABOUT THAT IS THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THAT ELEMENT TO THE BILL
DOESN'T. MEAN THAT AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPMENTS WON'T HAVE PARKING
WHAT IT MEANS IS THAT-
DEVELOPER YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES
IT BROWN PROFIT AND HE WILL GET.
HOW MUCH PARKING THEY NEED FOR
THE OF THE- BUT THE CREATING
WHOLE. AND SO AT AS OPPOSED TO
HAVE IT BE CREATED BY. BY US
COUNCIL SUPER TO FOR EXAMPLE OF
A DEVELOPER IS DOING A PROJECT
FOR FAMILY HOMELESS VETERANS
WHO MADE IT AND THEY HAPPEN TO
KNOW. THAT THEIR POPULATION.
UNLIKE CARS THE NATION IS PARTY
AT THE NECESSARY .COM THEIR-
NEXT OPPOSED POINT TO A. A SET
OF RULES THIS WHICH MIGHT HELP
EARLIER AND JUST SHARE TO WHAT
IS THIS BILL DOES NOT MAKE ANY
CHANGES TO PARKING. MINIMUMS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
AND PROJECTS THAT ARE ON YOUR
TRANSIT I DIDN'T SEE BONUS LAW
CURRENTLY ALREADY DOES THIS
JUST THIS JUST MAKES A LITTLE
MORE ADVANTAGEOUS FOR
DEVELOPERS USING. BY ME TO ON
TO THAT I JUST BE OF IT IS A
NOT IN ANY WAY. A DEVELOPER
WHETHER IT'S A NUMBER FOR ABOUT
TO. OR WHATEVER TO HAVE MORE.
AND WHAT IT DOES IS PREVENT A
CUTTER. APPROACH BECAUSE WE
HAVE. SOME LOCAL LAWS THAT BUT
YOU HAVE TO THIS MINIMUM.
INSTEAD OF ABOUT PARKS THAT IF
YOU'RE A- URBAN I. HI TRANSIT
AREA YOU GOING TO LOS PARK.
THERE IS AN AREA WITH TREND
NEARBY WITH. IT'S LIKELY UP.
THE BILL OVER TO MAKE I MUCH
BUT WE BASICALLY BY PROJECT
INSTEAD OF A COOKIE CUTTER. LOS
ST STE THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I
PUT THE CALM BUT I GUESS WHAT
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS WHO
HAS THE ABILITY TO MAKE THE
FINAL DECISION IN THE END. AND
I AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE IN.
THAT THAT I HAVE SUPPORTED
REDUCED REQUIREMENTS THAT'S NOT
THE ISSUE. THE ISSUE IS WHO
MAKES THE DECISION AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT. THINGS CHANGE OF
TIME. I'D SAY EVERY DAY IN IRAQ
HAVE NOT SEEN A REDUCTION IN
VEHICLES AND SO MOST OF THE
HOUSING UNITS. IN THE CITY OF
SALINAS AND IN A LOT OF OTHER
COMMUNITIES ARE THREE AND FOUR
CARS PER UNIT BECAUSE ARE SO
OVERCROWDED. SO MY CONCERN IS.
TO NOT HAVE A COOKIE CUTTER
APPROACH TO ALLOWING A WAIVER
IF YOU'RE DOING A DENSITY BONUS
THAT THEN DOESN'T GIVE THE CITY
COUNCIL AND ABILITY TO SAY YOU
GOT A ROUTE WHERE YOUR- YOUR
FOLKS ARE GOING TO PARTICIPATE.
IN FOR THIS HOUSE IS PAID.
THIRTY IN NEIGHBORHOODS IT I'VE
SEEN IT ALREADY AND SO THAT I
JUST WANT TO GET A SENSE I'M
GONNA LAY OFF FOR THIS RIGHT
NOW I'M GONNA GO BACK. THIS
HEARING- UP HI I'M CONCERNED
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
THE- I AM EXPERT TESTIMONY-
WHETHER IT'S A NONPROFIT
DEVELOPER. OR IT'S A FOR PROFIT
DEVELOPER IN IN MY EXPERIENCE
IT'S STILL THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
ARE RENTING AND THEY HAVE THE
SAME VEHICLES AND YOU JUST. MS
SO. I MADE TWENTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR A
SENATOR ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE US
ANYTHING CENTER KELSEY. MISTER
CHAIRMAN PAGE NINE ABOUT THE
OPPOSITION AND USUALLY THE
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND WESTERN CENTER
LARA POVERTY ARE CHAMPIONS ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT LOCALITIES SAID
ADOPTED A SUPER DENSITY BONUS
THAT THIS LAW WILL SOMEHOW
SKILL SET UP ACTIVE AND THEY
WERE FROM HARMONY. I MIGHT IT
IS THE IN THE PRESENT WONDERING
IF THAT THAT PARTICULAR CONCERN
HAS BEEN ADDRESS. FIVE ZERO MR
PERRIN MR PERRIN PLEASE UNDER
PERRIN YOU'D LIKE PLEASE
RESPOND WITH A CALL. OKAY
SENATOR. THE NEW VERSION OF THE
BILL IS A CAR OUT TO HOLD
HARMLESS AND THAT HAVE THE A
PRE EXISTING BONUS. THAT THE
BUT WHAT'S ACTUALLY 35% THAT
ALREADY AND STATE LAW SO THAT
IT COULD OPTION EIGHTY TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE ONE NOT THE
CITY WALK ANGELES CA. MORE.
YEAH IT. FOR ADDITIONAL ARE
COMMENTS REGARDING AB. TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE. I SEE NINE SO
SAID ARE ALSO A WOULD YOU LIKE
TO. AGAIN TO MY OPENING
REMARKS- WE REALLY HAVE A ISSUE
BOTH OF AFFORDABILITY AND
AVAILABILITY AND I HOPE THIS IS
THIS IS ONE TOOL IN OUR BOX TO
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE BOTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. VERY MUCH- WE WILL NOW
DO WE HAVE A MOTION I DON'T
REMEMBER XIN. THROUGH A MOTION
ON AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE.
BUT CENTER ROTH MOVES THE BILL-
AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LORENA GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CENTER WHERE HI WIENER AYE
MORRELL. I'M NOT M<c.cyan> NOT THAT</c>
IN BATES. DOT VOTING BATES
NORTHERN CABALLERO. CARRERO NOT
VOTING TO RUSSELL HI DORADO
MCGUIRE MORLOCK NOT VOTING
MORLOCK NOT VOTING ROTH. ROTH
AYE SKINNER HI SKINNER HI
NUMBER. CASKEY HI CASKEY I.
FIVE VOTES OKAY THE BILL'S FIVE
VOTES WILL PUT HER ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS- OKAY WE
WILL NOW GO TO OUR NEXT BILL-
ITEM NINE IF THE TWENTY FOUR OH
FIVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. UNDER
AND SO BECAUSE ARE VERY CHAIR
CENTER MORALE IS PRETTY
REMOTELY SENATOR MORE LOCK HAS
GRACIOUSLY AGREED- TO PRESIDE
OVER THE PRESENTATION OF THIS
BILL CENTER. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER MR SURE YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
CENTER. BY COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY
FOUR OH FIVE WHICH I'M
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE.
ESTABLISHES A RIGHT TO HOUSING
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS AFFECTED IN
TWENTY TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY
FOUR FIVE EMPHASIZES THAT
PERMIT THING IS THE ONLY WAY.
WE CAN END HOMELESSNESS A
FRAMEWORK. IN PRACTICE IT FOR
CRIED HOMELESSNESS. INCLUDING
PER IN THE FOR LOSING THEIR IN
THE FIRST PLACE. PROVIDING
EMERGENCY ACCOMMODATIONS WITH
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES SHOULD
SOMEONE LOSE OUR HOME- AND
TRANSITIONING INDIVIDUALS TO
PERMANENT HOUSING. FOR
FOSTERING A CULTURE OF DIGNITY
AND RESPECT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS TO MINIMIZE TRAUMA AND
DISRUPTION TODAY A LIFE. THE
BILL ALSO SERVICES GREATER
COORDINATION ACROSS STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES TO
STREAMLINE AND INTEGRATE
POLICIES. SAYS TO REDUCE HOW.
AND THE BILLS FROM ARE THANKS
OF COURSE SUPERVISOR. TO COVER
NINETEEN POUND ACT THERE WERE
NO EXPERIENCING FRIENDS A
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC WELL BEING
OF EVERY PERSON NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE ARE AND HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE WANT TO CHECK. HOMELESS WE
CAN FULLY RECOVER PANDEMIC. BUT
EVERY IS HOUSE ESTABLISHED THIS
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT HOUSING. I'M
TERRY EFFORT TO CREATE NEEDED
ACCOUNTABILITY COLORS ARE ASKED
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. I TESTIFY IN
BY PHONE IS BOOKER PEARSON
REPRESENTING BOUND HOUSE- AND
WE WILL GO TO. OUR WITNESS
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU TRAIL
WIENER- I AM LOOKING FIGURES.
REPRESENTING UP WITH BROWNELLS
AND MEMBER OF THE LOS ANGELES
PUBLISHED ALREADY COMMISSION
AND CHAIR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY COMMISSION FOR PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES IN ADDITION TO
THE SUPPORTERS LISTED DIGEST.
THE L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAS PASSED A MOTION
OF SUPPORT AND THE LA CITY
COUNCIL PRESIDENT WITH FIVE CO
SPONSORS HAS INTRODUCED A
MOTION TO SUPPORT LOS ANGELES
MAYOR GARCETTI HAS WRITTEN.
SUPPORTIVE IT TO FIVE. THE BILL
SET SOME OF. TO PROVIDE SAFE
DECENT AND AFFORDABLE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS USING THE DATA
BEST PRACTICES WELL PREVENTION
DIVERSION AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING USUALLY CRISIS HOUSING
ONLY. THAT IS CENTER TO WINNER
RECENTLY TWEETED GOVERNOR LUCY
AND MAYOR STEINBERG HAVE
STATED. HAVING OVER. ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE ON OUR
STREETS EVERY NIGHT. PERCENT OF
ALL CHILDREN HOMES IN THE
UNITED STATES CANNOT PERSIST
AND IS A MORAL FAILURE. IN
ADDITION TO THE UNCONSCIONABLE
HUMAN CALLS PUBLIC NOR IN OUR
OWN HOUSE WHICH COMES WITH A
VERY HIGH. ECONOMIC COACH
TWENTY ONE PERSON OF HOMELESS
IN THE- ON L. YEAH 55% LOWS ON
SHELTER. OVER ONE YEAR. FAR
MENTALLY WAS SIMILAR OUTCOME
DRUGS I ABUSE AND PHYSICAL
ILLNESS THIS CALL SINCE PUBLIC
TO INCREASE. EXPONENTIALLY AND
MUCH. THE COST TO HOUSE.
BECAUSE OF HOMELESS CHILDREN
TAKEN INTO FOUR CARE AND
ENTERING PRISON OR EXCEEDS A
HOUSES EIGHTY SEVEN PER OF THIS
YEAR COULD NOT GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL. COALITION THIS IS
A MOST EXTRA MAN. OF IT IS S.
TIME THAT WE ADDRESS THE SMALL.
AMOUNT OF AND THANK YOU CAN
CRISIS I'D LIKE TO MY GRATITUDE
ASSEMBLY BURKE FOR ALL THIS
BILL. THANK YOU FOR PERSON IS
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES THAT
YOU HAVE. IN SUPPORT SENATOR
WIENER. I KNOW MR- NO CENTER
OKAY THANK YOU THEN- MADAM OF
MODERATOR LET'S HEAR FROM.
THOSE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FOUR ZERO FIVE. I AM
CENTER BY METERS ONE ANNOUNCER
AFTER THIS BILL IS NOT WHETHER
IT ENDS AT ONE OR SOME OF THE
TIME WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
LUNCH BREAK RIGHT AFTER THIS
BILL. SO YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. THEN WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AGAIN THIS KEEPS DONE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEXICO ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. GIVE AN EXTRA COCOA
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BEARABLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MEXICO CAROLINA OF ONE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN CHAIR
MEMBERS BUDGET OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. IN MEXICO
AT THE LINE OF EIGHTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO JACK A
MEMBER OF CITIZENS FOR LEARNING
BENEFITS AND WE- ARE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AUTUMN BURKE AND
HOUSING FOR ALL THE- THINGS.
PFENEX WE'LL GO TO LINE UP
FORTY SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
A LITTLE NINETY FROM THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AN EXTRA CULTURAL LINE
OF FIFTY THREE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE WILL
GO DOWN TO THE LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REBECCA MARKETS FOR BEHALF OF
LEADING H. CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR ALL
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT
COULD LOSE MY GENERATION
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC COUNTY AND
ALSO IN SUPPORT SHE- AND ADDED
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FOUR OLD FIVE. ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE
ONE COMING. NOT GONNA COME UP A
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT ALWAYS WITH
ALL REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN SUPPORT. REMINDER TO ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE. ONE
ZERO IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
FOUR OH FIVE. AND THERE IS NO
ONE IF YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR AND STAYING
WITH THE THEME OF GOING IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WE ARE BLESSED TO HAVE A
FEW PEOPLE IN THE GALLERY SO
WHY DON'T WE START. WITH THOSE
IN THE GALLERY. HI MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- ALEX TORRES ON BEHALF
OF HANDS IN HERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND MARK
STIVERS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. ALRIGHT THEN
DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ON THE RECORD IS STATING HE
WANTED TO HAVE A AN OPENING
STATEMENT OF SENATOR WIENER DO
WE- THERE. THERE ARE I DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
THAT- WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO FOUR OH
FIVE. SEEING NINE I DIDN'T SEE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO
WILL TAKE. THOSE THAT ARE ON
THE LINE MADAME MODERATOR
YOU'RE BACK IN CONTROL. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS BILL
DOES NOTHING FOR OUR CURRENT
HOMELESS POPULATION AND ONLY
SPECULATE. ON FUTURE HOMELESS
DUE TO COLD NINETEEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT EXTROVERT SO I KNOW OF
AND NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS CAROL HASKELL
AND I DON'T SEE HOW THIS BILL
CAN. THE HOUSING AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE ECONOMIC-
MESSAGES FOR WHICH JACKET SO I
OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
IN THE NEXT MEXICO SO LINE AND
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI A
MAJOR SETBACK I THINK IT'S
WONDERFUL SO WONDERFUL AND
MORALLY FABULOUS IF YOU'LL BE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOUSING THE
HOMELESS THE PROBLEM IS THE
CONVERSATION WAS JUST HEAR
ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS AND
THERE'S NOTHING THAT I CAN SEE
IN ANY OF THESE BILLS THAT DOES
ANYTHING TO HELP. MENTALLY ILL
TO MAKE UP A LARGE PORTION OF
THE HOMELESS I THINK THAT
THAT'S A HUGE MISS AND ALL OF
THESE REZONING BILLS THAT
YOU'RE DOING THAT HOW THE
NOTION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND A REMINDER IF
YOU ARE OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
FOUR OH FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR- THAT TAKES US
TO THE COMMITTEE DO I HAVE ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK TO THE
BILL. SEEING NONE SENATOR
WIENER YOU HAVE. THE FLOOR
CLOSE. I'M SORRY DESERVES ALL
CAPS ARE YOU MISTER CHAIR
THAT'S OKAY I'M PREPARED TO
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU NOW
I'LL GET THERE CENTER WINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I THANK
VERY MUCH JUST IN RESPONSE TO
LAST COMMENT ON THIS COMMITTEE
DOES NOT COURTS HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER. MENTAL
HEALTH- AND I WOULD FOR THE
CALLER TO THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEES
THAT. ARE HEARING A NUMBER OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
BILLS I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
ADAM SECRETARY LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. THIS ISA SEPARATE BILL
TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WINNER. WINNER I'D
MORALE. NO MORALE NO BATES.
BATES SNOW CABALLERO HI
CABALLERO- TO RUSSELL HI
TORONTO BY MCGUIRE. MORLOCK NO
MORE LOOK NO ROTH. ROTH AYE
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
BOMBERG FIVE HOTEL SKI HI
WITHOUT SKI I'D- SEVEN A THREE.
TERM VOTED SEVEN TO THREE- AND
WE WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS BY THE
COLLEAGUES AS I INDICATED WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE A LUNCH BREAK
NOW IT IS APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
FIFTY- WE WILL RECONVENE AT ONE
THIRTY- AND THE NEXT BUT WE
WILL BE HERE WHEN WE COME BACK
WE'LL BE ITEM TWELVE. SB THIRTY
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HI
CHIU SAID WE ARE NOW IN RECESS.
UNTIL ONE THIRTY THANK YOU.
COLLEGE WE ARE RESUMING AFTER
COMMITTEE HEARING OF. AUGUST
FIFTH- WE NOW HAVE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
AND LOCAL PLANNING AND- MR CHIU
WERE HONORED TO HAVE YOU HERE
GOOD FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS. FORTY IS
PLEASE GET THE CREDIT THEY
DESERVE WHEN THEY ALLOW FOR UP
TO FOUR UNITS PER PARCEL. WEBER
STATE CITIES AND COUNTIES EARLY
CREATING HOUSING ELEMENTS FOR
SUBMISSION TO EXCEEDING. THIS
HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS OCCURS
EVERY EIGHT YEARS AS EVERYONE
KNOWS BUT THIS TIME IT'S GOING
TO LOOK DIFFERENT DUE TO THE
WORK THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
FOUND IN. WE REQUIRE THE STATE
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING OVERALL
HELP TRIPLEX THIS EXPECTED.
HELLO MILLIONS OF UNITS THAT
HAVE BEEN BUILT. THIS TIME
AROUND THE IS GOING TO BE HIGH
FOR LOW TOURIST. AND THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO MAKE HARD
DECISIONS THAT MADE BEEN
POSTPONED FOR DECADES. ONE OF
THOSE DECISIONS MIGHT ALLOW
MORE HOUSING IN NEIGHBORHOODS.
THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
SINGLE FAMILY. THERE'S A LOT TO
LIKE ABOUT SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
THIS BILL IS NOT SAYING
ANYTHING ABOUT THEM. BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE ZONE A
GREAT DEAL OF THE LAND IN OUR
STATE TO SOME REASONS WHICH HAS
A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS ABOUT THE
EFFICIENCY OF EFFICIENT USE OF
LAND. GIVEN GIVEN CHANGING
PLAN. WILDFIRE RISK IN
PUNISHING COMMUTES. THIS BILL
SAYS IS THAT. THE STATE WILL
GUARANTEE CITIES CREDIT TOWARD
THEIR STATE ISSUED HOUSING
TARGETS FOR EVERY SITE THAT IS
UP SOON FROM SINGLE FAMILY FOUR
PLEXUS. THE VALUE TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES IS THAT THEY CAN
CALCULATE THIS CREDIT UP FRONT.
RATHER THAN AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS AFTER AN EXPENSIVE AND
TIMELY PROCESS OF ANALYSIS BY
LOCALS AND REVIEW BY THE STATE.
THIS BILL BUILD GUARDRAILS I'M
SURE THE NEW UNITS COULD BE
CREATED. ACCORDING TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MAKES AND BY
RIGHT. THAT THERE AREN'T OTHER
STANDARDS THAT RENDERED THE UPS
OWNING IN FEASIBLE. AND CITIES
ARE ALSO INCENTIVIZED TO GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE CREDIT
GRANTED BY THIS BILL ALLOWING
HEDT GIVEN ADDITIONAL CREDIT IF
THEY DO SO. THIS BILL BALANCES
THE NEEDS ARE IN TERMS OF
HOUSING PRODUCTION. AND IS
SUPPORTED BY BOTH EMTS ON ONE
SIDE AND PRO HOUSING. FORCES AS
WELL AS CITIES AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT WILL RESULT. IN MORE
HOUSING IN LOCATIONS CHOSEN BY
CITIES IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEIR CONSTITUENTS WITHOUT.
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESS WHOSE CHRISLEY. FROM
SIX ACT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. MR LEE
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS CRISPLY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FORTY- AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED- THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO EMPOWER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NOT A BILL
THAT TAKES AWAY LOCAL CONTROL.
AS THE COMMITTEE REALIZES
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
LEGISLATION RECENTLY THAT'S NOT
TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
IDENTIFY ADEQUATE SITES THIS
BILL ACTUALLY TAKES THE
OPPOSITE APPROACH BY GIVING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MORE
CERTAINTY THAT THESE SITES WILL
BE ACCEPTED INTO THEIR
INVENTORIES. REMEMBER NOTE IT
CREATES A FULL AND NOT A
CEILING. WHILE THERE IS
RESTRICTIONS IN THE BILL
LIMITING- THIS DECIDES 210% OF
YOUR ABOVE MODERATE INCOME
SITES. WE'RE VERY INTERESTED TO
SEE HOW THIS BILL WORKS IN
PRACTICE AND CONSIDER IN THE
FUTURE INCREASING THAT
PROPORTION- IN THE MEANTIME WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS CREATIVITY ON THIS
APPROACH. IN A STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US TO REFINE THE
BILL. WE REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEE. NUMBER
TWO DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES- THEN WE WILL GO TO
THE GALLERY TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY WITNESSES THAT WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB THIRTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
MADAME MODERATOR YOU STILL WITH
US. I AM WILL SHARE. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FORTY IN MY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. WE WILL GO TO OUR
FIRST LINE. ONE MOMENT UP TO
FIFTY. YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE NEXT ONE OF SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOU CAN STROLL WITH
THE BAY AREA HOUSING ADVOCATES
ECO SESSION IN SUPPORT OF. THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NECKLINE WILL BE CONFIRMED
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOLLY
FOR ME THEY HAVE IF THE
BLACKHAWKS PUBLIC AFFAIRS-
IMPORTED THE BUILDING ON BEHALF
THAT THREE PIECE CAMPAIGN WHICH
INCLUDES SAN FRANCISCO
FOUNDATION AND TEAMS YOU
PARTNER AS WELL AS HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IS IN
SUPPORT AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA URBAN PLANNING AND
RESEARCH YOU ALSO KNOWN AS-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT.
TEN THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GEORGIA COMPLAINED OF
SUFFOCATION IN SUPPORT. IN
MEXICO THE LINE OF TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MARIN DAY WOULD
CALIFORNIA BE ESPECIALLY WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT BOARD. WELL THE
LINE- ONE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SURE MEMBERS JASON
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES WE ARE
ALSO SUPPORTED THE MEASURE. YOU
CAN IN MEXICO TO THE LINE OF
ONE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD COUNTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NEXT TO
A LINE OF ONE AND NINETY SIX.
ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORE SUNDAY FROM LOS
ANGELES CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SANTA MONICA THE IN THE- JUST
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS THANKS.
MEXICO THE LINE UP TO THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS WENT. FROM LOS ANGELES.
PART OF SHE'D BE CALLING IT
PART OF THE BILL. CONNECT. ONE
NINETY SEVEN POINT NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
GOING TO VOICE ON CALLING FROM
THEN I WAS ON BEHALF OF A SAID
BMB AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. Q. AND NEXT LINE OF.
THIRTY EIGHT. THREE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
STILL BE- FERRARI ON BEHALF OF
FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT. TALK OF A
LINE OF TWO FORTY ONE TO FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. AN ACTUAL LINE UP
TO NINETEEN TO NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JORDAN BRYANT ON BEHALF
OF AN INSULT FOR EVERYONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER Q. EIGHTY THIRTY FORTY
THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE OF Q.
ALL FORWARD TO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LAKE ROAD
CALIFORNIA CALLING SUPPORT WITH
ABUNDANT HOUSING OFFICE. THE
NEW. MEXICO. NINE TWO OH EIGHT
TWO OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI BABY WITH A FOR EVERYONE AND
I AM CALLING IN SUPPORT AS WELL.
HE BROUGH LINE OF TWO THIRTY
NINE TO THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS WHERE WITH
EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE AND ALSO
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK. YOU
CAN'T. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE OF ONE EIGHTY NINE ONE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
K. MANY TREATING. OTHER THAN
THE ONE THAT CAUGHT AND I
RESPECT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FOUR
THANK YOU. AN ACTUAL CULTURAL
OF ONE NINETY EIGHT POINT
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS A LITTLE FROM THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN MEXICO
LINE UP TO FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
FORCE FIELDS TO THE COMPANY IN
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS ONLY
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIAN BE
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT TIME
WE'LL GO TO TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK TO TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS STACEY NINETEEN I'M CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THE NEXT LINE OF
A TWO FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO OKAY GO TO SCHOOL
IN SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND A
MEMBER OF SOUTH BAY YEMENI AND
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. YOU MEXICO CAROLINA
OVER TO FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHE HELLO MY NAME IS
ARE YOU WHEN HE I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO GIVE ME
DEMOCRATS. WOULD LIKE SHOW OUR
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL. AN
EXTRA LINE OF TWO FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
ALEXANDRIA CONTRARY TO
CALIFORNIA YOU ME AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I THINK YOU. GOT A LINE OF Q.
FORTY NINE TO FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO ALSO LONGER
THAN WITH HEALTHCARE CAMINO
WITHIN. SIX THANK YOU. CONNECT
OTHER LINE OF TWO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIDLEY SCOTT
KELLY FOR ME REALLY SANTA CRUZ
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT ALTHOUGH LINE UP TO
FIFTY TO FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT IT IS NOW FREE TO YOU
TODAY IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AN OVER LINE UP TO FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COULD BE OCCURRING ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY AND HOME CALLING
IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF TWO FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS HENRY
HOW KERN CALLING FROM SANTA
CRUZ UNITY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. HE AN EXTRA COAT TO LINE
UP Q. FORTY FOUR. I KNOW THE
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS ROBERT
BOTTOM FELL CALLING O BEHALF
OF FINING PEOPLE PARK
COMPETITORS CALIFORNIANS FROM
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MEXICO THE
LINE UP. TWO SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ARIELLE STARR AND CALLING FROM
OAKLAND REPRESENTING EAST BAY
FOR EVERYONE I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT IN YOU MUCH YOU. AND AS
A REMINDER IF YOU RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FORTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FORTY ONE
ZERO NOW. AND THERE ARE NO MORE
IN Q. MESSENGER BETTER
MODERATOR YOU AND YOUR
WITNESSES DID A VERY
PROFESSIONAL JOB VERY
IMPRESSIVE ROUND OF CALLS IN.
THAT TAKES US NOW TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
FORMAL WITNESSES THAT- ARE
LOOKING TO. SINCE THE. HEARING
NONE I SEE NO ONE UP IN THE
GALLERY IS ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY FORTY.
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
OKAY MADAM MODERATOR DAZZLE US
AGAIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY FORTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. WE WILL GO TO LINE UP
TO THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS FOR AN HOUR
TO CATCH A POTION EDGE IN SAN
FRANCISCO ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN PART OF SAN FRANCISCO
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
AN EXTRA BOTTLE OF NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI JUST BACK WITH
YOU ORGANIZATIONS REVERE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IN THE
SOUTH BAY AND CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS FOR LOCAL CONTROL I'M
ASKING WHO'S FIGHTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. ALREADY DONE
MUNITY THIS SPRING. WHAT COULD
EIGHT BECAUSE OF A DEAL ARE OR
MAYBE. TWELVE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY ZERO FOUR ZERO.
IF YOU AN ACTUAL LINE OF TO
TWELVE TO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI IT'S MERRY JACK WITH
PRESERVING BENNETT WE WORK TO
PRESERVE NOT ONLY FOR THE BALL
HOUSING BUT OUR- COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AND WE OPPOSED TO
ADDRESS THANK YOU. AND THAT HAD
A LINE OF ONE NINETY THREE ONE
NINETY THREE YEAR LAW OF THE-
LET ME. YEAH HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. VERILY YOU MAY. HELLO HOLLY
OSBORNE I LIVE IN REDONDO BEACH
AND THE REDONDO GENERAL HAVE
MOLD A LOT THE REGULATE FOR
QUALITY THAT A LOT OF NOT
PRACTICAL AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU OPPOSE THE
BILL. NEXT ALTHOUGH LINE OF
QUEUE SEVEN. TO A SEVEN YEAR
LINE OF THE- WELL THE THING
BONTA ON THING WITH PROTECTING
OUR FOOTHILL COMMUNITY BILL SB
THIRTY FORTY- GIVEAWAY LOCAL
CONTROL AND IT WILL NOT HELP.
PORTABLE HOUSING YOU TAKING
DOWN. POLITICAL FAMILY HOMES
THAT ARE. THE CLOSE ENOUGH TO
BEING WHEN YOU READ JENNIFER
CASE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
REPORTED WILL HAPPEN WITH THE
VERY YOU KNOW GOOD. HELLO
EIGHTY THIRTY FOUR AND THE
PROTECTING OUR WITH NO CLUE.
THANK YOU. YOU CAN AN EXTRA
COAT SO LINE UP. TWO TWENTY
THREE. A LINE OF OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS TAYLOR ON THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM OF THE WEST TO LOOK
LIKE A HOMEOWNER OUR PRESIDENT
OF THE ASIAN. THE DATE UPON
WHICH THIS STUDY BILL IS
BASICALLY THE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOMES NEEDED BY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE IS FLAWED
AND WHILE WE DO NEED HOUSING WE
DON'T NEED NEARLY AS MUCH
PROPOSED. THIS LEGISLATION
CURRENTLY DRAFTED AS HIS HOME
DETAILS MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
COULD EASILY DISPLACE LATINO. I
CAN EITHER MINORITY COMMUNITIES
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA
WE STRONGLY OBJECT TO THE
LEGISLATION AS WRITTEN THANK
YOU. LOCAL ALAINA TO FACE ONE
LINE OPEN. TWO FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SERVICE HELLO.
YEAH. YOUR LINE IS OPEN THEY
GOT MY NUMBER NOW TO GET YOU
ONE. OKAY. YEAH PARDON SAY IT
NAME FIFTY WILL ALLOCATE EIGHT
ZERO MORE I AM CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIRTY FORTY
THANK YOU. NEXT ALTHOUGH TWO
ONE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE GONNA
PANHANDLE VALLEY I'M WITH THE
GLOBAL CALIFORNIA AND ANGELENOS
FOR TREES BY TARGETING HOMES
THAT ARE FIFTEEN YEARS OLDER
THIS BILL WILL GENTRIFY IN
PLACE WHICH CLASS NEIGHBORHOOD
IF THEY ACTUALLY. SEVEN URBAN
PRINTED STUDIED SHOWS SIX POINT
EIGHT MILLION OLDER HOMES ARE
FORMER TO GET I MEAN. UNDER
EIGHTY THIRTY FORTY DISPLAY IN
EQUITY AREAS LIKE LAZY BY LIKE
EAGLE ROCK HIGHLAND PARK
MONTECITO HEIGHTS. HI WELL HI.
ALL BECOME A SPEC CHESS GAME
PLEASE DO NOT HAVE TO BILL
UNTIL YOU FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
STOP THE GENDER AND SPECULATION
THAT THIS BILL WOULD CUT OFF
THANK YOU. BUT A. TO THREE
CAROLINA OPEN FROM EVERYBODY HI
MY NAME IS NANCY OKADA WITH
DATEABLE RAFAELI IN. THIS BILL
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT BLACK
AND LATINO HOMEOWNERS THROWN
OUT OF THEIR HOMES. CAN ONLY
OFFER THE PHONE TOWARD THOSE
THERE. OLDER HOMES TO BUY EXTRA
STARTER HOME AND WE FEEL THAT
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE THE CHANCE TO
BUY A HOME. PLEASE HOLD THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATAMATA PURCHASE FUNDING.
EVERYONE TO GIVE THEIR NAME AND
THEIR THEIR THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN ACTUAL GO TO LINE
TWO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAROL US IN PROTECTING OUR
FOOTHILL COMMUNITIES- UP
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
NEXT OVER THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
DAVID CAN TOGGLE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF INDIVIDUALS AND WE
ARE. THINKING AN ACTUAL GO TO
LINE IT TO SIXTY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I APOLOGIZE I'M
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT MY NAME IS
HEALTHY BEANS I LIVE IN PALO
ALTO I'M WITH. EVERYONE WHEN I
WALK AROUND MY NEIGHBORHOOD ALL
A HUGE HUGE HOMES GETTING BUILT
WE NEED MORE. AS AN ALL
NEIGHBORHOODS THANK YOU. AN
ACTUAL GO TO LINE UP TO SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS MARK DOT NEW COMMUNITY
UNITED SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
PROTECTING SINGLE FAMILY HOME
ALL THE BUILDING TO BE INTENT
ON DESTROYING. VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE THANK YO. MEXICO
CAROLINA ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI ANY BIG IN
HOLLYWOOD FRANKLIN YOU
COALITION CORRIDOR AND ALSO
UNITED NEIGHBORS TO LOOK
DANGEROUS. EIGHT MILLION HOMES
IN OUR MOST DIVERT SINGLE
FAMILY COMMUNITIES ARE
VULNERABLE TO BEING DESTROYED
AND WE STILL DON'T GET ANYTHING
FOR OUR MASSIVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESS CRISIS
HERE THANK YOU THANK YOU. AN
ACTUAL LINE OF TWO FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS JENNIFER HATE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO THIS BILL FOR UP
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVIZES.
POCKETED INVESTORS TO COMPETE
WITH LOCAL RESIDENTS IN BUYING
LOCAL PROPERTIES IN
TRADITIONALLY BLUE COLLAR IN
LOWER MIDDLE CLASS
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE MINE WHICH
IS ALREADY GENTRIFYING I OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WILL LINE OF TWO SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO READ
TRAIN SHELLEY WITH UNITED TO
SAVE THE MEASURE AND SAN
FRANCISCO IT'S HORRIFIC THE
DISPLAY A DISTILLATION THAT
HARM HER. DID YOU BROWN
COMMUNITIES THAT FOR THE TIME
LIKE THIS WE OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION UNLESS IT'S AMENDED
TO PROTECT THESE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AN ACTUAL
LINE OF Q. SEVEN NINE CAROLINA
OPEN. I SUPPORT THE BILL I GOT
MIXED UP IN THAT BUT I JUST
WANTED DAM TIRED OF LISTENING
TO OLD WEALTHY WHITE HOMEOWNERS.
THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE OF SAY
HERE WHY DON'T. TWO THIRTY
ALLIANCE OPEN. WE'LL GO TO THE
ONLINE OF QUEUE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES HI
SORRY- I AM OPPOSED TO THIRTY
FORTY I AM A RESIDENT OF THE U.
K. AND I AM VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT FIRE DANGER AND THE BEST
SOLUTIONS WITH OVERCROWDING AND
TOO MANY HOMES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH ARE IN THE
FIELD OR IN VALLEY LIKE IT IS
WHERE I. THAT IS UP TO YOU ON
BEHALF OF. MY NEIGHBORS WE ARE
OPPOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND THE NEXT TIME WE GO TO
ISSUE AT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS JIM DEUTSCH I'M A
RENTER AND THE MISSION AND- MY
LINE ACTUALLY GOT MIXED UP I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
STRONG SUPPORT BECAUSE- GIVEN
THE EXCLUSIONARY HISTORY OF
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING- WE NEED
TO. STOP PRIORITIZING LUXURY
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND START
ENABLING OUR NEIGHBORHOODS TO
BE INTEGRATED. WITH MORE DENSE
HOUSING THANK YOU. WE AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU UP. BILL FOR-
AB THIRTY FORTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOR. OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY
FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU MISTER CARE
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR GREAT
JOB. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU INTO CENTER MORE
LOCK FOR HOLDING ON THE FLOOR
WHILE I WAS PRESENTING AN
ASSEMBLY NAXAL RESOURCES- AND
SO- OUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS NOW
COMPLETES CORRECT CENTER
MORLOCK. OKAY WONDERFUL WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER LIKE KELSEY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN A QUESTION ON
THE COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENT
DATE YOU KNOW H. AWAY SHE SAID
EIGHT EXISTS I UNDERSTAND IT
IT'S- NOW ON IN THE BILL IF
THEY CANNOT AND RECENTLY
RESTRICT. THEIR TRIBE PASS WITH
PASSED THE AUTHOR IF THE CITY
CITY COUNCIL DECIDES IT ALL H.
WERE YOURS WILL BE- ZONE FOR
THIS FOUR PLEX WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN NEXT IN THE NORMAL.
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS WITH THE H.
AWAY I GUESS BERRIER THERE. I
THINK THIS IS ABOUT THE HOUSING
ELEMENT BUT I WILL THROUGH THE
TERRIBLE- ASK THE AUTHOR
COMMENT ON A- ASSEMBLY THAT THE
BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE CAT'S
FROM BANNING. ON RESUMING
RESTRICTING AND BASICALLY
APPLICATION THIS BILL- THERE
BEEN SOME CONCERNS THAT
SOMEHOW. WHAT ARE CURRENTLY.
LANGUAGE WHEN IT COMES TO SEE
IDEAS AND HOAS WOULD- WOULD
WOULD WOULD CREATE AN ISSUE
HERE. LAST YEAR THERE WAS A
BILL THAT PROHIBITED CITIES
FROM BANNING. EIGHTY YOU AND-
CONSTRUCTION WE WANT TO JUST
MAKE SURE WE'RE FOLLOWING THAT
AS WELL. YEAH WHAT WHAT I'M
WORRIED ABOUT IS THAT WE HAVE
YOU KNOW WHEN WE SAY WE GIVE
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE RIGHT WHO
IS THE ABOLITION EL HAGE HI
THIS USE BY RIGHT AND WE
CHANGED IT HAD CLOSING ELEMENT
WHEN WE IDENTIFY ALL THE SITES
I DON'T ANTICIPATE A CLASH WITH
H. AWAY ASSOCIATIONS ON THE
DETERMINATION WHEN SOMEBODY
ACTUALLY APPLIES FOR BUT YOU
KNOW IT'S MAYBE THAT'S- PART.
BUT IT'S- ONE OF THE CONCERN.
OKAY CENTER COUNTY WITHOUT IT
OR DID YOU HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION. OKAY ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. REGARDING AB THIRTY
FORTY. OKAY SEEING NINE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- JUST
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT AND RESPOND
TO SOME OF THE- THE OPPOSITION
THAT WAS REYES AND JUST CLARIFY
A FEW THINGS FIRST OF ALL
THERE'S A SUGGESTION THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS GOING TO
GENTRIFY. NEIGHBORHOODS AND MY
PERSONAL THAT THANKS TO YOUR
GOOD CENTER CENTER SKINNER SB
THREE THIRTY PROVIDES
DEMOLITION PROTECTIONS. LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S THE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL ALSO PROPOSED A BILL
BUT I JUST KNOW THAT THANKS TO
THE BILL I THINK WE'VE A GOOD
RESPONSE AND REAL PROTECTIONS
IN THAT AREA AND THEN I WOULD
ALSO JUST NOTE THAT THIS IS A
BILL THAT WILL REALLY AND SENT
THE CONVERSION OF WHAT WILL
LIKELY BE. MORE EXPENSIVE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES INTO
MULTIPLE SMALLER LESS EXPENSIVE
HOMES SO I THINK IT'LL HAVE
ACTUALLY OPPOSITE IMPACTS OF
WHAT'S BEEN SUGGESTED. OUR
SUGGESTION AROUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR US TO HAVE THAT AS ONE OF
THE LEADING. TRANSPORT WHILE
FUNDING. WORKING WITH. HOW DO.
HOUSING ALL LEVELS OF
AFFORDABLE ARE AND THIS ISN'T
WAY TO GET THERE THERE WAS ALSO
A SURGE THAT SOME THIS IS GOING
TO LEAD TO A LESS OF DIVERSE
NAY AND I FIRST ONE JUST NOTE
THAT WE'VE NEVER BEEN APPROACH
AS A AS A FORMER CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY THIS IS A SPECIAL I
WOULD BE ACUTELY KING TO. HOW
NOT PROVIDE ORGANIZATIONS WERE.
BLACK LATINO OR FATHER SAID
RIGHTS ARE CONCERNED WITH THIS
POINT. ONE OF CALPERS POINTED
OUT ARE BEATING THE- HISTORY OF
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING AS
SOMETHING. THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND I WOULD WOULD
AGREE TO THAT- OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
ENSURE REAL DIVERSITY IN IN ALL
THE NEIGHBORHOODS. IN OUR
STATE- BLESSING I WANT TO JUST
MENTION IS WRITTEN THIS ISSUE
OF LOCAL CONTROL- THERE WAS A
SUGGESTION FOR EXAMPLE
POTENTIAL FIRE SAFETY ISSUES.
THIS I TRUE LOCAL CAN. TO LOCAL
CHURCH TO THE DECISION OF
WHETHER THEY WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE INCENTIVE
THAT'S EMBODIED EMBODIED IN
THIS BILL. FOR ARE OR WHETHER
THEY WANT TO REZONE IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THEIR CITY
IT'S COMPLETELY UP TO THEM. SO
IF THERE'S A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD INVOLVE FIRE
SAFETY ISSUES. A CITY COULD
CHOOSE NOT TO. USE THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL THERE
WERE SIMPLY TRYING TO GIVE
ANOTHER TOOL. TO A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DECIDE AS THEY
SEE FIT SO AGAIN FOR ALL THAT
THE OPPOSITION IF THIS BILL
WERE TO PASS. YOU WOULD STILL
BE ABLE TO ENGAGE AS YOU DO IN
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
ENSURE PROPER DEVELOPMENT AND
UP WITH THAT. I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SUPPORT OF.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
LOCAL JURISDCTIONS WHICH-
OBVIOUSLY THIS HOUSING CRISIS
AND PROMISES CRISIS WE'RE DOING
WE WANT TO DO ALL WE CAN. TO
WIN SINCE THESE TO CONTROL.
MORE AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HI. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. MOTION
SENATOR ROTH EMERALD THE ROLL.
THIRTY FORTY BY SOME MEMBER TO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER WINNER BY
WINTER BY SEVERAL. MORRELL NOW
SENATOR BATES NO BATES NO
CABALLERO HI CABALLERO HI
TORONTO HI DORADO MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK MORLOCK HI ROTH NAY
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE NUMBER. NUMBER FIVE HOTEL
SKI SKI ICE. EIGHT TWO OKAY
THAT'S NOT FOR TO GET OUT WILL
PUT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS- AND WE WILL NOW SINCE
THE SUMMER SHE WAS HERE WE
WILL- SKIP AHEAD TO ITEM
FIFTEEN AB THREE TWO SIX NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY PRESENT.
THE SB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN WOULD
ADDRESS. SAYS ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THE KNOWS
FULL WELL THE DARK CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS. BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT.
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
OF OUR NEIGHBORS WERE HOMELESS.
OUR STATE HAS HAD THE HIGHEST
RATE OF ONE SHELTER HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COUNTRY. SO
WE ALL KNOW THAT AS MORE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN HOUSE. MORTON FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS. WITH THE
PANDEMIC. CARE BINGE
PROJECTIONS OF HOMELESSNESS
COULD INCREASE BY FORTY TO
FIFTY PERCENT. AS A RESULT OF
THE RESEARCH. FOR EVEN MORE IF
WE DON'T ADDRESS WHAT HAPPENED.
AFTER JUDICIAL. THIS. TWENTY
THIS IS A BILL THAT CAME OF TO.
FOR EARLIER THIS. THE
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL ON REGIONAL
HOMELESS ADVISORS HEADED UP BY
THE FORMER SENATE PRO TEM. AND
MAYOR OF ST. WILL START. WITH A
WITNESS TODAY. PROPOSED A
STELLAR OF AN ENFORCEABLE
RESULTS BASED ACCOUNTABILITY
MANDATE TO END HOMELESSNESS.
SINCE PURELY VOLUNTARY EFFORTS
BY MYRIAD OF LOCAL AND STATE
AGENCIES AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF FUNDING. HAVE FAILED.
CHECK THIS BILL COMES OUT OF A
CONVERSATION RELATED TO
LAWSUITS. BEFORE CORONAVIRUS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE COME
UNDER INTENSE LEGAL PRESSURE TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. ADVOCATES
OF SUCCESSFULLY SUED LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE STATE
WHO FAIL TO HOUSE PART ON
SHELTER. FOR EXAMPLE IN ORANGE
COUNTY FEDERAL JUDGE DAVID
CARTER. SUCCESSFUL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE TO
PROVIDING EMERGENCY SHELTER BUT
THAT PROCESS WAS VERY COMPLEX
EXPENSIVE. AND TIME CONSUMING
BOTH FOR GOVERNMENTS AND IT'S-
SINCE THEN THE TERM OF FIVE A
LAWSUIT. FOR SENT INTO LETTERS
TO ANGELES SAN DIEGO SANTA CRUZ
SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO AND
OTHER RESTRICTIONS AROUND STATE.
THIS BILL WOULD A PROCESS
MOVING STATED IN SEASON
GOVERNMENT COUNCIL FOR HOUSING
OR UNSHELTERED BASED ON
MEASURABLE GOALS AND EXISTING
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE
IDENTIFIED IN DOING THIS
WITHOUT EXPENSIVE OR TIME
CONSUMING LAWSUITS. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE TO
COMPLETE A GAPS A NEEDS
ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE WHAT
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE. IT
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
COMPLETE THE GAPS A NEEDS
ANALYSIS AND TO WORK REGIONALLY
TO CREATE AN ACTUAL PLAN TO
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS BY 90% BY
THE- TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. AND
WE'RE- SINCE. THE WHOLE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNT OF FOR
FAILING TO SUBMIT A PLAN FOR
NOT TO SUBMIT A PLAN. AGAIN THE
IDEAS BY HOLDING ALL OF US
ACCOUNTABLE BASED ON BENCHMARKS
IN PLANTS HOPEFULLY THIS WILL
MOVE CALIFORNIA TOWARD FINALLY
ADDRESSING MORE CRISIS OF OUR
DAY. AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO OR ONE MELENDEZ
AND SUPPORT THE FORMER PRO TEM
OF THIS BODY THE MAYOR
SACRAMENTO MISTER DARRELL
STEINBERG. OKAY WE WILL NOW GO
TO- MAYOR STEINBERG BY MAYOR
BACK TO THE SENATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND THANK
YOU TO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL AND
TAKING ON THIS. IMPORTANT
CHALLENGE YOU KNOW I HAVE BEEN
IN YOUR SHOES AND- I APPRECIATE.
THE DIFFICULTY IN THE
COMPLEXITY- MAKING PUBLIC
POLICY IN THIS ARENA AMONG SO
MANY JURISDICTIONS AND LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT AND HOW DO WE
MAKE PROGRESS ON WHAT SOMETIMES
SEEMS LIKE. A MOST INTRACTABLE
ISSUE. AND I THINK THAT MAYBE
THE LUXURY BEING OUT- AND
CHAIRING THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE HERE TO TAKE A STEP BACK
AS DID MY COLLEAGUES WHO SERVED
WITH ME. TO ASK A FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS WHY IS IT THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IN THE
AREA OF HOMELESSNESS. THE MOST
CERTAINLY PRIOR TO THE
CORONAVIRUS THE MOST SERIOUS
HEALTH. PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY CHALLENGES FACING
OUR STATE WHY IS EVERYTHING WE
DO. VOLUNTARY AND OPTIONAL WHY
IS THERE NOTHING IN THE LAW
THAT SAYS THAT ALL OF US WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE AND ACCOUNTABLE
FOR MAKING THIS PROBLEM BETTER
AND SAVING THE LIVES WHY AREN'T
WE REQUIRED COLLECTIVELY TO
MOVE TOWARDS GETTING MORE
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET INTO INTO
HOUSING ALTERNATELY. A ROOF- AT
FIRST AND WHATEVER SERVICES
THAT PEOPLE NEED TO. I AM VERY
LIVES. THIS IS GOING TO HAVE TO
USE PUBLIC POLICY TO ADDRESS
THAT QUESTION AND I BELIEVE IT
DOES SO IN A VERY INTELLIGENT
WAY. IT SAYS THAT OVER AND
AGGRESSIVE BUT REASONABLE
PERIOD OF TIME THAT ALL OF US
EVERY CITY EVERY COUNTY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MUST BE
MUST MOVE TOWARDS- ACHIEVABLE
BENCHMARKS IN REDUCING THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNSHELTERED. AND IT IS. A AS
THE CHAIRMAN SAID THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE SAID. MR TO. APPOINT
AN INSPECTOR GENERAL TO ENSURE
THAT ALL JURISDICTIONS ARE
ACTING IN GOOD FAITH TOWARDS
MEETING THE BENCHMARKS. THIS IS
ESSENTIAL AT LEAST SOME FORM OF
THIS IS ESSENTIAL BECAUSE NO
AMOUNT OF MONEY. HE'S GOING TO
CHANGE SOME OF THE DYSFUNCTIONS
FRANKLY THAT EXIST WITHIN OUR
HOMELESS SERVICES AND HOUSING
SYSTEMS. THE MULTIPLICITY OF
JURISDICTIONS THE FACT THAT
MONEY IS NOT. THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE TO CONSOLIDATE
RESOURCES ACROSS. TO MEET CASH
PARKS THE FACT THAT SOME
JURISDICTIONS DON'T WANT TO DO
THIS WORK BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO HOMELESS SHELTERS OR
HOMELESS RELATED HOUSING IN
THEIR JURISDICTIONS THE FACT
THAT COLLECTIVELY WILL NOT
DRIVEN TOWARDS A GOAL. IT WE
MUST BE DRIVEN TOWARDS GOAL.
AND SO I WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PASS THIS BILL.
AND KNOWING THAT WERE LIVING IN
THE MIDST OF A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME CANNOT FORSAKE.
ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND
HOMELESSNESS IN LEGISLATIVE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE LIVING IN A TOUGH TIME
THE BENCHMARKS THAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU HAS IDENTIFIED ARE
REASONABLE THE PROCESS TO
DEVELOP BENCHMARKS I SHOULD SAY
ARE VERY REASONABLE THEIR
COLLABORATIVE. AND I KNOW SOME
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE OPPOSED OR AT
LEAST. OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED I
WOULD JUST REMIND EVERYONE THAT
AMONG I BELIEVE THE SIX
THIRTEEN MEMBER TASK FORCE THAT
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTED. A
NUMBER NINETY SUPERVISORS AND
CITY. AND MAYORS. AND SO THIS
ISN'T A MANDATE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THIS IS A CALL TO
ACTION FOR ALL. OF US. TO
CREATE A- NOT A LEGAL RIGHT IN
THE SENSE THAT MAYBE I
ORIGINALLY ADVOCATED ALREADY
DISSIPATED. BUT A LEGALLY
ENFORCEABLE OBLIGATION ON ALL
OF US TO DO THE RIGHT THING ON
BEHALF OF THIS ISSUE LATER ON
BEHALF OF TOO MANY SUFFERING
PEOPLE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. I THANK YOU MR
MAYOR- WE WILL NEXT GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL ASK PEOPLE
TO LIMIT THEIR REMARKS. TO THE
NAME ASSOCIATION OF ANY AND
YOUR SUPPORT- IN THE GALLERY GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
ALEX TORRES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY ADDITIONAL OVERCOMING
GALLERY SCENE ON THE MOVE
DURING TWENTY FOURTEEN- MT AS
USUAL- WHEN I GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE
IN PARTS OF AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT. THE GOVERNOR'S REGIONAL-
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS. ARE
VERY STRONG THANK YOU. OVER THE
NEXT. THANK YOU NEXT TO A COURT
LINE OF ONE NINE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MORE ACCURATELY
HELP NUMBER YEAH I AM IMPORTANT
DEL INSPIRON. NEXT ALTHOUGH
LINE OF TWO EIGHT EIGHT YOUR
LONG IS OPEN. ON BEHALF OF THE
OAKLAND MAY LIBBY AND STROKES
OF THANK THE OFF FOR HE
LEADERSHIP. NEXT ALTHOUGH I AM.
TWO NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH BENEFIT ON OF JOSE SAM
LICCARDO TRUMP BEFORE IN THINK
THE MEMBER TO FOR HIS LEADERS
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BARRISS CARL
WOULD. YOU REALLY CAN'T HERS
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT. YOU
AND NEXT CAROLINE TO NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BACKING
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. CONECTADO
LINE TO FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU FORTY EIGHT.
MEXICO CAROLINA TO NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS JACK AVERY ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD
TO SUPPORT. ME TWO SIX NINE
THANK YOU FOR TO BE ON THAT-
AND THEN WE- ACTUALLY. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN. OF AB.
THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE MY PRESS
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ORDER TO
LINE UP TO FIFTY THREE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
HENRY OCCUR I'M CALLING FROM
SANTA CRUZ IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TO SIXTY NINE. AND THERE IS
NOBODY ELSE IN HUMAN STRUCTURE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
NOW GO TO THIS. TO AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY NINE- THE LEAD OPPONENT
WHO WILL HAVE- TWO MINUTES IS
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE GOOD
AFTERNOON AND BECAUSE MEHRESTAN
BURKE I DID TAKE A BIT LONGER
THAN. TWO MINUTES I WILL BE
FLEXIBLE WITH YOUR AS A MATTER
OF OUR- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
YEAH. EVERYONE ADMIN OF THE
COMMITTEE. KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA THIS AFTERNOON.
REGRETFULLY OPPOSED AND- AB
THREE TWO SIX NINE ONE ARE THE
POSITION FOR US ARRIVE AT AT
AND WE- TOOK SOME TO GET THERE
BECAUSE COUNTY THE GREED THAT
COMPREHENSIVE AND AGGRESSIVE
NEW STRATEGY IS REQUIRED TO
MEANINGFULLY. REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
COUNTY IS BELIEVE THAT ANY NEW
APPROACH NEEDS TO INCLUDE AT
LEAST. THE FOLLOWING PRINCIPAL
ELEMENT. CLEARLY ARTICULATED
GOAL DEFINE ROLES IN
RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN STATE
COUNTY AND CITY GOVERNMENTS.
THERE IT ONGOING FUNDING TO
FULFILL THE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND THE CHEAP. AND TRANSPARENT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO HOLD
EACH LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PRUDENT USE
OF STATE RESOURCES. ALTHOUGH
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE TWO
SIX NINE GENERALLY INCLUDES
ARTICULATED GOAL BY SPECIFYING
A PLANNING PROCESS AND
REDUCTION TARGETS IN THE BILL
ALSO INCLUDES ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS INSPECTOR
GENERAL IN COURT INTERVENTION
PROP. HOWEVER THE MEASURE IS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED DOES NOT
PARTICULARLY CLEAR ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR EACH LEVEL
OF GOVERNMENT. NOR DID IT
PROVIDE THE ON GOING YOU WERE
THAT ARE VITAL FOR SUCCESS
OUTCOMES. IN SHORT EIGHTY THREE
TO SIX NINE CURRENTLY FOCUSES
ON PLANNING WITHOUT FUNDING THE
PROCESS PRESCRIBED THE SOLUTION
WITHOUT A FULL UNDERSTANDING OF
THE NEEDS AND GAPS AT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL. AND FOCUS AS
OUTCOMES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT FINDING YOU AND TO
ACHIEVE PROGRESS. CONSIDERING
THE CURRENT FISCAL CLIMATE IN
THE UNCERTAINTY THAT STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
CONTINUING TO EXPERIENCE DUE TO
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE
BELIEVE THAT IF THE BILL WERE
TO MOVE FORWARD ABSENT A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY IT
SHOULD TAKE A MORE MEASURED
APPROACH THIS YEAR THAN ITS
CURRENT FORM. AND WE HAVE
OFFERED AMENDMENTS TO THIS AND-
AT THE TWO MOST CRITICAL
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE OFFERED
IS STILL REQUIRING MANDATING
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS PLANTS AND ALL
FIFTY CAO PUTTING. IN THAT
PROCESS THERE SO AND THREE. BUT
PER THE FUNDING AFTER TO THE
PLANNING PROCESS. AND SECONDLY
TWO DIFFERENT ACTION ON SETTING
GOALS AND MILESTONES TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS. UNTIL THE LOCAL
PLANS ARE COMPLETED AND THE
DOWN THERE GOT. ALL PARTIES CAN.
THE DATA AND ALSO HAVE A ROBUST.
AB THE FINE ROLES AND- SO AGAIN
COUNTY THAT AN AGGRESSIVE NEWS
ON HOMELESSNESS IS NOT. AND WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF TAKING THE
BEGINNING SEPT ABOUT STRATEGY
THIS YEAR- WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
AIR SIGN LEADERS ON THE CHRIS
CRITICAL ISSUE AND LOOK FORWARD.
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH BOTH
OF THEM IN PURSUIT OF A COPPER
NEW HOMELESSNESS STRATEGY THAT
WILL LEAD. OR DO THINGS. THANK
YOU VERY WE WILL MAIL ON THIS
BOB COMMON IS A ROOM. PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENT YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY- AND
THE FACT THAT YOU OPPOSE-
LOOKING UP IN THE GALLERY I DO
NOT SEE ANY OPPOSITION COMMENTS
IN THE GALLERY WILL NOW MOVE TO
TWENTY FORTY- NO ONE IS IN
TWENTY FORTY ONE I GO TO THE
PHONE LINE. AND YOU MAY OPEN UP
PHONE LINES. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
FIRST LINE IS MONEY ONE NINETY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN JASON
RIGHT WE CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT
WE SHARE MANY OF THE COMMENTS
ARE MADE BY MISS ALLEN TIME
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING ABOUT THE COMMITTEE- FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
MCALISTER'S. MISTER CHAIRMAN I
HAVE A- QUESTION REGARDING- D.
RID OF MEN. HAVE MANDY. DAVIS
PROCESS- IT'S HIGHLIGHTED ON
PAGE SEVEN OF THE STAFF REPORT.
HE NOTICES BECAUSE OF THE
COVERT WORK THIS BILL NORMALLY
WE GO TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THERE'S- FIVE CHALLENGE HERE
ABOUT THE THAT THIS GENERAL
MAKING OF. MAKING THE
DETERMINATION ON ON WHO'S
FAILED. TO DO THIS AND THEN. I
DON'T WANT TO PRE ORDER AND FOR
FROM THE COURTS BUT HAVING
COURTS RATHER USE INDEPENDENT
JUDGMENT SIMPLY- RIPPER STAMPER
IS- FACILITATE. THE VEHICLE
THAT THE TERM THAT THE MAY SO
THAT'S A SERVICE QUESTION IN
THIS QUESTION IS THAT THIS.
APPEAL. AGAIN IT'S- USUALLY
WILL LET THE COR THE- WHAT
SHOULD BE EXPERT I'M APPRECIATE
THE FORMER PRO TEM'S TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF THE CHALLENGE OF
HOMELESSNESS BUT TO TELL THE
COURTS THAT THESE. THESE ISSUES
HAVE. ALEVE ATTENTION IS REALLY
YOU KNOW NOT THE TRADITION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND OF
THE LAWS WOULD HAVE SAID LIKE
THE AUTHOR COULD. COMMENT
PONDERED. FIVE ISSUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERTAINLY SERVICEABLE AS
A GOOD CENTER AND I WERE JUST
DISCUSSING BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
HEARING AS SOON AS WE GOT THIS
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT WE
REACH OUT TO THE CENTER. MANY
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO ENGAGE
WITH THEM AND WORK THROUGH
THESE ISSUES SO THAT'S THE
FIRST. THING I WANT TO SAY THAT
THE SECOND ONE IS A IS. A THE
PURPOSE FOR THIS BILL THIS IS A
BILL THAT WE'VE INTRODUCED
BECAUSE- WE HOME THIS CRISIS
THAT SPANISH PROFOUND IN. IS
PENDING NOT JUST BECAUSE IT WAS
AN IMPORTANT AND SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSAL PUT OUT BY THE
GOVERNOR'S- ADVISERS SAYS BUT
BECAUSE AT THIS MOMENT. ARE ARE
ANY. ON THIS. THE MATTER IS A
TWO HUNDRED THAT ARE BEING TO
BY SEN AND LITIGANTS ARE AT
RISK THAT ARE SPENT AND JUST
GIVEN ALL THE CHALLENGES WE
HAVE- IT'S TAKING AN AWFUL LOT.
OUR TOO BAD THE COURT SYSTEM
ADDRESSES SUPPORT THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL IS TO ESSENTIALLY.
CREATE A PROCESS BY WHICH- IT
ADVOCATES FOR OUR HOMELESS
RESIDENTS AND OUR BROADER
COMMUNITY KNOW THAT EVERY
JURISDICTION IS MAKING REAL
HEADWAY TOWARD ADDRESSING THIS
AND HOPEFULLY IDEALLY OF
GETTING- OUR ALL THE LOSSES
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW SO THE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND. THE PURPOSE
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING. NOW THAT
BEING SAID THAT WAS THIS.
EXPEDITING SOME LAWSUITS WOULD
WOULD MAKE SENSE OF WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
WILL BE WORKING THROUGH IT I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO. KEEP YOU
ABREAST OF THAT DISCUSSION AS-
AS WE AS WE MOVE THROUGH. OKAY
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MEASURE- I STRONGLY AFFIRM THE
DIRECTION OF THIS BILL- THERE'S
DEFINITELY BEEN A VACUUM HERE
AND I CAN I CAN KIND OF SURE
THAT FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
AFTER BECOMING THE PROVIDER IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX- THE COUNTY
WAS REAL ACTIVE IN PURSUING.
WHAT THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION
WANTED TO DO AND THAT WAS A
COMMISSIONED IN HOMELESSNESS
AND SO I WAS THE INITIAL
CHAIRED SERVED IN THAT POSITION
FROM MY- ENTIRE TWO TERMS AND I
KNOW IT TAKES YEARS TO TRY AND
DEAL WITH ALMOST THE IT'S NOT
LIKE OVERNIGHT THING THE
GOVERNOR I REALIZE. THAT IS
WELL AND STEINBERG IS WELL. SO
I UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE AND
EMPATHIZE WITH. I I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THIS IS THE RIGHT
WAY TO GO AND SO MAYBE JUST.
BEING SENSITIVE TO. THE
COUNTIES AND THE CITIES. I LOOK
AT THE THIS WAY IT WOULD IF WE
ALREADY HAVE. COMMISSION STAY
IN HOMELESSNESS AND WE'RE ALL
WORKING ON ENDEAVORS I DON'T
KNOW FOR A WHOLE NEW
BUREAUCRACY WOULD PERHAPS
STAFFING AND ALL THE REST OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS TO GO
I THINK THE GOVERNOR HOLE IS
ALREADY GETTING. THEIR PLANS
FOR HAS THEM WHILE GETTING THE
MINUTES OF THEIR MONTHLY REPORT
WE HAVE MONTHLY MEETINGS OF THE
WORLD PROGRESS WORKING WITH.
ALL THE SILOS PROFITS THE
BUSINESSES BERMAN CITIES IS A
BIG STEP AS OLD AS YOUR HEAD
YOU KNOW WE WERE JUST TRYING TO
DO A TEN YEAR PLAN. YOUR TRIP.
FOR THAN A- EVERY THING SO MANY
REACTIONS AND SO MANY SALUTE
AND I'M NOT SO IF MAYBE SOME OF
THEM SURE YOU CAN HELP ME IN
YOUR CAR OR BUT I I'M NOT SO
SURE THIS IS THE WAY THAT GOES
I TO GO I AM WITHOUT WITH.
ANILINGUS I WOULD PREFER FOR
SOME OF COLLABORATE. EFFORT
THAT YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THREE WORK AND THEN SEE
HOW THAT GOES AND THEN SEE IF
WE NEED SOMETHING A LITTLE
MORE- I DON'T KNOW WHAT SORT OF
LOOKING FORWARD TO.
DIGITIZATION ERROR HEAVY HANDED
IS WHAT COMES TO MINE AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE RIGHT
ONE BUT I PER WHAT WE WHAT
DOING I'M THERE MY HEARTS
THERE. I JUST. I JUST WONDERING
IF THERE'S A LITTLE. DIFFERENT
WAY TO. ATTEMPT TO MOVE THE
SENATE THAT SUPPLY INPUT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. FIVE THANK YOU
AND- SUMMER OF A CLOSE CENTER
BATES. I THINK YOU ARE
DETERMINED WIENER ODD COUPLE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL A
PROBABLY. ONE THAT I THINK IS
OUTSTANDING AS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR CIVIL PENALTY A
COMMUNITY THAT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
TRANSPORTING HOMELESS FROM ITS
COMMUNITY TO ANOTHER AND
BECAUSE SIDE THE HOMELESS
POPULATION THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED IN OUR COUNTY
TRANSCANADA HAS TO BE SOME.
SORT OF CONTROL ON IT AND IT
NEEDS TO BE PRESENTED HER
FINDINGS THAT WOULD BE
PRESENTED TO ACTUALLY INSURE
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS
NOT. BASED ON WHAT I'M READING
THAT IT DOES NOT EVEN GO ON
THROUGH THE COURTS IT'S REMAINS
WITHOUT THIS NEW INSPECTOR
GENERAL- OFFICE FOODS SO THAT'S
ONE MAJOR CONCERN EITHER ONE OF.
OUR CERTAINLY INTERVIEWS WITH
THOSE WHO WERE STEPPING UP FOR.
I OF THE HAS MADE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IT WAS
INTERESTING TO NOTE. THAT
PROJECT A ROOM KEY WHICH WAS
FIVE. YOU KNOW A NEW. SOLUTION
TO HOMELESS DURING OF THE OF
SIGNIFICANT OUTBREAK EARLY AND
THE COVE IN NINETEEN SITUATION.
HAS BEEN CHANGED- MOVED TO OUR
PROJECT HOME KEY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE GOING
TO INVEST MONEY AND- ACTUALLY
PURCHASING ALL MOTELS HOTELS
THAT ARE WILLING. PROVIDE
HOPPING FOR IN THE. SOMETHING
THAT WILL A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE CAN GOVERNMENTS THE STATE
SO THIS SEEMS TO BE REALLY A
HEAVY HANDED BEFORE WE'VE- THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN ISSUE-
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. DON'T
COMPLY IN THE SHORT TERM WHEN
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE OUT THERE ALREADY TO TRY TO
ADDRESSED AND ALL OF THE VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE. THAT WE HAVE
WITH HOME FILE UNDER PROJECT A
ROOM KEY PAUL LEVENTHAL FLYNN
NO ROOMS WERE PURCHASED OR
LEASED. OR FINANCED YET ONLY
60% OF THOSE WERE ACTUALLY
OCCUPIED THAT SUGGESTS THAT.
THE TRANSIENT NATURE OF
HOMELESS ON THE PROBLEMS THAT
PROBABLY ARE BASICALLY ALL
SIGNIFICANT HIM OUT. DO THING
PERCENT. OF SO I THINK IT'S PER
INTO WE HAVE THE BIGGER PLAN WE
PRIDE. HOME KEY TO SEE IF WE
ARE ABLE THROUGH THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS OF THE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM WITHOUT THE HEAVY HAND
OF ANOTHER BUREAUCRACY AND A
NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN- THAT IS
GOING TO BE. DESPITE TO
COMPLAIN THAT MADE HAVE ANY
FINDING WHICH IS SOMEONE WHO
THINKS IT SHOULD BE DONE
DIFFERENTLY. AND I HATE TO GIVE
THAT KIND OF AUTHORITY WITHOUT
SOME VERY VERY STRIPPED. DOWN
CONFORMING REQUIREMENTS BEFORE
SUCH HEAVY HANDS COME DOWN ON A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY SPEAKING ABOUT WHERE'S
THE WHERE'S THE FUNDING FOLKS
WHERE'S THE FUNDING SO- I WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BACK. WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY ON
THE YEARS THAT I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. CANNOT
CERTAINLY THE APRS WITH THE-
OWNER ON THE SIR ALL
SIGNIFICANT. AND REDUCE. THE
NAY IN THE TELEHEALTH COME. OF
HOMELESS AND I THINK WE TO
GIVE. OUR. INTO THE BEFORE WE
TAKE THAT RATHER. HI I THINK.
OF STAFF LAW WITH LOCAL THE-
AMINA'S HERE TODAY LISTENING TO
ALL OF THE OF THESE HOW. VOWED
TO FOR MADE LOCAL. I MEAN IT
ARE JUST ALL OVER THEM AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S BEEN WRONG IF
WE WANT LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO BE
A VERY STRONG PARTNER FINITARY
POSITIVE PARTNER WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND SOLVING OUR
HOUSING. THE HOMELESS ISSUES.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU CENTER
RATES ARE BECAUSE ANY THE COM
OR. QUESTIONS OKAY NINE WE USED
TO HAVE A MOTION TO PASS BILL.
MOTION BY SENATOR RAW AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER FIRST OF ALL
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
DETACHMENT IN THE DISCUSSION
AND WE ALL KNOW. HOME CONTRACT.
CHALLENGE FOR SIMILAR
PERCEPTIONS AND- I WOULD HAZARD
A GUESS THAT EVERY MEMBER IN
THIS BODY HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
SOME INTENSE WAYS OVER THE
YEARS TO OUR CAREERS AND TRYING
TO TACKLE THIS PROBLEM AND THIS
IS EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED TO
BUILD I WANT TO ADDRESS SOME
COMMON THAT OUR CALLS FROM
ORANGE COUNTY LATE PARTICULARLY
SENATE MORLOCK AROUND YORK
COUNTY EXPERIENCED. THIS BILL
PART CAME OUT OF WAS INSPIRED
BY WHAT IN ORANGE COUNTY WHEN
HE SAID IN THE FALL WAY. THERE
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
JURISDICTIONS. CITIES AND THE
COUNTY THAT HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
GRAPPLE WITH HOMELESSNESS. AND
YET DESPITE THOSE EFFORTS YOU
WERE SUED BY ADVOCATES. AND
THROUGH A MULTI YEAR PROCESS
YOU HAD A FEDERAL JUDGE. WHO
RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES. IN FAVOR
OF CITIES AND COUNTIES DOING
MORE TOGETHER. AND AT THIS
MOMENT WE HAVE LAWSUITS- THAT
ARE SIMILAR THAT ARE
THREATENING JURISDICTIONS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING. TAKE A STEP. AS
SIGNIFICANT COST AND I WOULD
SUGGEST WHICH WOULD PROBABLY BE
THE MOST HEAVY HANDED WAY OF
APPROACHING THIS. WE ASK FIRST
AND FOREMOST THROUGH THIS BILL
ARE THAT THE STATE WORK WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO ENGAGE
AND- AN ANALYSIS OF GAPS IN
NEEDS ANALYSIS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED. MEMBERS HAVE DONE
THEM. WE HAVE NO AN- WHAT
HAPPENED AND REALLY SORT OF.
EFFORTS ON AND WE ASK TO COME
UP A PLAN WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
OVER THE EIGHT. TO HOMELESSNESS
AND A SIGNIFICANT WAY. ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE CARE OUT I
WOULD SUGGEST WE HAVE THE
LATEST FORM OF. OF BEING ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS WITH
AN INSPECTOR GENERAL- THAT
WOULD ONLY UNTIL A FEW STAFF TO
ENSURE THAT. THE NEEDS ANALYSIS
HAPPENS THE PLANT PROBLEMS AND
THESE JURISDICTIONS ARE HELD
ACCOUNT. ON I WANT ALSO RESPOND
A NEW SERVED TO ASKED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE ARE ALL KNOWN
OR COMMUNITIES AROUND
HOMELESSNESS DUMPING THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE JURISDICTIONS THAT
ARE LITERALLY IN FOLKS DOWN THE
ROAD TO MAKE CITY THE NEXT
COUNTERPART IN THE STATE WE
ALWAYS SEEM TO A STOP AND DIE
AS I COMMITTED TO CENTER WHITE
HOUSE KEY CERTAINLY IN OUR
CONVERSATION WITH SENATE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING. EUROPE
IS THE- RIGHT THERE'S ANOTHER
WAY TO SELF AGAIN I HAVE TO
KEEP OF ON AS I DO. THANK IN
GETTING OF OUR LOCAL JR AND SAY
THAT IF YOU IF YOU DON'T THE
COMMERCE WITH HAD WITH SAID IN
URBAN COUNTIES AND OTHER.
THERE'S A THAT WE CAN AGREE ON
I THINK ALL AGREE WE NEED TO
SKIP. SAYS WE NEED TO DO PLAN.
AND I THERE WAS A SURGE THAT
SOME THIS BILL DOESN'T PROVIDE
FOR. AND I APPS CAN THAT PER
THIS. AND FOR. IS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS THE GAS. WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE PROBLEM. AND WHAT WE AS
WE- ONCE WE- GAP IS AND WE KNOW
WHAT THAT SAY WE- CONTRACT
REVENUE GAP. WE WILL SERVE
HAVEN'T COME IN THE FUTURE. ON
RESEARCH WITH BUT ONE THING
THOSE VERY. THIS PSPO IS WITH.
DO NOT LOCAL BIRTH A- FOR DOING
MORE TO SOURCE THEY HAVE. A
VERY L. O. NO WORLD OVERTURES
TO UNDERSTAND THAT AND THAT'S
PART OF WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
NOW UP IN SAID HI WE ARE SO
VERY MUCH A DISCUSSIONS WITH A
LOCAL. WE WILL TO MAKE THIS
WORK HI AND MY HOPE BELIEF THAT
IN THE COMING WEEK WE WILL. BE
ABLE TO. FINE TUNE THE INTERNAL
THIS AND WAY THAT WILL MAKE
SENSE OF. WHAT THAT. GENDER
MUCH A- TWENTY AND UP. AND UP
FOR ALL OF US WE NEED TO MAKE A
MAJOR STEP IN THIS. IT IS. NOT
JUST. HAVE TO DO BECAUSE
CONSTRAINTS ARE ASKING THE- BUT
WE- THIS BECAUSE IT IS THE
THING DO. BOTH BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND CERTAINLY DURING
PANDEMIC SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY FOR SOME. FIVE
THANK YOU. DID I ASK FOR A VOTE
YES SAN RAFIU THE BILL-
EVERYONE NOW CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO
SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHIU THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WINNER.
WINNER BY MORAL. WELL MARRANO.
BATES BATES NO CALL. TORONTO I
TO ROSA I MCGUIRE. MORLOCK NO
MORE LUCK NOW ROTH ROTH HI
SORRY SKY ON NUMBER FIVE NUMBER
FIVE ACCOUNT HI WHAT SKI I. SIX
TO THREE. OKAY DOES NOT VOTE TO
GET OUT WILL PUT ON CALL YES
MA'AM THANK YOU MEMBER THANK
YOU CENTERS WE WILL NOW GO TO.
FOURTEEN AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO. BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEN.
AND THAT WILL BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THE BATRES WE
WILL BE AMENDING THE BILL TO
ALLOW HOAS WITH TIME BASED
RENTAL VANS LONGER THAN THIRTY
DAYS OF THOSE TIME FRAMES
AUTOMATICALLY REDUCED TO THIRTY
DAYS UNTIL THE HOAS CAN UPDATE
THEIR GOVERNING DOCUMENTS THE
AUTHORS ALSO AMENDING THE BILL
TO PAY OUT THE RIGHT OPTION AS
TO. IN THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND
HOUSE DEBT THE JUDICIAL CANNOT
COMMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS. BOB
HOAS GOVERN 25% OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIRTEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS LIVE
IN AN H. AWAY. I'M TO DO A
LOOPHOLE IN STATE LAW HM REYES
AND OTHER COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS ARE ALLOWED TO
PROHIBIT OR LIMIT HOMEOWNERS
FROM RENTING OUT THEIR HOMES
THEY CAN ALSO BE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FOR EXAMPLE
EIGHTY USE. WHAT AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO DOES. IS SOLVES THAT
ISSUE BY AMENDING THE DAVIS
STERLING ACT WHICH- GOVERNS
COMMON LINE COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. TO LIMIT AREAS
WHERE HOAS CAN BE AN INTIMATE
RENTERS. THE BILL SAYS THAT ANY
PROVISION OF THE GOVERNING
DOCUMENTS OF A COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT THAT EFFECTIVELY
PROHIBITS RENTALS IS VOID AND
UNENFORCEABLE THERE TO ADDRESS
THE PHONES CONCERNS THE BILL
HAS BEEN AMENDED TO ALLOW HOAS
TO CAP RENTALS. AT 25% OF THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF HOMES. WHICH IS
CURRENTLY BELOW THE ALLOWABLE.
5265% RENTER OCCUPANCY RATE.
THAT EXISTS IN MOST HOAS AND
THE 70% FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION
CONDOMINIUM SWITCHES ALLOWED
REQUIRED BY FHA AND THE
VETERANS IS IT VA. WHAT THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY TWO REALLY DOES IS
CLOSE A VERY IMPORTANT LOOPHOLE
TO MAKE NEW AND EXISTING
HOUSING AVAILABLE TO MORE
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE HAVE.
BELIEVE I DON'T HAVE THE NAMES
OF OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE YOU AND IF I IT'S A GOING
TO THE RESTAURANTS A FOR
CALIFORNIA YIMBY BUT BEFORE YOU
GET THERE I JUST WANT. RAIMES
MISSES US TO CLARIFY THE
AMENDMENT THAT US SKINNER
MENTIONED THIS IS AN AMENDMENT
THAT IS NOT IN THE ANALYSIS H.
MENTION HI APPROACH THEM
MENTION IT TO THE AUTHOR
YESTERDAY HE ACCEPTED A AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR OKAY I THINK
IT IS A VERY COMMON SENSE
AMENDMENT- THAT RIGHT NOW THERE
ARE HOAS. MINIMUM RENTAL PERIOD
OF SIXTY EVEN NINETY DAYS- AND
THIS BILL WOULD CAPITA THIRTY
DAYS- IT MAY TAKE OUT TIME FOR
SOME USERS SO IF TO CHANGE OUR
DOCUMENTS- THE WAY THAT THE
BILL IS STRUCTURED. IT COULD BE
INTERPRETED THAT IF YOU DIDN'T
QUICKLY CHANGING DOCUMENT BY
JANUARY FIRST. EFFECTIVE DATE
YOUR SUCCESS TODAY MINIMUM.
FIVE REQUIREMENT WOOD RENTAL
REQUIREMENT WOULD BE JUST
ELIMINATED. AND PEOPLE COULD
START DOING SHORT TERM RENTALS
AND SO THE BILL WILL BE
AMENDED. SO THAT AUTOMATICALLY
EVEN IF YOU DON'T AND YOUR
DOCUMENTS IF YOU HAVE A HIGHER.
MINIMUM. WAGE THANK THIRTY.
OPTION OF LAW YOU. AS GIVEN
BASED ON THAT SO JUST WANNA
CLARIFY TEXAS NOT IN THE. ONE
SEVEN CO TWO TO BILLION
WITNESSING YEAH FROM THE
RESTAURANT TO. OFTEN CALLED ME.
DEFINITELY CHECK AREA. YES WE
CAN WE CAN MISTER ROGERS. THANK
YOU HI GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY HE
TODAY MY NAME IS LOUIS MONDAY
OCT THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA B. CALIFORNIA IS
QUITE PROBABLY SPONSOR A. B.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO AND I
JOIN YOU TODAY TO FURTHER
SUPPORT OR IT. THANKS ARE
DOING A BETTER. JOB IN
DESCRIBING THE BILL SO I WILL
TRY TO KEEP MY CALM BRIEF OUT
OF RESPECT DIGNITY. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TO HELP US
ADVANCE OUR MISSION BY. OUR YOU
KNOW. YOU CAN WHAT I AM PART
THROUGH IOWA OF OUR OWN WHO.
CHAMILLIONAIRE TO BUILD AND AN
EIGHTY YEAR AND THEIR THEY'RE-
H. AWAY AND WE'RE RUNNING INTO
BERRIER AFTER BERRIER AND-
LOCAL THAT GETS BILL WILL HELP.
CLEAR SOME THOSE BARRIERS-
WHICH HAD A COUPLE OF BENEFIT I
THINK FOR THE CALIFORNIA. YEAH
COMMITTEE KNOWS WHAT. SUFFER A
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION UNITS
A SHORTAGE OF HOUSING- ONE HAS
CREATED PROBLEMS RENDERED IN
STARKER CLARITY THAN EVER
PERHAPS A BIT NINETEEN. AND ONE
EIGHT HE WAS A REALLY ARE WAY
OF APPROACHING BUILDING A HOUSE
THAT IS TYPICALLY OCCUPIED BY
RENTERS IN H. AWAY. THINGS LIKE
YEARS AT THE WILL HELP FOCUS
BUILD THOSE YEARS I HAVE WHERE
WHERE THEY'RE NOT CURRENTLY
ALLOWED TO HAVE BEEN ALSO
IMPORTANTLY ADVANCE IS RENT.
ALLOWING READY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THEY CAN AFFORD
LIVE IN COMMUNITIES ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE MIGHT HAVE BETTER
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND FOR THAT
FAMILY A BRIGHT FUTURE. BOTH
ALL THEY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
AND I CAN DO SO AND HAS. I
EIGHTY TWENTY TWO WOULD SAY
THAT BECAUSE OF THE H. AWAY
COVER DR BEFORE ON IT THEY
EITHER FOR AFFECTED WE BRING
ORDINARY RICH. LEADING OUT HOW.
OVER ENTERTAINMENT A CAP EIGHT
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY WHICH THE
FUTURE WILL NOT EXCEED RENTER
LIMIT IMPOSED THE H. AND VA
HELPING MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS.
PORTANTINO FINANCING THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE. ON. ABOUT
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO AND- YOU
CAN SEE THEM ABOUT IT- IS THERE
ANY QUESTION BY YOU HAVE TO
HELP ON THAT- BUT OTHERWISE
WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR A.
B. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU RESTAURANTS- AREA WE WILL
NOW GO TO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT- AS A REMINDER. PUBLIC
COMMENT SHOULD NOW BE LIMITED
TO YOUR NAME. YOUR AFFILIATION
IF ANY- AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. HI I DON'T SEE ANYONE
AT ALL IN THE GALLERY- SO WE'LL
MOVED. TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
TWENTY FORTY AFFAIRS. TWENTY
ONE I'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT. FOUR FIVE AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO AGAIN
PLEASE SIMPLY SAY YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION OF ANY AND YOU
SUPPORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE ALREADY
IN Q. PLEASE STAY. HOME AGAIN.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO OUR FIRST LINE NUMBER IS
TWO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER GIVE US KEEPS DONE WITH
THE HELP APARTMENT THIS IS.
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ONE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HENRY
HOOKER REPRESENTING SANTA CRUZ
SENIOR CENTER HOUSING. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO INCREASE THE
OPTICALLY INDOORS A. B. THIRTY
ONE NINETY TWO THANK YOU. IN
LINE THREE IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS CONNOR
TWENTY FROM CULVER CITY JUST
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND MY TWO EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT SAYS HE
MIGHT IF HE FELT THAT THE DAIRY
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY YEAH. NINE
THREE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THE
FINAL BILL WITHIN A CREEK ENVY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND NINE
THREE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MIKE THREE
ELEVEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND LIVING ON
THE LINE. THREE OH SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
GET AFTERNOON OUR BREAKDOWN
THEIR MODERATES YOU CAN CARRY
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE THREE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DIDN'T
KNOW A CROW WITH OPEN HOUSE IN
LOS INTO A CRITICAL NEED
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE EIGHT
TWO. IN NINE THREE OH SEVEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY THE TWO DAY TORN FROM
OAKLAND FROM EBAY FOR EVERYONE
CALLING FOR THE EIGHTY THREE
ONE EIGHT TWO THANK YOU. NINE
ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
ARIANNA STRIVE CALLING FROM
OAKLAND AND WAIT EAST BAY FOR
EVERYONE AND I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT AB THREE ONE EIGHT
THANK YOU. THREE FOURTEEN
YOU'RE THE FIRST PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI BABY KING FRIENDLY
CITY ALL WITH THE BAY FOR
EVERYONE CALLING SUPPORT. SEVEN
NINE THREE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M LYSENKO QUINN
FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND
MEMBER OF THE SOUTH BAY DMV
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. IN NINE TO NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINETEEN NINETEEN YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIVING ON THE LINE ONE NINETY
SEVEN NINE ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE NINETY SEVEN YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI. MY
NAME IS THERE'S VOICE HARM I AM
FROM AND I WAS. CALLING ON
BEHALF OF I SHOULD BE IN THE
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILLS WELL. IN MIND ONE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY. ONE EIGHTY NINE
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS. ALAN I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
ONE MECCA AND MANDELA BALLY IN
THE HEART OF BEING BEING AND-
YOUR SUPPORT. IN MIND TEN YEAR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME SEVEN CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES CA. AND YOUR
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF SANTA
MONICA EMB. AND NINE TO THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SANTA CRUZ I SPEAK IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BUT ALSO THE- I
DON'T. BY OUR EDITORIAL SAID
DEGREE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
NINE THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD AFTERNOON.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS CONNIE
A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF LAKE WILDWOOD
ASSOCIATION IN OUT OF COUNTY WE
HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED. OKAY
RENT THE PORT PART WE SUPPORT
NOBODY'S TO. IF THIS A TOWARD
TO HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION. THEY
MIGHT YOU HIDING YOU TO ENSURE
TERM. WHICH HI. TAKE A FROM THE
HOUSING STOCK YOU WE ARE TRYING
DO THAT AND ARE BEING
CHALLENGED YOU. NINE THREE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND A MEMBER OF
HOLLYWOOD CAN BE CAN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINE THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA L'ORGANISME
GIVE ME LONG BEACH RIGHT BUT
THAT THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE
THREE ELEVEN YOUR IN THIS OPEN
PLEASE AHEAD. NINE THREE LET
YOU MAY BE MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIVING ON THE LINE THREE TWENTY
SIX NINE THREE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JORDAN.
FROM SAN MATEO CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF DENTAL FOR EVERYONE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT PORTEND
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU COULD ASK
FOR MORE TIME. ABSOLUTELY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF. AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN
NINE THREE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES IT IS
YOU CAN GET PLEASE. I DIDN'T
RECEIVE A NUMBER I'M NOT AN
ATHLETE HOLD PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON. BEHALF OF.
EXPLAINING REGION ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO FURTHER COMMENT
SUPPORT AB TO ONE EIGHTY TWO
THAT THIS TIME THANK YOU WE
WILL MAIL GO TO THE OPPOSITION.
AB THREE ONE EIGHT TWO. THE
LEADER PONANT IS ARE GOING TO
BE LOUIS BROWN- FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE AND MYSTERONS
REMINDED YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. AND WE WELCOME YOUR
COMMENTS. SAN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND WE BROWN CALLING IN TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE. I OPPOSITION AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO FIRST I
NEED TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO MR KING IN THE STAFF IN THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL FOR A
SPENDING. SEVERAL TOP WITH US
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS ON THIS
BILL THE ORIGINAL OF THE BILL
HAD SIGNIFICANT ISSUES- THAT
WOULD HAVE VERY MUCH MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO QUALIFY
FOR FHA LOANS AND VA LOANS ON
BECAUSE THE TERMINOLOGY USED.
YOU PRESS MANY OF THE PROJECT
YOU AGREE THAT HELLO WE WERE IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL FOR TWO
REAL ISSUES FOR WE DON'T THREE
ONE EIGHT TWO IT'S TAKING A
LITTLE. HOW RENTALS AREN'T ANY
ISSUES ESOS. NOW WE THINK YOU'D
HAVE TO LOOK LONG AND HARD TO
FIND ASSOCIATION THAT ACTUALLY
PROHIBITS RENTALS AND THIS BILL
IS NOT ABOUT EIGHTY USE
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED LAST
YEAR DID YOU USE. N. H. O. H.
THAT PUTS THE TYPES OF
RESTRICTION DAN. ON IT SHOULD
BE OUR ASSOCIATION CANNOT
UNREASONABLY RESTRICT EIGHTY
USE WHICH WE BELIEVE EXTENDS TO
RENTAL RESTRICTIONS ON THOSE
WHAT THIS BILL DOES CONTINUES
TO TRY AND- TAKE IN THE DAVIS
STERLING ACT. BROAD FRAME. IT
PROVIDES OVERSIGHT I A MINUTE
GUY FOR HOAS AND TO MAKE IT A
MORE SPECIFIC ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SET OF POLICIES FOR OVER FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND ASSOCIATION. SO
SEE ASIANS THAT ARE BUILT
AROUND THEIR COMMUNITIES THEY
HAVE RULES THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THEY FIT
THEIR COMMUNITIES ONE SIZE FITS
ALL JUST DON'T WORK AS AN
EXAMPLE WELL WE DO APPRECIATE
THE SHORT TERM- RENTAL LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL. AS YOU POINTED OUT
MR THAT HAVE SIXTY DAY PER.
REPORTDAY PROHIBITIONS THEY
NOW CAN'T HAVE THOSE THEY'LL BE
HELD TO THIRTY DAY
PROHIBITIONS. WHILE I
APPRECIATE YOUR RECOMMENDATION
AND THEN IT MAKES A WHOLE LOT
OF SENSE WE THINK IT SHOULD
ACTUALLY BE EXTENDED. TO THOSE
LOCATIONS HAVE OTHER RENTAL
CAPS THAT MADE LESS. THAN THOSE
IN THE BILLS THEY'RE NOT COULD
FORCE AND FORCING THE IMPACT
THE SITUATION THAT YOU SPOKE OF
HAVING TO FORCED TO RUN- NEW
DOCUMENTARY CHANGE THEIR
DOCUMENTS. THE END OF THE YEAR.
SECOND DETER HOME ON
ASSOCIATIONS WE PROVIDE. THAT
AMOUNT OF THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS. HOME
BUYERS WITH FHA LOANS SENIORS
AND OTHERS. EVERY UNIT THAT NOW
TURNED INTO A RENTAL UNIT IS
ONE LAST THAT'S AVAILABLE FOR
HOMEOWNERS WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED. BILLS THANK YOU FOR
TUNING DUSTMAN BUYERS COME IN
BY MULTIPLE UNITS WITH A
CONDOMINIUM CONDOMINIUM
ASSOCIATION AND THEN TAKE THOSE
OFF THE MARKET FOR GOOD THANK
YOU WE'VE SEEN THAT HAPPEN IN
OTHER DOWN MARKETS IN WEEKS
IT'LL BEGIN. OUR FUTURE TIME.
ASK FOR NO VOTE THANK YOU IT'S
COMMENT ON. AND AGAIN BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE NUMBER OF COMMENTERS
AND WE WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
WE JUST ASK YOU PLEASE SIMPLY
FOR YOUR NAME YOUR IDEATION IF
ANY- AND THE FACT THAT YOU
OPPOSE THE BILL. OUR BE ALL
THAT. OUT YOUR NAME. OF ANY AND
THE FACT YOU OPPOSE. THE BILL
SO WILL BE MODERATOR I START
THE Q. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
THIS AND I OF AB. HI GUYS. BUT
FORGOT TO GO TO THE GALLERY
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE GALLERY.
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE TWENTY
FORTY OKAY NOW BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU AND
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO
BE JUST A MOMENT FOR US TO
GATHER THE LINE NUMBERS. NINE
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE PER TO
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS
OKAY. YES IT IS. YES OKAY YEAH
I DON'T FROM GARDEN VALLEY
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION CLEARING
GARDEN GROW. CLEAN MODE NO. ONE
EIGHTY THIRTY ONE IF YOU CAN
THANK YOU. MY FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS REBECCA EATON
RIVERSIDE COUNTY HOMEOWNER IN
THE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION.
BILL REMOVED EXISTING PROPERTY
RIGHT WITHOUT A CONTRACT THE
CATION PLEASE PROTECT THE
HOMEOWNERS AND VOEPEL THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MATT
PARSONS A MEMBER OF THE TENNIS
FERRY TENNIS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION THIS BILL FROM
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES THAT
ALLOWS MY CURRENT PROPERTY
RIGHTS TO BE STRIPPED AWAY AND
I QUESTION THE NEED TO REMOVE
THE NEGOTIATED LEGISLATIVE
PROPERTY RIGHTS. AFFORDED BY
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY TO
GRANDFATHER HOMERS IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THE OVERALL GOAL OF
THIS BILL PLEASE DON'T KNOW AND
PROTECT MY FAMILY AND THOUSANDS
OF OTHER CALIFORNIANS THAT WE
PUT IN FINANCIAL HARDSHIP IF
THIS BILL PASSES. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ERIC RIVERA AND THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
TRILLIONS PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE LOS
ANGELES. COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
COMMITTEE I AM OPPOSED TO AB
THREE ONE EIGHT TWO THANK YOU.
NINE TO SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS KELLY. ARE COUNTY SAN DIEGO
AND I AM. NINETY HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM CANCELING THE GRAIN OF RICE
PRESIDENT SAID THEY WATCHED
TOWN HOME IN LOS ANGELES AND I
AM EXTREMELY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL IT WOULD BE VERY EXPENSIVE
FOR US WE CAN'T AFFORD IT WE
DON'T WANT WE DON'T NEED IT
PLEASE VOTE NOW. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS DAVE BROCK IN THE
PROFESSIONAL COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION MANAGER IN PASADENA
WE MANAGE OVER THREE HUNDRED
COMMUNITIES I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE VOTE NOW THANK YOU. NINE
TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS FRED BARGE I'M ON THE MARK
MORGAN HILL HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION BOARD OF DIRECTORS-
I'M OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS WE
KNOW THAT WHEN MY RENTALS
INCREASED PROPERTY VALUES
DECREASE PLEASE VOTE NO. THANK
YOU. NINE TWO EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IS THAT MY
LINE IT IS PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
BETTY ROSS R. O. T. H. AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
HERITAGE LAKE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION. IN MANATEE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. THREE ONE EIGHT
TWO THANK YOU. NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THOMAS WHERE BE HAPPY
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION INSTITUTE
GREAT OF LOS ANGELES CHAPTER
NUMBER A POST. NINE TWO TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI TAYLOR PRESIDENT
PRO TEM OF THE WEST TO LOOP THE
LAKE RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION AND-
THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
STRICT PROPERTY RIGHTS ONE SIZE
DOES NOT FIT ALL I CAN CURB
WHICH AND MISTER. BROWN'S
PLEASE DON'T MAKE IT EVEN
HARDER FOR FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS TO GET INTO THE HOME
BUYING MARKET NUMBER ONE WAIT
FOR COVERAGE PEOPLE MIDDLE
CLASS AND BLUE COLLAR PEOPLE TO
BUILD WEALTH AND STABILITY
THANK YOU I OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS NATALIE STEWART
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF I THINK
YOU EIGHTY BERMAN THAT
UNDERWRITE CONDOMINIUM
ASSOCIATION FOR FHA AND VA
LOANS. I STRONGLY OPPOSE FROM
THE TENDED. OF NOT ALLOWING
LENDING SENIORS VETERANS FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M DOING KAMALA AN INDIVIDUAL
HOME OR IN A LOCAL THE TRIGGER.
POINT H. AWAY. PASSIONATELY
OPPOSED. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO.
NINE TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE NINE TWO FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
FOR HER GLORIA KIRKLAND FROM
HOME VALLEY HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION AND ON THAT THERE
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. NINE THREE
OKAY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS SHERIN BOTTOM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE HIDEAWAY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION IN LUCKY CALIFORNIA
CALLING TO OPPOSE EIGHTY THREE
ONE EIGHT TWO THANK YOU. NINE
TO EIGHTY NINE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROBERT WHITTAKER NOT PROPERLY
SERVE AS A VOLUNTEER H. O. A
BOARD MEMBER FOR MY HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION NAMES RANCH PCA AND
LOCATED OR IN A VALLEY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. COMMUNITY
CONSISTS OF TWO THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES COUPLED TO ALMOST
TEN THOUSAND RESIDENTS AND WE
ARE PASSIONATELY OPPOSED TO SB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
OPEN UP. AND I THINK. TWO
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN IN OAKLAND AFTER
GENERAL HOMEOWNER NATURE WE IN
INDIA- AND ALSO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION-COMMITTEE ND I'M OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY THREE ONE EIGHT TWO.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I AM OBVIOUSLY A
CON A HOMEOWNER IN THE BAY AREA
AND THE H. REPORT MEMBER I'M
TECHNICALLY OPPOSED FOR
COUNTING PURPOSES BY ACTUALLY
SUPPORT MOST THE BILL AND IT'S
ASKING FOR MINOR AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AMOUNT ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. AT
NINE THREE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN IS ROBERT
IN ACCORD WITH THE ORANGE
COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE QUEUE-
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION INSTITUTE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IF
YOU. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR GOOD
JOB. NOW DO I HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MY FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE DO I HAVE A MOTION.
SO THE- MOTION YES SENATOR
SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
YOUR CLOSING REMARKS THANK YOU
SO MUCH I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT-
WHEN I MENTIONED THAT THE
AMENDMENT THAT ALLOWS THE H.
AWAY TO IMPOSE THE RESTRICTION
OF A- LIVE A CAP OF 25% THAT
AMENDMENT IS ABSOLUTELY IN
THERE BUT IT ALSO GIVES THE H.
AWAY FLEXIBILITY BE TO RAISE
THE CAP HIGHER. IF NEEDED TO
MEET FHA OR FREDDIE MAC
MORTGAGE REQUIREMENTS SO WHILE-
THE OPENING OPPOSITION REYES
THAT THAT THAT. THAT IN SOME
CASES A HIGHER NUMBER RENTAL
UNITS MIGHT AFFECT THE ABILITY
TO FINANCE THE AMENDMENTS DID
PROVIDE FOR THAT SO I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT- BECAUSE
I DIDN'T STATE IT WHEN I
PRESENTED THE BILL- WITH THAT I
THINK THAT THE DISCUSS THE
PRESENTATION BUT- THE
SUPPORTERS AN OPTICIAN OF. MAY
THE BILL THAT I ASKED FOR YOUR
I. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATE
SKINNER AND- CENTER WAS THERE A
MOTION ON THIS. MOTION BY SEN
SO OKAY- WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS EIGHTY THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TANK THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
SENATOR WINNER BY WINNER OUR
MORAL. NO. MORRELL NO SORRY
BROWN THOUGH BATES MILL HE
BATES NO CABALLERO DEBORAH. HI
TORONTO HI MCGUIRE MORLOCK FIVE
MORLOCK I RALPH HEY RALPH HIS
BY SKINNER HI NUMBER WHAT HI
CASKEY I. THREE SIX TWO OKAY
THAT IS NOT BOTH TO GET A PUT
OUR CALL FOR MEMBERS BECAUSE WE
TO BILLS. LEFT WE HAVE AN AB
THIRD THREE AWAY BY SOME I'M
WORKING. CENTER CARVE A IS
PRESENTING UP TO SHE AND IT WAS
A YOU'RE GOING TO GO OFFICE AND
SO I DON'T KNOW- PERHAPS WE
COULD I THINK WE SHE SAID SHE
CAN COME BACK IF WE NEED HER. A
SECOND COULD WE ASK HER TO COME
BACK TO PRISON BUT BUILT AND
THEN WILL BE- BOB REMIND YOU
TAKE A BREAK AND THEN WARMING
UP AB. ONE SIXTY EIGHT. CLOSE
UP SMEROM. HOUSE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. ONE SIX THE RECORD
YOU KNOW JUDICIARY HAD EIGHTY
BILL HI I FEEL FOR THEM SO-
LET'S JUST HOLD ON HOLD FOR ONE
SECOND TRY TO GET CENTER TO
COME IF SHE IS A.
TO OKAY- I AM
GOING TO PENSION AND- PRESENTS.
AB THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE CABALLERO
WHO'S WHO'S GONNA PRESENT ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL- SO HAND THE- CENTER
MORLOCK. FEDERAL OCT. I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA PRESENT THE NEXT BILL
BY SOME MEMBER GABRIEL. AND SO.
NO I'D RATHER TO SENATOR BATES
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO IS THAT WHAT
I. OKAY OKAY- MAY. CENTER FIVE
COLLEAGUES- AB THIRTY THREE
AWAY BY SOME MEMBER GABRIEL
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
RESTRICT OCCUPANCY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON SCHOOL
DISTRICT OWNED LAND. WHICH IS
BEING FUNDED WITH LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS- IT ALLOWS
RESTRICTION TO TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICT. EMPLOYEES OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE THE LAN
IT FURTHER ALLOWS IMPORTER
EMPLOYEES TO ALSO OCCUPY THE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTED UNDER THIS
PROVISION THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO CREATE MORE
FLEXIBILITY ON PREVIOUS FOR
TWENTY SIXTEEN- BY MY
PREDECESSORS CENTER MARK NO
THAT WE CAN ALL SCHOOL THIS TO
BUILD HOUSING BUT I WAS. REPEAT
YOUR AND APART. BEFORE ABOUT
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TO LIVE
THERE I STARTED FOR THE YOUR
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. AND SHOULD COME. OKAY
WE NOW HAVE A LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS- TEAM
HUTCHINGS FROM THE CITY OF
REDWOOD CITY. AND SO. WE CAN BE
AMERICA'S CARE. NEAR ME YEAH.
GREAT A GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBER STATE HUTCHINGS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY PRIVATE
JETTY IN STRONG SUPPORT IN A CO
SPONSOR OF THE NEEDS OF THE
TRIO EIGHT- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
GREAT GABRIEL HAVE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH YOUR ADVOCATE IN
ALLOWING MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
ADDRESSING OUR REGION HOUSING
NEEDS. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK
ABOUT HOUSING COMMITTEE STAFFS
AND REPUBLICAN CAUCUS STAFF I'M
WORKING WITH THIS DIRE OUT SOME
OF THE. MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES.
AFTER SOME TIME NOW THERE'S
BEEN A DESIGN JANET COUNTY. TO
DEVELOP WORKFORCE. PRIMARILY
FOR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. BUT
CHALLENGED TO OUR- YOUNG ISSUE.
FIND INDIVIDUAL THE L. OF A-
SCHOOL. WHO WOULD QUALIFY FOR
ON LOW INCOME HOUSE TAX CREDIT
UTILIZATION. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BOB WHICH SIGNIFY SCOLDED WAS
FOR TO CONTROL RESULTING INTO
THEIR K. TWO SIX CAMPUSES. WITH
ONLY AFTER THEY GET CURRENT
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE DEMAND
CHALLENGE THE DISTRICT WHICH
RAISING. A. B. THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT PART WHAT ALLOW PER CITY
COUNT AND OTHER PUBLIC AGING TO
WORK. WITH THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. TO BUILD WORKFORCE
HOUSING ON PROPERTY OWNED BY
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT. AT
PRESENT THE RIGHT BUT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT RED WITH CITY
REQUIRE UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND OTHERS ARE WORKING
ON A PROJECT IN THE HEART OF
DOWNTOWN REDWOOD CITY THAT
WOULD PROVIDE HIGH DENSITY
WORKFORCE HOUSING ON SCHOOL
DISTRICT. PROPERTY THREE
APPROACH ALLOW A PORTION
APPLICABLE WITH CITY AND OTHER
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES TO
BACKFILL THE DEMANDS FOR BOTH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- WHILE STILL
ALLOWING FOR READ WITHIN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
RETAIN CONTROL. AND PREFERENCE
TO COMPORT WITH FEATURES
HOUSING ACT TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND
THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT GUIDELINES. THE
SUCCESSFUL PASSAGE OF THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW. BIG CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO OPEN UP THE
POOL OF POTENTIAL APPLICANTS
INCREASING PROJECTED RENTAL
DEMAND AND THEY TO. SECURE THE
FINANCE NEEDED TO THE PROJECT
OFF THE- IN SHORTEST WILL HAVE
A TANGIBLE IMPACT IN HELPING
OUR REGION YOU HOUSING ME.
EQUITIES RESEARCH URGENT
SUPPORT THE QUESTION I BOTH ON
EITHER BETWEEN EIGHT THANK YOU
I THANK YOU MUCH ONE GO TO THE-
COLOR COMMENT. WHICH HAS MY
WILL BE LIMITED TO NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY- AND STATING
THAT YOU SUPPORT I DON'T SEE
ANY IS THERE ANYONE UP IN THE-
SUPPORT OF. THE FORTY- WHICH IS
AGAIN I'M THE ONE NOW MOVES TO
THE PHONE LINES AGAIN YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY- AND THE
FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THE PART AB THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE UP
TO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GET MISUSED
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK. NEXT
WILL BE COME FROM TWO THIRTY
SEVEN TO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHARE MEMBERS LUKE
MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA YIMBY
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. IN MEXICO TO LINE UP
THIRTY TO THIRTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. THE LORD DURIAN
FLORIDA. LEGAL FOR YOU TO
STATION IN SUPPORT. AN ACTUAL
GO TO LINE OF THREE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE ORDER SHALL
WOULD LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE I COULD
CONTACT THE BILL AND WEREN'T
SUPPORT. NEXT PHOTO LINE AT
THREE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS JACK
GARDNER PRESIDENT OF THE JOHN
STORE COMPANY- A SUPPORT EIGHTY
THREE THREE OH EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE OH EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE OH
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. WELL WITHOUT CAROLINE OF
THREE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JORDAN GRIMES CALLING
FROM SAN MATTEO CALIFORNIA
CAPITAL ONE ALE IN STRONG.
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER
FOR SUPPORT OF AB. THREE THREE
ZERO EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
TWO FIFTY THREE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
HENRY HOOKER CALLING PERCENT OF
CHRISTIANITY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. YEAH AND AGAIN AT THE ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THREE THREE ZERO EIGHT. AND
WE HAVE NOBODY ELSE IN PUMA'S
FUTURE. OKAY THANK YOU ANOTHER
THE OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION- IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION NO TWENTY FORTY-
KNOWING THERE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO
AB THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT AGAIN-
YOU CAN STATE YOUR OPPOSITE. IF
YOU IF YOU ARE OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE THREE ZERO EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE ZERO IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. THREE THREE
ZERO EIGHT. AND NOBODY IN CUBA
STRUCTURE OKAY THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER CALTRAIN MOVED
THE BILL. CUSTOMERS ADELE
CENTER OFFICE. OKAY FUNCTIONS
ARE COMMENTS BY MEMBER. PLACE
OKAY SEEING NINE CENTER
CABALLERO WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MUCH- WITHOUT WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL ON AB THREE THREE
OH EIGHT. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL TO
MOTIONS DO PASS SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE MORRELL. NO
MORAL FAITH. CABALLERO HI
COPYRIGHT TO RUSSELL. TORONTO I
MCGUIRE MORLOCK. HI MARK I ROTH
HI ROTH AYE SKINNER BY SKINNER
NUMBER. NUMBER FIVE HOTEL SKI
HIGH WITH I. IT ONE OF THE TO
ONE WILL THAT ON FOR THE OF MY-
THE COLORS WE HAVE ROOM BILL IF
YOU ONE SIXTY EIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A BRIEF RECESS- AND
THEN WE WILL RETURN AND START
IT IS THREE THIRTY NOW. BUT WE
WILL TAKE A FIFTEEN MINUTE
RECESS. AND RETURN AT THREE
FORTY FIVE SO IF EVERYONE COULD
PLEASE BE ON THE FLOOR AT THREE
FORTY FIVE I WOULD APPRECIATE
IT. YOUR WE ARE IN RECESS UNTIL.
THREE FORTY. OKAY WE ARE-
ENDING OUR RECESS. AND I
APOLOGIZE I SAID WE WERE GOING
TO RECONVENE AT THREE FORTY
FIVE AND ITSELF FOR EIGHT SO MY
APOLOGIES TO COLLEAGUES A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC FOR THAT
DELAY BUT IT WASN'T. SO WE HAVE
NOW. COMPLETED UP OVER WE TO
LIVE CALL OF THE- OF RUNNING A
TO OUR FOR BILL OF THE DAY. AB
SIXTY EIGHT. WHICH HAS BEEN RE
REFER TO THIS CAN PER SE THE
SAN RULES. NINE POINT ONE OH B.
AND THE AUTHOR IS A SAM MEMBER
CURRY. WHO IS HERE WE'LL PUT
THE BILL. I WANTED TO STAY THIS
MEMBER FOR. WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE. FOR THE LAW FORTY
MONTHS AND SOME OF THE YOU MAKE.
THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M TO
PRESENT MY BILL AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT TO RISK THE RIGHTS CAL
TRIBAL GO. TO CON. ON PROJECTS
THAT MAY FOR DIMINISH THE CULT
AND THE REESE. REMAINING IN OUR
STATE. JUST OVER A YEAR AGO ON
JUNE SEVENTEENTH GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. IS SHOOTING ORDER MARK
MORE MEMORIALIZE AN APOLOGY THE
COW NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION.
HE SAID CALIFORNIA'S RECKONED
WITH OUR DARKEST. CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE SUFFERED
VIOLENCE DISCRIMINATION
EXPLOITATION SANCTIONED BY
STATE GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
ITS HISTORY. WE CAN NEVER UNDO
THE WRONGS INFLICTED ON THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LIVED IN ON
THIS LAND THAT WE NOW CALL
CALIFORNIA SINCE TIME
IMMEMORIAL. WELL WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO BUILD BRIDGES. TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT OUR PAST AND
BEGIN TO HEAL DEEP WOUNDS.
TODAY WE CAN BEGIN TO RIGHT ONE
WRONG AND BEGIN TO PUT THOSE
WORDS INTO ACTION. FOR MUCH
HELLO HISTORY. FILE IN TWO
GAMES LEGAL RIGHTS INSTEAD IN
THE LAW CONCERNING OF THEIR
CULTURAL RESOURCES. THAT AMOUNT
OF PROGRESS TOWARD THE SCHOOL
WAS ACHIEVED IN SB EIGHTEEN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. AND AB FIFTY TWO
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. IT
TWO THOUSAND. IN RECOGNITION OF
OUR STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS SB
THIRTY FIVE ALLOWED MANY
HOUSING PROJECTS TO BE EXEMPTED
FROM THE SEQUEL. BUT TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES WERE NOT ON
THIS LIST. THERE BY ELIMINATING
TRIBAL RIGHTS TO CONSULTATION
ON THESE PROJECTS. THE BILL
EXEMPTED SEVERAL CATEGORIES OF
NON TRIBAL RESOURCES FOR FROM
STREAMLINING ELIMINATING ANY
OPPORTUNITY INCLUDED INCLUDING
NO LEGAL RECOURSE FOR
DEVELOPERS TO PROCEED WITH THE
PROJECT THAT IMPACTS A
PROTECTED RESOURCE. LET ME BE
CLEAR THE APPLICANT CAN ONLY
CONTESTING OF AN EXAM RESEARCH.
NOT TO PROCEED WITH A PROJECT
TO DO WITH A PROJECT TO DAMAGES.
THE TRIBAL CULTURE REDUCE THE
BURDEN RELIGIOUS RESOURCES WERE
LEFT OUT. LET ME MAKE IT CLEAR.
I DO NOT BLAME YOU CHAIRMAN
WIENER FOR THIS OVERSIGHT AS
MANY OF US DELIVERING ON THAT
BILL WE'RE ALSO UNAWARE OF THE
DAMAGE WE WERE DOING TO TRIBAL
RIGHTS. A SHOULD NOT THE FINEST.
HOW WE WORK TO FIX IT DOES.
WHAT BEGAN WE ALLEGE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN INTRODUCED IN
JANUARY OF LAST YEAR TO
REESTABLISH THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION ROLE IN
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT MAY
IMPACT TRAVEL RESOURCES.
SENATORS SINCE WE LEFT THIS
COMMITTEE WITH A UNANIMOUS VOTE
LAST FALL THE ONLY CHANGES MADE
TO THE BILL HAVE BEEN MADE TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS FROM THE
CHAIR. AND THE BUILDING
COMMUNITY. WELL AFTER WELL
AFTER WELL OVER A YEAR OF
NEGOTIATION AND STAKEHOLDERS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS CBA THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND HOUSING ADVOCATES. AND
NUMEROUS MEETINGS WITH MISTER
CHAIR AND CONSULTANTS FROM THE
THREE SENATE COMMITTEES OF
JURISDICTION. HOUSING EQ
GOVERNMENT FINANCES WE HAVE
MADE SEVERAL ROUNDS OF MAJOR
AMENDMENTS. WE HAVE PAINS TO
CONSTRUCTED SCOPING LOCATION.
FOR SUCH PROJECTS TO STILL
STREAMLINING THAT EXISTS NO
OTHER NON TRIBAL CATEGORY OF
RESOURCE. WE NOW PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROJECTS
INVOLVED INVOLVING TCRS TO
ACCESS STREAMLINING. PROVIDE
FOR NOTIFICATION TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS A PROJECT INTENSE A
LOCAL DEVELOPMENT RULES ARE
LOCKED IN PLACE SB THREE
THIRTY. AND REQUIRE A
NOTIFICATION OF PARTIES WHY
PERMIT FOR SB THIRTY FIVE IS
BEING REJECTED TO PROVIDE A
RECORD OF ANY BAD FAITH
DECISION BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AS YOU IN OUR MOST RECENT ME MR
CHAIR WE ARE DOWN TO ISSUE. SO
I WILL NOT ADDRESS THE- OF
OTHER CHIU. WE'VE MADE TO MOVE
THE BILL IN A DIRECTION YOU AND
THE BUILDING COMMUNITY MIGHT
ACCEPT. MOST WILL NOT BE OF
INTEREST TO TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
MOST OF THE REMAINING PROJECTS
THAT WARRANT INVESTIGATION WILL
NOT THREATEN TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES. FOR THOSE THAT DO AN
AGREEMENT TO AVOID OR MITIGATE
IMPACTS TO A TRIBAL CULTURE OR
RELIGIOUS RESOURCE WILL ALLOW
THE PROJECT TO CONTINUE ON TO
STREAMLINING. YOU'VE ALSO
AGREED MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
THIS THAT THE SUGGESTION THAT
TRIBE GOVERNMENTS WOULD MISS.
SOMETHING SO CORE TO THEIR
CULTURE AND BELIEVES IS ABSURD
AND ALTHOUGH SO OPPONENTS MAY
WHISPER. THIS COULD BE TRUE TO
THEY'VE NEVER GIVEN UP FOR.
EXAMPLE OF THIS. EVER ANYWHERE
IN THE STATE. WHETHER ANOTHER
RESOURCE EXISTS UNDER SB THIRTY
FIVE CAN BE CHEN IN COURT. WHEN
ONE SUGGESTED CULTURE RESEARCH
DOES EXIST. WHAT IT IS. SO THE
FINAL ISSUE BY THE COMMITTEE
USURY FOR AN TO ALLOW ANY WHO
CAN REACH INTO TO AVOID OR
MITIGATE A TRY CALL OR
RELIGIOUS RESOURCE TO SEEK
COURT APPROVAL TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE OBJECTIONS OF THE
IMPACT TO TRY. MISTER CHAIRMAN
NO MATTER HOW MANY CREATIVE
ANSWERS ARE CRAFTED. TO IGNORE
THE REALITY. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT INSTANCES WHICH- QUESTION
TRAVEL CULTURE. AND CAN ABOUT
ITS EXISTENCE. I CANNOT ACCEPT
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE FOR KNOWING
DESTROY OF WHAT REMAINS OF
TRIBAL HISTORY AND THE CULTURE
OF THE STATE. IF AN APPLICANT
WANTS TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PROJECT THE DEMAND DAMAGES OR
DESTROYS THE TRIBAL RELIGIOUS
OR CULTURAL RESOURCE. THAT THAT
REALITY EXISTENCE SEQUENCE
WHERE AT LEAST THE TRIBES HAVE
A FIGHTING CHANCE. THE
AMENDMENT THIS OP BY YOU
DEVELOP STICKER WOULD TAKE AWAY
ANY INCIDENT FOR. APPLICANTS TO
SEEK A GREEN. KNOWING THEY HAVE
THE BACKS OF OUR COURT SYSTEM
WOULD. RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
TRAMPLED FOR GENERATIONS. THAT
QUOTE UNQUOTE OPPORTUNITY
EXISTS IN SEQUENCE AND SHOULD
NOT BE MADE EASIER. IF THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AN
AMENDMENT TO ALLOW AN APPLICANT
TO PURSUE A PROJECT IN A
WETLAND THAT'S COASTAL ZONE RUN
PROPERTY OF THE COW MISSIONS
WHICH ARE CALLED HAS DEEMED
HISTORICALLY. THREE COULD BE SO.
AND WOULD BE HARSH. A MR CHEN
AND SENATORS SB THIRTY FIVE
PROVIDES NO. TO FOR OTHER NON
REESE WHERE YOU ARE OUT IN THE
TRIBES. FURTHER CLAIMS THAT THE
BILL GIVE THE TRIBE SOME SORT
OF VETO AUTHORITY PERSON UNTRUE.
APPLICANTS ARE C. AN UP TO
INDUSTRY. AND THE TRIBES HAVE
CRAFT A- PROCESS. TO STILL
ACCESS STREAMLINING. THE
EXEMPTION OCCURS WHEN AN
AGREEMENT TO AVOID OR MITIGATE
ANY IMPACT OF TRIBAL CULTURE
RESOURCE CANNOT BE REACHED. WE
HAVE PAINSTAKINGLY CONSTRUCTED
A PROCESS FOR SUCH PROJECTS TO
STILL INDUSTRY MONEY THAT
EXISTS FOR NO OTHER CATEGORY.
OF RESOURCE. MORE OVER THE
ALTERNATIVE IS NOT NOT BE
TERMINATED PROJECT. IT IS THE
SEQUEL PROCESS THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS RESERVED FOR EVERY OTHER
CATEGORY OF NON TRIBAL
RESOURCES UNDER SB THIRTY FIVE.
AND A PROCESS WHICH BY NATURE
WILL BE BRIEF BECAUSE THE
APPLICANT MUST CERTIFY NO OTHER
C. PUT IN TAXES. THIS CHAIRMAN
I WILL GLADLY ENGAGING YOU IN
FURTHER DOES TO CLARIFY THE
ROLE OF LOW AND GOVERNMENTS BUT
YOU BELIEVE TO BE AN CLEAR.
WHAT I CANNOT ACCEPT. IS A
CORPORATE. TO ALLOW PROJECT
PROCEED EVEN IT WOULD JUST. A
TRIBAL REDUCE. AGAIN THE
ABILITY DOES NOT OF FOR ANY
OTHER THINGS RESOURCE. EVERYONE
HEARING WHO WE'VE DONE
BREAKDOWN DAM TO OUR IN OUR TO
INDEED PEOPLE AND GOT. I'VE MET
WITH OF EACH OF YOU AND WE ALL
WE MUST FIX THE ERROR MADE IN
SB THIRTY FIVE IT WERE THE HAVE
WITH THE FATAL FLAW. THE
GOVERNOR SAID LAST YEAR WE MISS
READ THE PAIN HAVE BEEN FOR THE-
AND TRIED REAP THE REAL. WITH
THEIR SAYS SITE TRIBE
GOVERNMENTS. FORCING INTO A
STACK COURT PROCESS EVERY TIME
APPLICANT ONE TO PURSUE TO YET
TO HIS. CULTURAL FOR RELIGIOUS
RESTORE. FOR THE X. PURPOSE FOR
PER TO. IT IS NOT THE WE BE TO
REPAIR THE- THAT WE HAVE DONE.
SO PAULA FOR IT ARE ERRORS
IMPORT ACTIONS IN CHAU WHETHER
WE REALLY MEAN THEM. I ASK FOR
THIS PER OF A ANSWER SO THE
TRIBAL. CAN HAVE A ON MATTER OF
THEIR RIGHTS. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. THANK YOU. I
THANK YOU MEMBER WE WILL NOW GO.
YOUR. SEATS MAN. WHENEVER I GO
TO YOUR. LEGAL AND THEY ARE
ALARM AROUND THE FROM TIME
ABOUND OF THE GENERAL INDIAN
THANKS FOR THE CALL FROM OVER
INDIAN COMMUNITY WE HAVE A WE
HAVE BY THIS HEARING. SEVENTY
TWO WITNESSES MYSTERONS- AND
THIS COIL YOUR TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES AND SO I WOULD YEAH SO
YOU EACH PERHAPS TYNER'S. AT
TWO MINUTES ONE DOESN'T HE AND
THE OTHER HI TIME SO YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE ARE READY.
PERHAPS MISTER. FOR GOOD
AFTERNOON. GERMINOMA OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M LAW MARANDA
MEMBER TO TRY AND AN ATTORNEY
FOR TWENTY YEARS ON LANDING
ISSUE AND CALLED RESEARCH FOR
TECH. HI SIR AS TECHNICAL
EXPERT ON SB. AND AB FIFTY TWO
I ALSO HAVE THE OF STATE NATIVE
AND HERITAGE TO ALTHOUGH I AM
HERE BACK. TO THIS BILL ONE
SIXTY EIGHT CORRECTION OF BY
THE LATEST WOULD TRAVEL CALL
REESE. OR FROM THE LAW OF X. TO
STREAMLINING UNDER AT THIRTY.
ALTHOUGH OUR TRAVEL RE. HAVE
BEEN IN SEQUENCE AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN. AND THEN GENERAL
STANDARDS AND TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR. TRAVEL READ WORKING
OVERLOOKED THE LEAD HAS.
OVERSIGHT IS AND CAN. WITH THE
STATUS RESPECT ENDING TOWARD
CAL AND. AS THE MOMENT HEY.
ALLOWED AT ALL UNDER ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WHICH TRAVEL RESOURCES
THAT ARE NOT ON REGISTERS
LISTED STREAMLINING CAN OCCUR
IF THE PARTY DOCUMENT AND
ENFORCEABLE TREATMENT AGREEMENT
IT'S THAT STRAIGHTFORWARD BONTA
FAR TOO MANY OCCASIONS TRIED TO
HAVE BEEN DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
AND YOU WILL PROCESSES
DEVELOPERS WILL TELL OUR PEOPLE
THAT WE DON'T KNOW THE LOCATION
THE SIGNIFICANT. EVEN THE
PURPOSE OF OUR OWN. SERVER
TRIED TO ENGAGE IN THE PROCESS
IS FUNDED LEVEL OF RESPECT AND
CONFIDENCE IS REQUIRED SO THE
PROCESS WILL BE AND PREJUDICE.
ONLY YOU CAN DO THIS. TRY TO
RECOGNIZE IMMEDIATE NEED FOR
MORE HOUSING WE ALSO KNOW THAT
IN TWENTY TWENTY HOUSING CAN BE
STREAMLINED AT THE SAME TIME
THE TRAVEL SAFER PLACES CAN BE
RESPECTED. THIS IS NOT AN
EITHER OR ISSUE IT'S A BOTH AND
ISSUE DOES THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE STATE VALUE THE HISTORY AND
CULTURE OF THE FIRST
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS FOR AND I WILL NOW GO
TO MISS COYLE ON THIS CALL YOU
HAVE A MINUTE FORTY FIVE
SECONDS. MY NAME IS COURTNEY
COIL OUTSIDE COUNSEL FOR UNITED
AUBURN. I HAVE PRACTICED A
CULTURAL RESOURCES LINE SEQUEL
FOR NEARLY THIRTY YEARS AND
ASSISTED ON RELEVANT
LEGISLATION. INCLUDING SB
EIGHTY AND AB FIFTY TWO. BOB
BURNS AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT TO
ENSURE THAT THE PROTECTIONS OF
AB FIFTY TWO ARE NO LONGER
CHAPTER DOUBT BY OPERATION OF
SB THIRTY FIVE HE B. FIFTY TWO
WITH SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN RECOGNIZING A SEPARATE
CATEGORY OF RESOURCES UNDER C.
CLASS. TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE TO BE
IDENTIFIED TO THE SPECIAL
EXPERTISE OF CALIFORNIA TRIBES.
SB THIRTY FIVE WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CONTAINING EXEMPTIONS FROM
STEAM STREAMLINING PUTTING FOR
A LISTED HISTORIC STRUCTURES
HOWEVER TRIBES WERE NOT
CONSULTED AND TRIBAL CULTURL
RESOURCES WERE NOT MENTIONED
NAY. AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT WAS
INTRODUCED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TO AT RIVAL CONTROL RESOURCES
TO THE EXTENSIVE LIST OF.
RESOURCES EVERYTHING.
STREAMLINING THEN THE AUTHOR
TICKET A DAY AMEND. SINCE THE
MAN OF MY VOTED. AND OF THIS
BILL ALL THESE AMENDMENTS WERE
THOUGHTFULLY DESIGNED WITH THE
PARTICIPATION OF LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL TO IDENTIFY TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES EARLY IN THE
PROCESS. PROMOTE COLLABORATIVE
DISCUSSIONS TO AVOID LITIGATION
AVOID MIXING DISCRETIONARY
ACTIONS INTO A MINISTERIAL
PROCESS AVOID NEEDLESSLY
IMPORTING SEQUEL LANGUAGE.
AVOIDING CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES
AND TO PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY AND
CLARITY TO PROJECT APPLICANTS.
THROUGH THESE AMENDMENTS THE
AUTHOR HAS DONE HER BEST TO
MEET BOTH THE NEEDS OF PRIDE
AND APPLICANTS WITHIN THE
CONSTRAINTS OF THE EXISTING
LAWN POLICY. THE GOOD BILL EVEN
THAT I REMAIN OF A FOR QUEST.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS COYLE
AND I WANTED TO GO OVER THE
RECORD THAT YOU NAILED IT IN
TERMS OF THE EXACT NUMBER OF
SECONDS SO THAT IS VERY
IMPRESSIVE. THANK YOU THAT'S MY
NAMESO OKAY WILL NOW GO TO
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT. AS A
REMINDER- THE REMAINING PUBLIC
COMMENT BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD THE
LEAD WITNESSES WHO HAVE
ARTICULATED- VERY POWERFULLY-
THERE THE- PERSPECTIVE OF
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL- WE'RE
SO. ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE LIMITED TO STATING YOUR
NAME. YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY.
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL- GO
TO THE- FIVE CHAMBERS GALLERY.
ONE ON TO ROOMS READY AND ONE
AGAIN IS NO IN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS SAID I'VE TO CEASE IN ANY
COMMITTEE AND CAN TWENTY FORTY
I DON'T KNOW WHY- AND SO WILL
NOW GO TO THE TELEPHONE SET UP
FOR THE MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP
UP. COMMENTERS ON THE- THANK
YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT. WE
WILL CULTURAL LINE UP FIVE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JOB FRANK MOLINA
BEHALF OF THE SALMON OF
ANIMATION INDIANS AND THIS IS
MANISHA MENTIONED IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
CHARACTER FROM ONE NINETY FOUR.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT.
ONE MOMENT HERE. OKAY NEXT LINE
WILL BE. THREE FIFTY SIX THREE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
KNOW LEVEL TO THE NEXT LINE OF
THREE FIFTY NINE. THREE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY I
WE ALL I'M YOU. OKAY NUMBER GO
TO THE NEXT ONE.
AND THE NEXT
ONE WILL COME FROM THE LINE OF
THREE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THANK YOU GERMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ENTER
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF THE
MORONGO BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
COMES FROM THE LINE OF THREE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MERRY VELARDO THE TOWARDS
MARTINEZ DESERT CAHUILLA
INDIANS AND REPRESENTATIVE OF-OUR CULTURAL COMMITTEE OF
SENIOR AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE COME FOR THE
NEXT ONE THREE SIXTY SEVEN GO
AHEAD LINE IS NOW OPEN. THREE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEY WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ONE WE HAVE LINE AT NUMBER
THREE OF FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS AFRIKA ORDER
SOME OF THE ROLE TRIBAL MEMBER
OF THE KLAMATH TRIBE CALLING IN
SUPPORT. FOR THREE. THE TRICK
RITUALLY AMANDA PUMMEL INDIANS
THE RINCON THE END OF THE TO
SEND YOU INDIANS AND THE TWO
LITER TRACK. AND OUR NEXT LINE
IS THREE AT SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CATALINA
COLUMN I AM THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE TRIBAL ALLIANCE BOB AND
INDIGNATION. AND DINNER
GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATION THE
FEDERAL CORRECT NITRIDE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE I AM IN
SUPPORT. L. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND OUR NEXT LINE IS THREE
OF FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS OF
THE BERRY BROKE ON BEHALF OF
THE ALL WILL CALL THE
INDEPENDENT CAHUILLA INDIANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE LINE
IS THREE FORTY THREE AM PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
CANNOT ON BEHALF YEAH IN THE
END AND UMBILICAL CUOMO OF
UPPER LAKE WE APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR REJECTING CANADIAN AND
THEN STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
GRAHAM THANK YOU. AND THEN IN
THE NEXT ONE COMES FROM A LINE
OF THREE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. I HAD BEEN. RIGHT
GOOD EVENING THIS IS ROSEMARIE
MORE WE ALL TRAVEL TREASURE FOR
THE TOWARDS WORKING TOGETHER
CREATING ANYTHING WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIFTY EIGHT
TO PROTECT HER FIGHT. THANK YOU.
SENATE FINANCE ONE NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS JILL
STUART LITTLE CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND
THEN I FINALLY THREE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAROLINE
BILL HUNTER ON BEHALF OF YOUR
TO THE HE WENT TO NATION
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL. AND
OUR NEXT LINE WILL COME FROM
THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI READ VERY MUCH FROM
THAT DATE. OF BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
ARE WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING. ONE
SIXTY. YOU AND OUR NEXT FINAL
COMPANY THREE SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE SEVENTY AIRLINES
OPEN. DO YOU HAVE ME ON MUTE.
LOCAL ON THE NECKLINE OF. THREE
SEVENTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH LEARN YOU'RE TAKING CON ON
BEHALF OF THE CORONA BANDED
THAT MISSION INDIANS AND
SUPPORT. AND I PLAN WILL COME
FROM THREE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
POLITICS ON BEHALF OF THE-
COLUSA INDIAN COMMUNITY CHINA
BANNED THE NEW INDIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. P. AND AT OUR IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. ONE
ZERO IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX
EIGHT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
UP THREE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. VERY ROMANTIC- INTO
PORT OF THE WEST BERKELEY SHELL
MOUND AND SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT WITHOUT AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SIX EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. IN OUR NEXT LINE WILL
COME FROM THREE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SUSAN JENSEN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF JEAN I GUESS REPRESENTS
THIRTY FIVE BUT REALLY
RECOGNIZE TRIBAL GOVERNMENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND IN SUPPORT
OF H. B. ONE SIX EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. I DON'T KNOW
LINE WILL BE SO FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IRWIN BILL HUNTER ABI
HAPPY- TODAY WE HE WENT TO
NATION AND FROM SUPPORT. AND AS
A REMINDER IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SIX EIGHT MY PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE VIDEO TO BE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE SIX EIGHT. AND THERE IS
NO FURTHER- ANYONE IN Q. COULD
YOU SUCCESSFUL MORE TIME PLEASE.
YES IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX
EIGHT. MY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
OUR LINE UP THREE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY CLIENT OF
A HALF TABLE MOUNTAIN RANCHERIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND I COLOR
COMPANY THREE AT FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
REPURPOSE ENDING FEDERATED
INDIANS UPGRADE RANCHERIA IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OBVIOUSLY
WITHOUT AN AMENDMENT. AND I
CLAMOR FROM THE THREE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE OPEN. HELLO
THERE. HELLO I'M IN. OF. ONE
SIX AB ONE EIGHT ALSO TOP IN A
NUMBER FROM LOCAL BAND THANK
YOU. REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN OF
AB ONE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX EIGHT.
AND THERE IS NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY COULD YOU CHECK
ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE WE
GOT EVERYONE. YEAH IF YOU ARE A
PART OF AB ONE SIX EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. ONE
ZERO YOUR EXPORT OF AB ONE SIX
EIGHT. THERE IS NO WARNING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME IF YOU CHECK
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT
AYE CONCLUDES SUPPORT TESTIMONY
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITE WE TO
OPPONENTS THE DEPARTMENTS WILL
BE TESTIFYING MICHAEL GUNNING
FOR THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
PRESERVATION- AND MILES I'M ALL
FOR. THE LAW FOR KOGAN'S TOP PM
BASS YOU ALL HAVE THE SAME FOUR
MINUTES THAT THE I SUPPORTERS
ADAM BONUS POINTS IF YOU FOR
SPACES CORNELL IN TAKING THE
EXACT NUMBER OF. I WOULD
RECOMMEND IF YOU SILVA TOO MANY
SO THAT YOU BOTH. IN ORDER TO.
FIVE OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE. TO
HAVE THE OF THEM. SHOULD BE ON
THE PHONE. OKAY WHY DON'T WE
START WITH A YEAH. THE COMPANY
WENT PUBLIC AND I'M TOLD THAT
MICHAEL GOING MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
ON THE PUBLIC COMMON LINE SO HE
MIGHT HAVE TO. THE OTHER WAY.
SO WE'LL START WITH MICHAEL
GONNA YOU CAN PRESS. SO MICHAEL
GONNA YOU CAN PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND IF THIS IS MICHAEL
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MICHAEL ON THE LINE. MICHAEL
HAVE TO PUSH ONE ZERO. MICHAEL
YOUR LINE IS AN OPEN. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL GETTING HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO THE BILL I THINK THE
I. EIGHT REPORTS INTENT OF AB
ONE BIG THE EIGHT PROVIDE
AMERICAN PRIDE BIG GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT. THE TROUBLE COOPER
PROVIDED ON SPEAKER PART OF THE
SB THIRTY FIVE HOUSING FOR WITH
YOU. A. B. I. A. ALL SUPPORT
THE TRIBAL READ ARE TREATED
SAME AS ALL OTHER ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA CRITERIA UNDER THE
THIRTY FIVE. WHAT WE OBJECT TO
IN THE LATEST VERSION OF THE S.
AB ONE FIFTY EIGHT. A CURRENT
LANGUAGE TREATS TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES DIFFERENTLY THAN ANY
OTHER SB THIRTY FIVE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA BY
ELIMINATING DUE PROCESS IN
GIVING TRIED THAN. DOUBLE DIGIT
NET THE WEATHER HOUSING PROJECT
IS ELIGIBLE. FOR SB THIRTY FIVE.
BEYOND WHAT CURRENTLY THE LAW
SPEAK WELL WHAT IS CURRENTLY
THE FOR ALL THE THIRTY FIVE
BUILD. CRITERIA AND IN FACT
WHAT IT CURRENTLY THE LAW FOR
ALL GOVERNMENT LAND USE
ENTITLEMENT THE DIGIT. ALL OF
SB THIRTY FIVE BILLION TO. ARE
MADE BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND ARE APPEALABLE COURT BY ANY
THAT OBJECT. THIS IS THE CASE
NO MATTER THE ISSUE WHETHER THE
PROJECT SITE IS LOCATED IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. A LET LEARN A
CRIME FARMLAND. HABITATS FOR
PROSPECTIVE ET WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEMOLITION OF HISTORIC
STRUCTURES FOR THE EVALUATION
OF ANY OTHER. QUALIFYING
CRITERIA. FOLLOWING TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT GOT CALLED. THE
LOCAL GOT MAKE THE TERM. AND
THAT THE WAS APPEALED TO COURT
ANY. IN THE OF A ONE EIGHT OF
THE TWO OF THE PRODUCT MAY NOT
MOVE. ACTO OF. NO THEY JOHNSON
DECISION. THANK PRESIDENTIAL
ISSUE FOR SPEED A WE ARE NOT
AWARE OF ANY OTHER LAND I DON'T
KNOW TO BY LOCAL STATE OR
GOVERNMENT BODY NOT SUBJECT TO.
AND REVIEWABLE BY THE COURTS
THE ABILITY TO AN APPEAL OF
GOVERNMENT. IT'S FUN TO
ELEMENTS TO DO PRODUCT. YOUR
CALL MISTER CHAIRMAN A MAN WE
THE IN OF ONE A IN THE IN. OF
THE TRIBAL CALL PROCESS THAT
THE OF THE SPEAKER FIVE PROJECT
REVIEW BUT WE RESPECTFULLY THAT
THE BILL BE AMENDED PER THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ON THE MENTAL DUE
PROCESS IS NOT. PART OF THE
IMPORTANT PROCEDURE THANK YOU.
BUT YOU VERY MUCH FOR NOW MOVE
TO. AND WALL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME SMILE
THEY WANT IN ON PARTNER AT THE
LAW FIRM PUBLISHED PASSED IN
THAT TAMPA. RIGHT OKAY ON LAND.
BEING AYE HOW APPLICANTS THE
COPS COME AND DYNAMIC PROCESS
MANY OF MY CLIENTS ARE HELPING.
INCLUDING A FOUR HOUSING. AND I.
AM SEVERAL AT THIRTY FIVE FIVE.
THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS THAT THE
TRUE AND- PROCESS CAN BE
DAUNTING. IT'S A LENGTHY ANSWER.
SUBJECTS THE LATEST. WE THIS IS
TRUE IF FOR PRIDE THAT ARE
PERCENT COMBINED ZONING. THIRTY
FIVE PROVING TO BE A OF TO
PROGRAM THE- ESPECIALLY PROUD
HOUSING PROJECTS BY. ON
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS THIRTY FIVE
PROVIDE CERTAINTY. IS CERTAINLY
IS INCREDIBLY VALUABLE
PARTICULARLY FOR AFFORDABLE
PROJECTS THAT ARE VERY
COMPLICATED TO FINANCE
INSURANCE IN THE TIME FRAME
FROM YEAR TO MONTH. GET THAT
PORTABLE HOUSING UNITS BUILT
QUICKLY MANY AFFORDABLE UNITS
WILL OME ONLINE IN SOONER AS A
RESULT OF THE LAW. IT THAT
THIRTY FIVE PROJECT DO NOT BE
TRACK. PRESIDENT INTEL COME WE
ALL AGREE ON IN THE GOVERNMENT
THE GOVERNMENT UP FRONT. UP
FRONT CONSULTATION IS THE RIGHT
TOOL. HOWEVER AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT CURRENTLY LACKS DUE
PROCESS THERE'S NOT A LEGAL
REMEDY TO CHALLENGE THAT
DECISION A PRODUCT DOES NOT
FOLLOW FOR SB THIRTY FIVE
STREAMLINING DUE TO TRIBAL
CULTURAL. SB THIRTY FIVE
EXEMPTION ALL OF WHICH CAN BE
CHAO IN COURT FOR EXAMPLE OF
THE PROJECT TO DENY DUE TO THE-
OF WHAT ARE HAVE HAVE. BUT
THERE IS EVERY THAT THERE IS NO
WAY OR- HAVE A HM SETTING. WE
ARE AT FOR THE SAME REMEDY HERE.
THIS CAN FIXED BY THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
JUDICIAL CHALLENGE THANK
GOODNESS I DON'T POLITICAL
RESOURCES. PROCESS CAN BE
PROTECT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH. OKAY WE'LL LOG TO ANY OF.
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. AND AGAIN AS A REMINDER.
PLEASE SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION IF ANY- AND THE
FACT OF YOUR OPPOSITION TO. NO
ONE IN THE GET. SO WE'LL MOVE
TO ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY ONE OUT OF THE
LINES HI YOU MAY- QUEUE UP-
FURTHER THIS PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE NOT
POSITION OF AB ONE SIX STATE
POLICE PLAZA. ONE ZERO. WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF CUTE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO THIRTY. THANK
YOU. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LUIS
MARIN K. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA MEET CALIFORNIA B.
IS IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN
ITS CURRENT FORM PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO EXPRESS RATHER A REAL
DESIRE THAT WE VERY MUCH WANT
TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE WE AGREED WITH
AND THE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND TRIBAL CONSULTATION
NEEDS TO BE A PART OF ANY
MATERIAL HOUSING GROUP. THANK
YOU THANKS FOR YOUR WORK. THANK
YOU. AND OUR NEXT WINE THE ONE
MICHAEL IN THE BENEFITS OF.
MANNER RESEARCH IS A KNOWN AS-
AND WE'RE WITH THE OPPOSITION
WITNESS COMMENTS THANK YOU. IN
OUR NEXT FINAL COME FROM THREE
FIFTY. ALIGN ITSELF. HE SIGHED
A LITTLE NINETY FROM THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
SHARE THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMMUNITY. BACKLINE WILL COME
FROM A THREE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JON STEWART OF
HIP AND HIS CO DEVELOPER OF-
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
IN SANTA ROSA. WE HAVE ALREADY
COME TO A TWELVE YEARS AGO WE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY TO DETERMINE
THAT WERE NO TRIBE CALLED.
RESOURCE ON THE SITE YOUR- THIS
IS EXACTLY WE WANTED TO AVOID
BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE TO HOLD YOU
BILL BECAUSE WE TAKE IT SLOWS
SB. THIRTY FIVE IT IS AND
THAT'S WHAT. ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
GRANT. AND THERE SHOULD SOME OF
GLOBAL REMITTANCE. KAREN ARE.
FINAL BE THREE SEVENTY ONE LINE
OF THE- WEARING A WHITE WITH A
CALIFORNIA ANSWER. LEAGUE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION BUT
WE A LETTER CONCERN THE LARGE
AND THAT IT THE EXTRA BY MR
GUNNING THANK YOU. THANK YOU D.
I KNOW CALLER WILL BE FROM THE
THREE OH ONE. YOUR LINE IS J.
PRICE BEAR HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
WE WANT SOMEONE THAT. THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT FINAL COME A THREE
FIFTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS JACK GARDNER WITH THE JOHN
STORE COMPANY REGRETFULLY
OPPOSE WITHOUT AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU. AGAIN AS A REMINDER HERE
IN OPPOSITION A BILL AB ONE SIX
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
IF YOU'RE NOT POSITION OF BILL
AB ONE SIX EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT MISTER. AT
LIMA COMPANY THREE FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE SIMPSONS
WAS MODELED GENERATION HOUSING-
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION BUT WE DO WANT TO
SHARE AT THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED
BY THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GROUPS ON THE STOCK. I DON'T
CALL COMING FROM THREE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AB ONE
SIX EIGHT PRESS ONE ZERO.
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE SIX EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
WHAT KIND OF OPPOSITION OF AB
ONE SIX EIGHT HE WAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE A LINE OF
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A SOME MUTE
THREE SEVENTY NINE. CAN I. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO IN
OPPOSITION OF BILL AB. ONE
pOPPOSITION OF BILL AB ONE SIX
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND THERE IS NOBODY IN Q.
MISTER CHAIR. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE MODERATOR- SO
WE WILL BRING IT BACK- TO THE
COMMITTEE- FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER LOCALES QUE. I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE EFFORTS IF YOU
MADE IT HERE AND THE CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT- REVENUE AND THE
CHAIR OF P. Q. AND ALL THE
STAFF VOTE. DUNDAS I GUESS
FIRST I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
HAVE DO THAT I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT. ON THE- WE FIND
OURSELVES ON THE PHILOSOPHY OF
EXEMPTING. PROJECTS FROM SICK
AND THE PROMISE OF SB THIRTY
FIVE WHICH I VOTED FOR TWO
YEARS AGO WE SAID THESE WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE INFILL EASY
BREEZY PROJECTS THAT WORSE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THAT WERE.
YOU KNOW WE HAD THE CATEGORIES
THAT WE ACCEPTED THINGS OUT AND
AS I'M LISTENING TO THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE OPPONENTS
AND THE PROPONENTS YOU KNOW WE
CAN WERE. THE WRONG STATE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE COMMITTED
AGAINST IT FOUR AMERICANS HAVE
COMMITTED AGAINST THE NATIVE
AMERICANS WHETHER IT GOES BACK
TO THE ORIGINAL TIME FOR WHEN
WE DRAFTED JUSTICE SEQUEL. WHEN
WE DRAFTED SYKORA WE ALL MADE
IT PROVO TRAVEL CULTURAL
RESOURCES AND THAT WAS FIXED IN
FIFTY TWO- PUT OUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GATTO. WE'RE CONFRONTED
WITH BUT DOES. TO A PROJECTS
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW WHICH
IS DIFFERENT FROM STREAMLINING
PROJECTS AND YOU KNOW THE
SENATE HAS TWO REPORTS HAVE
BEEN PRODUCED AT LEAST WHEN I
WAS CHAIR OF EQ ONE FROM OUR
OWN. INITIATION BOB CALL
COMMITTEE THAT PAINS REVIEW OF
PRIDE THE FINE OUT THAT REALLY
THE AND THE LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION IS TALKING ABOUT
REALLY YOU'RE NOT SEEK WORK
ORIENTED RATHER THEIR LOCAL
PLANNING ORGANISER THERE BUT
THERE'S A PHILOSOPHY THAT THAT
UNLESS WE EXEMPT EXEMPT THINGS
THAT THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THE
PROJECTS COULD BE DONE I THINK
THE BILL AND THE AUTHORED.
THAT'S WHEN HE MAKES A GOOD
POINT THAT THAT THIS WAS.
HOWEVER WE WANT TO CHARACTERIZE
IT IS SAID. SB THIRTY FIVE DID
NOT EMBRACE THE TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE AND THAT
SHOULDN'T BE AN EXCUSE TO FAST
TRACK THE PROJECTS ARE PLOT
EVERYBODY'S EFFORTS TO WORK ON
THE BILL TO TRY TO GET SOME
RESOLUTION BUT- THE- WITHOUT.
WITHOUT SEQUEL WE HAVE NO
POSSIBILITY FOR PUBLIC TO
COMMUNICATE YOU KNOW THERE ARE
SOME NON. VISIT COAL SOURCES IN.
D. IDEA IN THE D. THE IDEA
WE'VE EXEMPTS. THIS PROJECTS
FROM THE ROBUST DISCUSSION OF
THE ENVIRONMENT QUALITY ACT IN
CALIFORNIA IT SOMEHOW CREATES
AN ENTITLEMENT THAT THEY HAVE
THAT THAT THAT THE PEOPLE THE
DEVELOPERS WHO WANT TO DO IT
AND THAT SOMEHOW WE CORRECT
THAT MOVIE WE CORRECT BILLS ALL
THE TIME WE FEEL LIKE WE'VE
MADE A MISTAKE AND I'M
PARTICULARLY SENSITIVE. OF THE
TRIBAL LEADERS IN THE
PROPONENTS ARE SAYING YOU KNOW
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CULTURAL
LANDSCAPE TO THE EXTENT THAT
IT'S GEOGRAPHICALLY DEFINED IS
GOING TO BE BUT WE'VE DONE
SCREWED SO MANY WRONGS. SLEEPER
FOR ALTHOUGH I. VOTED FOR SB
THIRTY FIVE FIVE BUT I THINK
THAT PUBLIC PROCESS AND THAT.
THAT ROBUST DISCUSSION GOES ON
SO WITH WITH THAT HI I'M-
SOMEWHAT ANNOYED THAT THERE ARE
NO ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS THAT
HAVE SPOKEN ON THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS THIS IS WRAPPED UP WITH
WITH C. COOPER WITHOUT A MOVE
THE BILL AS IT IS AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S EFFORTS.
AND CENTER CLARIFY THAT IS A
MOTION TO SEND THE BILL TO THE
FLOOR. BECAUSE WE'RE A RULE
TWENTY NINE TEN. THE SPECIFIC
FOR SOME CENTER CHARACTERS MADE
A MOTION TO SEND AB ONE SIX IT
TO THE FLOOR. THAT IS A MOTION
ON THE TABLE. ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS CALL A.
S. SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MEASURE HI I ALWAYS LIKE TO IN
BUSINESS MAKE SURE THAT WE
AVOID SURPRISES AND SO- I JUST
WANNA ASK THE AUTHOR IF THERE
IS A YOU KNOW PRETTY GOOD
ROBUST THE LISTING OF. TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES THAT. YOU
KNOW AND HONEST PERSON WHO'S
PURCHASING LAND TO DEVELOP IS
NOT STEPPING INTO A SITUATION
THAT. EVEN GETS US TO THE POINT
THAT IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN FULLY
DISCLOSED AT THE TIME OF
ACQUISITION. SO I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THAT IS THE CASE I
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO LOOK UP
HISTORICAL LANDMARKS IN. STATE
SENATE A REASONABLY GOOD JOB OF
DEDICATING A LOT OF SITES IS
STATE HISTORICAL LANDMARKS FOR
A LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS. I
WOULD GO. TRAILER WE'VE GOT
BILL GRINDING SITES SOCIAL
MOUNTAINS BURIAL GROUNDS SACRED
SITES BUT- HOPEFULLY. WE HAVE A
GOOD INVENTORY SO THAT SOMEONE
DOESN'T EVEN FIND THEMSELVES.
VISITATION YES I'LL TURN OVER
THE ALL TOURNAMENT BUT I WAS
UPSET BECAUSE WE NOW HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS WITH US AND ABOUT
THIS AND SO IMPORTANT- THERE
ARE SEVERAL CATEGORIES THERE
ARE REGISTRIES. OF TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES FEDERAL
STATE OR TRIBAL REGISTRIES- AND
THESE ARE LISTS THOSE ARE ALL
CATEGORICALLY EXEMPT FROM SB
THIRTY FIVE UNDER SB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. AND I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE A DISAGREEMENT ABOUT FIVE
ON A REGISTER. OF THINGS
CHECKED OF VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
HOWEVER THERE ARE MANY TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES THAT ARE NOT
LISTED ON A REGISTRY AND THERE
ARE MANY. VERY VERY WHEN. WHY
NOT LISTED. ONE OF THOSE
REASONS. SIRWHAT DOES THE
CURRENT. AND IF YOU HAVE IT IS
ON A RED JUST. EVEN IF IT'S
THEIR PUBLIC COURTS SUPPOSED TO
POKE A PAUL. AND WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE EITHER INTENSELY OR
UNINTENTIONALLY ANNOYS PEOPLE
JUST WANT TO SEE SOMETHING AND
END UP DAMAGING AT. OR THE-
BECAUSE- YOUR. ON THE STRINGS.
AND SO IS THEY'RE ARE SOME
POWER REASONS WHY THEY ARE ALL
LISTED AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT I KNOW I'M
CONFIDENT WE WILL FIGURE OUT IN
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF
YOU WANT TO- COMMENT ON THAT I
WOULD LIKE LIKE TO MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE TRIBAL
CANNOT. TO RESPOND AS WELL- I
THINK YOU KNOW AS THE SENATOR
DID A GOOD JOB RUNNING
IDENTIFYING. WHAT THEY'RE WHERE
THEY ARE IN THE REGISTRY CIVIC
BUT I'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONS TO MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE THAT. SIR
THE STRAND OF A SQUEAL OF ONE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
THAT. OKAY YEAH. PRINCETON.
OKAY I'M SORRY APPARENTLY THEY
WERE MUTED BECAUSE THE
FEEDBACKS OF THE MODERATOR-
WHEN YOU I'M YOU MISS MARANDA.
YOUR OKAY HELLO YES WE. IT'S A
COMMON FACT THAT MEASURE
CHARLIE SIGNIFICANT PLACES ARE
NOT BROADCASTED TO THE WORLD-
LISTED AND LAST THEY ARE
THREATENED A HEART WRENCHING
HISTORY OF NON CREDENTIALED
ARCHAEOLOGIST HISTORIES AND
BANDELE THEY'RE DESTROYING
ARTIFACTS HAS CAUSED MANY TRIES
TO WITHHOLD INFORMATION FROM
LOCATION ABOUT PLACES UNTIL
THEY ARE ACTUALLY UNDER THREAT.
THERE'S ALSO THE ISSUE ABOUT
THE PLACES THAT IS HELD TIGHTLY
WITHIN THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY
SOMETIMES ONLY WITHIN CERTAIN
ELDERS ARE DESIGNATED SPIRITUAL
LEADERS THIS IS BECAUSE THE
POWERFUL NATURE THE PLACES
CULTURAL LIFE WAYS AND
PRACTICES THIS INFORMATION IS
NOT LOOSELY OR UNNECESSARILY
SHARED IT'S VERY CONFIDENTIAL
AND THIS IS BECAUSE THERE HAS
BEEN A LONG HISTORY. WILL BE
THREATENED PUNISHED AND EVEN
KILL FOR PRACTICING OUR LIFE
PLEASE AND REAL. THIS TYPE OF
JUDGMENT AND SCRUTINY
UNFORTUNATELY STILL OCCURS
INSTITUTIONALIZED FORMS AND
THIS TRIED TRAUMA AND
SEGMENTATION OF TRIBAL BELIEFS
DOES NOT CREATE AN ATMOSPHERE
OF TRIBES AND WANTING TO SHARE
THE INFORMATION AND- ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. THANK YOU MISTER
BROWN. SO THE INTERLOCK SOMEONE
OF CHOIRS A PIECE OF PROPERTY
AND STARTS TO PROCEED BY AND
GOES THROUGH THE STEPS OF. AB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT AND IF THERE IS
OPPOSITION BY A TRIBE THEN.
THAT ELIMINATES THE OPTION OF
THE STREAMLINING SO I'M.
DEFENDER MARLON I'M CURIOUS
MISTER SURE HOW WE RESOLVED
THIS. ISSUE MOST OF US ARE JUST
TRYING TO. THANK YOU RECORD OUT
THERE WE'RE WE'RE WORKING
REALLY REALLY HARD TO RESOLVE
THE AND I'LL MAKE SOME MORE
COMMENTS ABOUT THAT- AFTER
OTHER MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTED
TOPIC THAT IS AN ISSUE WE'RE
VERY FOCUSED ON- WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TO RESOLVE.
MORE THAN I WILL JUST PATIENTLY
WAIT THANK YOU MISTER JENKINS
FRAZIER BUSINESS ON CHECK IN MY
MEMORY SOMEONE IS CONTINUE SHE
HAD ASSEMBLY TO COMMENT YES
ABOUT THE THIS GROUND THOUGH IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO- THINKING I
MAKE IN ADDITION. HI AT. AND
THIS IS LAURA MARIA AND GUIDED
THE PER SE THREE FOR TRIBAL
INVOLVED. AND THE TRIBAL
SCOPING CONSULTATION THAT IS
CREATED BECAUSE- THERE CAN
THEY'RE AND NOT AS A WAY TO
IDENTIFY. IF THERE ARE TRIBAL
RESOURCES ON ON THE PROPERTY
AND WHAT THEY ARE AND HOW
SIGNIFICANT THEY MIGHT BE SO
THAT IS ALREADY IN ONE SIXTY
EIGHT AT THIS TIME AND IS THE
SOLE PURPOSE OF WHY. THE
DEVELOPING CONSULTATION WAS
PLACED INTO THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER MILLER ON ANY
ADDITIONAL. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON YOUR DATA CENTER
BATES AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
CENTER THERE ALSO OKAY SO I'M
JUST A CLARIFICATION BECAUSE
THE MOTION THAT AS MADE BY OUR
SENATOR Y. KASKI IS TO MOVE IT
TO THE FULL. COULD YOU EXT
PROCESS SINCE I THINK MOST OF
US CAN SAY MOST OF THE LOBBY IN
PARTICULAR WAITING TO HEAR SOME
RESOLUTION ON UNDER APPEAL
PROCESS OF SOME FASHION YEAH
AND I I'M ASSUMING THAT'S WAS
GOING TO BE WORKED ON. YEAH
CENTER BATES- SO BECAUSE THIS
BILL- THIS HAS BEEN REFERRED TO
THIS COMMITTEEUNDER SENATE
RULE TWENTY NINE TEN- BE
BECAUSE IT WAS PREVIOUSLY ON
THE FLOOR WENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS IS COMMITTEE PASTOR
WITH MY SUPPORT. LAST YEAR
WONDER GOING FINANCE- AND THEN
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATIONS.
COMMITTEE MAYBE EVEN YOU TO AS
WELL I CAN'T REMEMBER CENTER A
LOT OF COMMITTEES AND- IT WAS
ON THE FLOOR AND THEN THE
AUTHOR OF WHICH IS HER
PROVOCATIVE. MADE SUBSTANTIAL
AMENDMENTS ON THE FLOOR IT
BECAME A TO YOUR BILL IT WAS
REFERRED BACK UNDER RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN B. THAT MEANS THAT. WE
CANNOT AMEND THE BILL IN
COMMITTEE WE CAN OBTAIN
AGREEMENTS TO AMENDED ON THE
FLOOR. IT ALSO DOES NOT HAVE TO
RISK. RELATIONS COMMITTEE SO
OUR OPTIONS TODAY ARE TO HOLD
THANK YOU PASS IT TO THE FLOOR.
AS I WILL STATE AT THE END. ALL
THE MOTION WHAT THE THAT SO
MEMBER I RECORD CENTER MCGUIRE
AND I ARE GOING TO SPEND ENERGY
PARTNERS ARE GOING TO WORK IN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS- AND I'M
JUST AND I'M CONFIDENT HOW TO
BUILD OVERALL GONNA RALLY AND
GET BEHIND TO GET PAST HI YES
THE ISSUE OF LEGAL RECOURSE IS
I WILL BE SHORTLY IS ONE THAT
IS ON MY MIND- AND IT'S ONE
THAT- I BELIEVE WE WILL BE ABLE
TO RESOLVE. PRESIDENT OF THE
BUS SENATOR. THE DID GO THROUGH
HERE. OKAY MMHM SENATORS ARE
ALSO. I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF THE SENATE MCGUIRE AND
THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY I LOVE THESE WORDS
A MISTAKE SHOULD NOT DEFINE AS
HOW WE WORK TO FIX IT DOES AND-
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH I LOOK
FORWARD TO VOTING FOR THIS ON
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU CENTER BY
SENATOR ROTH. JUST OF THE
COMMENTED A QUESTION CHAIR YOU
KNOW I'VE- I. BELIEVE I ASK A
QUESTION I'M NOT SURE I HAVE AN
ANSWER YET THE BILL UTILIZES
THE TERM POTENTIAL TROUBLE
CULTURAL RESOURCE AND FOR
EXAMPLE ND- REMEMBER WHAT.
SUBSECTION THIS IS IT'S- FOR
SECTION SEES SO IT'S IS IT IF
BURKE PERMISSION TO REACH THE
BILL MISTER. AFTER THE SCOPING
CONSUL THE PARTY'S FINE TODAY
POTENTIAL TROUBLE CULTURAL
RESEARCH RESOURCE COULD BE
AFFECTED BY THE PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENT. AND ENFORCEABLE
AGREEMENT IS NOT DOCUMENTED
BETWEEN THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBE IN THE LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT REGARDING METHODS A
TUTOR TO RETURN OF THE
DEVELOPMENT SHALL NOT BE
ELIGIBLE. FOR THE STREAMLINED
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL PROCESS
THIS IS MY QUESTION I GUESS IS
THIS WHAT WHAT THE POTENTIAL
TROUBLE CULTURAL RESOURCE IS
NOT DEFINED. AS THAT MEAN WE
THINK THERE IS ONE. WE'RE
SPECULATING THAT THERE'S ONE OR
THAT THERE IS A TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCE THAT COULD BE
AFFECTED. AND THAT'S WHY. THE
ACTION IS NOT TAKEN OR THE
ACTIONS TAKEN. I WOULD PASSED
THE GIVE THE AUTHOR BRAXTON'S
BROWN THE TO. ON TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION I WOULD LIKE COULD YOU
POINT OF CLARIFICATION ON THAT
PLEASE. WHAT I LIKE TO CLARIFY.
OKAY YES. AROUND THE I'M SORRY
TO KEEP. PUTTING YOU BACK IN
BUT YOUR EXCELLENT ANSWER
QUESTION SO IF YOU COULD-
PROCESSED CENTER QUESTION.
HELLO YES WE HEAR. SO NORMALLY
DURING THE CONSUL PROCESS THE
GOAL IS TO FIND OUT WHAT
ATTENTION OF CULTURAL RESOURCES
AND CULTURAL RESOURCES EXISTING
AND POTENTIAL IS ABOUT.
IDENTIFYING CERTAIN FACTORS
THAT MAY INDICATE A RESOURCE
UNDERGROUND A LOT OF THESE
RESOURCES ARE NOT CLEARLY
VISIBLE WHEN YOU ARE FIRST
LOOKING AT DOING CERTAIN TEST
EXCAVATIONS OR WHATNOT AND
SOMETIMES ONLY A PARTIAL CAN BE
IDENTIFIED AND- SO IT'S TAGGING
THAT THERE'S THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THERE IS A CULTURAL
RESOURCE WE MAY NOT KNOW THE
FULL EXTENT OF IT BUT WE'RE
GOING TO AN AGREEMENT. TO
CONCEPTS TERMS TO ADDRESS BOTH
THE ACTUAL RESTORED AND WHAT
MIGHT POTENTIALLY COME UP LIKE
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE TERRIBLE
MONITORS DURING GRADING BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW THEY'RE STILL.
MAYBE THINGS ON THE GROUND.
THANK YOU MISTER. OKAY ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY SEEING NINE- I'M
GOING TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
BUT I DO JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
ARE THERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS OR SEVERAL BECAUSE AND
I MEAN SOME OF THEM THE AUTHORS
AGREE TO SOME SHE HAS NOT
AGREED TO THOSE ONE WHERE
THERE'S AN AGREEMENT CONCEPT OF
WE'RE GONNA WORK OUT- SOME OF
THE DETAILS. FOR THE PROCESS
SO- COLLEAGUES AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. IS AN EXCEPTIONALLY
IMPORTANT BILL. I'M FRANKLY
THAT'S WHY. WE'VE TAKEN AS MUCH
TIME AS A TAKEN OVER THE LAST
YEAR. TO WORK ON IT IF THIS
WERE NOT. A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BILL. IN TERMS OF
WHAT IT PER TAX- WE WOULD NOT
HAVE TAKEN. THAT AMOUNT OF
TIME. AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT
MY HOUSING COMMITTEE SUFFERS
FROM MORE TIME OVER THE LAST
YEAR ON THIS BUILDING OR ANY
OTHER BILLS. AND THAT'S
APPROPRIATE. THIS MATTER IS.
PROTECTING TRIBAL RESOURCES
MUST BE A HIGH PRIORITY. AND WE
NEED TO GET IT RIGHT. AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT IS A LANDMARK BILL.
BECAUSE SB THIRTY FIVE IS NOT
THE ONLY STREAMLINING BILL.
THIS IS A LANDMARK IMPORTANT
PRESIDENTIAL CRITICAL BILL. IT
HAS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT GOAL
OF PROTECTING TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES SO MANY OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED. SB THIRTY FIVE
WHICH OF COURSE AS HE WON SIXTY
EIGHT AMENDS IS A LANDMARK
HOUSING LOSS SET IS CURRENTLY
AS WE SPEAK STREAMLINING
APPROVAL OF MANY THOUSANDS OF
UNITS OF HOUSING MANY HOMES.
OVERWHELMINGLY HOUSING THAT IS
AFFORDABLE TO LOW INCOME PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING IN MY HOME CITY
SEVERAL THOUSAND ALONE SYSTEM
ONE CITY. AND INCLUDING IN
CITIES THAT HAVE NEVER BEFORE
ALLOW LOW INCOME HOUSING TO BE
BUILT. IN THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
TOPPING BECAUSE OF SB THIRTY
FIVE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT. TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR BOTH UNBELIEVABLY
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES. TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES REFLECT THE
CULTURE BUT PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCED GENOCIDE AT THE
HANDS OF COLONIZERS AND WE NEED
TO CALL THIS FOR WHAT IT IS
GENOCIDE EXTERMINATION. AT THE
HANDS O COLONIZERS COLONIZERS
WHO ATTEMPTED TO A RACE AND-
GLITTERY THEIR CULTURE ENTIRELY.
CALIFORNIA HAS EMBRACED
PROTECTION OF THESE CULTURAL
RESOURCES THERE'S MORE WORK TO
DO NO DOUBT ABOUT IT BUT WE
KNOW THAT IS A PRIORITY FOR
STATE. AND AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
IS AN ADDITIONAL STRONG STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION. IN ADDITION
CALIFORNIA FACES A DRAMATIC AND
DESTRUCTIVE HOUSING CRISIS DUE
IN PART. TO HELP LONG IT TAKES
TO GET HOUSING APPROVED TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS. TO GET HOUSING APPROVED.
WE'RE SHORT MILLIONS OF HOMES
IN CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY FOR
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS. TWO TWO
ARE SEVERE HOUSING SHORTAGE
PEOPLE ARE BEING DISPLACED. FOR
BEING PUSHED INTO POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS. PEOPLE ARE LIVING
IN INTENSELY OVERCROWDED
CONDITIONS WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
SEEING CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
BEING SO HORRIBLY IMPACTED BY
COVERT NINETEEN RIGHT NOW
PEOPLE ARE BEING FORCED TO LIVE
HOURS FROM WHERE THEY WORK SO
THAT THEY HAVE TO SPEND FOUR
HOURS A DAY IN A CAR. GETTING
DIABETES HEART IN A BOX NOT
SEEING THEIR CHILDREN
DESTROYING THE ENVIRONMENT.
PEOPLE ARE BEING FORCED TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA ENTIRELY.
CALIFORNIA HAS 13% OF THE
NATION'S POPULATION YET WE HAVE
TWENTY 5% OF THE NATION'S
HOMELESS AND 53% OF THE
NATION'S UNSHELTERED HOMELESS
THAT IS A MORAL FAILURE IN
EXTREME. AND THE DESTRUCTION OF
TRIBAL CULTURAL RESOURCES IT IS
A MORAL FAILURE IN THE EXTREME.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY WITH AB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT TO SHOW WHAT IS
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR. THAT TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES AND HOUSING
ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE IT
SHOULD NOT BE PITTED AGAINST
ONE ANOTHER THESE ARE TOO HIGH
HIGH PRIORITIES. THAT WE CAN
ADVANCE BOTH. AND WE CAN HAVE A
BRIGHT FUTURE FOR HOUSING AND
WE CAN EMBRACE AND PRESERVE THE
CULTURE THAT REMAINS AND THE
RESOURCES THAT REMAIN FOR OUR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. WHEN I
SB THIRTY FIVE HAS BEEN
SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
PROCESS OF SB THIRTY FIVE I WAS
THE AUTHOR OF THAT BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT WAS ONE
OF THE CENTERPIECES OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. LEGISLATIVE
HOUSING PACKAGE THE GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNED. THAT BILL. EVERY
I'VE ALL I'VE INTRODUCED FORTY
PIECES OF LEGISLATION SINCE I
HAVE BEEN A MEMBER OF THIS
HOUSE TO LEGISLATIVE SOCCER
SEASON EIGHTY EIGHTY PIECES OF
LEGISLATION TO LEGISLATIVE
CYCLES NO LEGISLATION THAT I
HAVE AUTHORED HAS RECEIVED MORE
TECHNICAL AND LEGAL SCRUTINY
AND SENATE BILL THIRTY FIVE HE
WAS INTENSIVELY SCRUTINISED BY
SIX DIFFERENT COMMITTEES
INCLUDING THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY SENATOR
ABOUT THE SENATE THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE THE APPROPRIATIONS
LARA. THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY SOMEONE TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
CHAIRED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR CURRY THE SENATE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY THE RUNNER
GONZALEZ COMMITTEES WITH STRONG
CHAIRS. WITH BRILLIANT STAFF.
AND NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THESE
CAN. IDENTIFIED THIS SHOULD BE
AN ADDITIONAL EXEMPTION THAT
WAS AN INSTITUTIONAL FAILINGS
COLLECTIVE FAILURE BY ALL OF US
AND I AGREE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THAT WE HAVE TO OWN
THAT. AND WE HAVE TO FIX IT I
WILL ALSO SAY THAT ARE NOT BILL
MANY MANY MANY ADVOCATES
LOBBYISTS APPROACH US. WITH
FEEDBACK AND IDEAS THE BILL.
NOT A SINGLE LOBBYIST CAME
FORWARD AND SAID HEY YOU MISSED
PUTTING. TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES AND AS AN EXEMPTION.
AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF
LOBBYISTS IN THIS COMMUNITY WHO
FOCUS ON THAT IS NOT A SINGLE
ONE APPEARS TO HAVE CAUGHT IT
THIS WAS A COLLECTIVE FAILURE.
AND WE MUST FIX IT. AS I
MENTIONED SB THIRTY FIVE.
FRANKLY SHOULD BE SINGLED OUT
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF THIS
BILL. BUT THIS ISN'T AS SB
THIRTY FIVE WE HAVE MANY
STREAMLINING BILL'S GOING BACK
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN
THIS BUILDING. I THINK.
STREAMLINING BILLS THAT TAKE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PROJECTS OUT
OF SEQUENCE. WE HAVE
STREAMLINING LAWS. THAT HAVE
REMOVED SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
FROM SEQUENCE STREAMLINING LAWS
THAT ARE REMOVED HOMELESS
SHELTERS FOR NAVIGATION CENTERS
FROM SEACROFT. AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH THIS IS A BROADER. ISSUE
IT'S NOT ABOUT ONE BILL. I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER
SPONSORS FOR WORKING. WITH THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE WORK TO DO
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED. THE WAY
THE BILL IS STRUCTURED NOW.
THERE IS NO LEGAL RECOURSE IF
SOMEONE DISAGREES WITH THE
DECISION. THERE IS NINE. WITH
EVERY OTHER SB THIRTY FIVE
EXEMPTS AND THERE IS LEGAL
RECOURSE IF THE CITY DECIDES
THAT THIS IS A HISTORIC
RESOURCE FOR ITS ON A CERTAIN
FLOOD MAP AND YOU DISAGREE YOU
CAN SET UP A LEGAL REMEDY. TO
CONTEST THAT. BUT NINE IN
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT. THAT IS
THE ISSUE THAT WE ARE WORKING
FOR. IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THE
CIVIL COURT SYSTEM I KNOW. THAT
THE TRIBES HAVE VERY WELL EARNS
TO SUSPICION. THE CIVIL COURT
SYSTEM AND I'M NOT BEEN TREATED
THE WAY THAT THEY SHOULD BE AND
OUR CIVIL COURTS. AND SO WE
NEED TO BE CREATIVE. ABOUT HOW
WE GET TO A SYSTEM WHERE THERE
IS SOME SORT OF RECOURSE IF
SOMEONE BELIEVES THE LAW HAS
BEEN VIOLATED. THAT IS SO
FUNDAMENTAL. TO OUR LAWS AND TO
BASIC FAIRNESS THAT IF YOU
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A LEGAL
ENTITLEMENT AND HAS BEEN
VIOLATED. IF YOU BELIEVE THAT
YOU MAY BE WRONG. BUT IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF LEGAL RECOURSE. I
DO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HER SPONSORS. FOR DEVOTING
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF TIME.
MISTER AND I MISS COYLE WERE
TWO OF THE- HAREDI GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE WE'VE BEEN
MEETING FOR A YEAR WORKING
TOGETHER BUT THERE ARE OTHERS
AS WELL AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THEM. FOR PUTTING SO MUCH
ENERGY INTO THIS SOMEWHAT FOR
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE. I
WANT TO PARTICULARLY THANK
HOUSING SOUTH. OF FOR PUTTING
ENDLESS HOURS AND- TO WORK ON
THIS DAY- HAVE DONE AN AMAZING
JOB. AS I SAID. THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY POOR BILL IT HAS TO
HAPPEN WE HAVE TO GET IT RIGHT.
I WILL SUPPORT- THE MOTION
TODAY TO MOVE THIS BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WILL WORK
OVER THE NEXT TWO WEEKS TO FIND
AN AGREEABLE SOLUTION- RELATING
TO THE RE OF THE PARTIES. ARE
IN AGREEMENT. ADELE THE TRY
CULTURAL RESOURCE
DETERMINATION. SO I'M ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY ON CENTER
Y. CALYCES MOTION. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING IN THE
COMING WEEKS WHAT THE AUTHOR.
CENTER MCGUIRE WITH THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS. AND THIS
BILL WILL NOT BE TAKEN UP ON
THE SENATE FLOOR. UNLESS WE
HAVE. A CONSENSUS AMONG MYSELF
CENTER MCGUIRE OF THE AUTHOR.
AND OUR TRIBAL PARTNERS A
CONSENSUS WHICH I AM CONFIDENT
THAT WE WILL REACH. WE WILL
PASS AN EXCELLENT. THE BILL TO
PROTECT THESE RESOURCES. SO
WITH THAT I AM RECOMMENDING. HI
VOTES- AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M
VERY CURRY- ASKS FOR IT YOUR
WELCOME TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I'VE HAD IN
THE- DISCUSS REGARDING L. A.
ONE. EIGHT SECOND YEARS AND- I
FIRST WANT TO THANK ALISON OF
YOUR STAFF WHO'S BEEN
RELENTLESS ON THIS AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE TIME AND
EFFORT SHE'S PUT IN THIS AS
WELL AS YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THEN OF COURSE I WANT TO
THANK MY SPONSORS WHO HAVE BEEN
BY MY SIDE- ALL ALONG AS WELL
AS MINE. MY STAFF THAT HAVE
SPENT HOURS AND- OUR
FRUSTRATIONS BUT WE'RE HERE AND
WE'RE HAPPY THAT YOU'RE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY. ALL
SIDES HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY ON
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS PAST
MONTHS. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
CHAIR AND CENTER MCGUIRE. I'M
WILLING TO COMMIT MORE TIME TO
DISCUSSION OF ALTERNATIVES ON
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IN THE END
AGREEMENT CANNOT BE REACHED
AFTER A SCOPING CONSULTATION.
UNDER AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
ALTHOUGH THE IS COMPREHENSIVE
AND REFLECTS ALMOST TWO YEARS
OF STAKEHOLDERS WORK WE MUST
ENGAGE WITH TRIBAL LEADERS AND
OUR TRIBAL COALITION TO
DISCUSS. POTENTIAL OPTIONS. IN
ORDER TO ALLOW THE TIME TO
EXPLORE THESE OPTIONS I'M
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
AND I WILL COMMIT TO YOU TO DO
EVERYTHING Y POWER TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN CHAIRPERSON.
WIENER SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
MYSELF IN PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
IN THE END I HOPE YOU WILL
AGREE THE PROTECTION OF
INDIGENOUS CULTURE RESOURCES.
THIS IS NOT A REGULAR BILL
SENATORS IT'S A MATTER OF
CHOICE BETWEEN MORAL IMPERATIVE
TO RECOGNIZE THE CIVIL RIGHTS
OF OUR SISTER SOVEREIGN TRIBAL
NATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SOMEONE NUMBER SENATE MCGUIRE
BRISTER MIKE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCHER AND I'LL BE VERY
BRIEF YOU KNOW THAT. YOU THE
SIM THE WOMAN IN THE COMMITTEE
HAS HAD A LONG DAY MISTER CHAIR
I JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
INCREDIBLE WORK BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY. OVER THE
PAST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS AND I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR DEEP
INSINCERE ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
ISSUE MISTER CHAIR IN THE END
IN MY OPINION- I DO HOPE. THAT
A DEAL CAN BE REACHED IN
CANDIDLY I BELIEVE WE'RE NOT
THAT FAR OFF SO I'M FEELING
GOOD ABOUT THAT. I KNOW ALL
SIDES ALL SIDES ARE GONNA WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TOGETHER IT'LL
TELL ME ALTERNATELY IN THE BILL
THAT MOVES ON THE SENATE FLOOR
WILL NEED TO HAVE A CHAIR
WIENER CINNAMON AGUIAR-CURRY
MYSELF AND SPECIALLY OUR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS ALL IN
AGREEMENT AND AGAIN. I DO NOT
BELIEVE WE'RE THAT FAR OFF AND
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING THIS
DONE IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND TAKE
YOU TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN. THANK
YOU CENTER. THANK YOU SENATE
MCGUIRE. OKAY HAVING INCLUDED
AND AUTHOR HAVING- SIMILAR HER
CLOTHES- WITH THE MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE T.
TO SEND AB ONE SIXTY TO THE
SENATE FLOOR I AM RECOMMENDING
AND I'D VOTES ON THAT MOTION.
AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION IS THAT
THE BILL BE RETURNED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR CONSIDERATION.
SENATOR WINNER HI WIENER AYE
MORRELL. BATES HI BATES I
CABALLERO HI. I TO ROSA.
TORONTO HI MCGUIRE. HI MCGUIRE
HI MORE A LOT MORE LOOK HI ROTH
NAY ROTH SKINNER. SKINNER I
BURKE NUMBER WE CAN SKATE BY
WOOD COUNTY I TEND ZERO FIVE
TEN ZERO AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT CENTER MORALES- IT'S
NOT RETURNING THAT'S OKAY SO
THE VOTERS TEN NOTHING- THAT
BILL IS OUT AND RETURN TO THE
SENATE FLOOR I THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR ISSUED ALL OF YOUR HELP
ON THIS. THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE
NOW GOING TO OPEN THE RULES ON
OUR OTHER ITEMS OF WHERE
MEMBERS WERE NOT PRESENT FOR.
VOTES SO WE'LL DO THAT- IN
ORDER- STARTING. NUMBER TWO- AB
ONE AB SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING- WE PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. AB SIXTY NINE BY
FAMILY MEMBER CHIANG THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
MCGUIRE. HI MCGUIRE AYE NUMBER
NUMBER HI. TO IT TO ONE OF THE
VOTERS EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY SIXTY
NINE AS ADULTS- WILL NEXT GO TO
ITEM NUMBER. THREE EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY FOUR BY SOME OF OUR
DAILY. THIS IS A FAMILY MEMBER
FOR THIRTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATE MCGUIRE RIGHT. MCGUIRE
HI NUMBER NUMBER ELEVEN HOURS
AGO TO DELIVER NOTHING EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTY FOUR IS OUT- WILL
EXTRADITE HIM FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WORKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE SORRY ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I CAN SPEAK FOR CASKEY I.
EIGHT TO THREE THE THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE IS OUT. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR REQUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE NUMBER. HI NUMBER
FIVE WITH CASKEY HI WHAT KASKY
BY. TEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT
EXTRA TIME WE WILL NEXT GO TO
ITEM- OKAY NOW GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEM
SEVEN TEN AND ELEVEN SENATOR
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WOULD CAL SKI WITH
HUSKY BY ELEVEN ZERO. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED.
WE WILL NEXT GO TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS FOR
THE REQUIRE HI MCGUIRE HI
NUMBER FIVE NUMBER I. COPYRIGHT
NOT THE TO A. EIGHT TWO ZERO
OKAY- THAT BILL IS OUT WE'LL GO
TO ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
FOUR OH FIVE- WILL OPEN THE
ROLE AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI. HI. EIGHT TO THREE. THE
BILL IS ALEX WE WILL NOW GO TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB THIRTY
FORTY FIVE SEVEN NUMBER TWO.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FORTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATE MCGUIRE HI REQUIRED BY.
NINE TO. THE BILL IS OUT WILL
NEXT GO TO ITEM FOURTEEN AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANK. A. B.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING THE MOTION
IS TO PASS CABALLERO. NOT FORTY
CABALLERO NOT VOTING MCGUIRE
RIGHT MCGUIRE AYE NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER FIVE EIGHT TWO. THE BILL
IS OUT I WILL NEXT GO TO ITEM
FIFTEEN AB THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TWO AND WILL
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CABALLERO VOTING. I'M NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE HI
SEVEN TO THREE. IT UP BILLS
OUTSTANDING FINALLY WILL GO TO
ITEM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THIRTY
THREE OH EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE SB THIRTY THREE
OH EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATOR BATES. PAGE NOT LOADING.
AND SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE
HI BATES IT'S NOT LETTING TO
KNOW. THAT'S NINETY TWO OKAY
AND THAT BILL IS OUT HI TO THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT HAVE WE KNOW
COVERED ALL THE BILLS YES OKAY
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR-
PERSEVERING FOR THIS LONG HI
HEARING- AND THANK EVERYONE FOR
I THINK HAVING A REALLY STRONG
DAY FOR HOUSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA